All right. Three, two, one, go. Hope I'm on the right filter. Listen, if we have anything like we did for the Pv2 patch where there's just no gem information, I'm going to blow up. Salute soldiers. How we doing today? Glad I'm doing three streams. Definitely the second stream of the day. Yeah, I was like six hours late to stream earlier because I was doing uh I was studying and then I had dinner so I couldn't continue the ride. Is there a replacement for rolling magma? You can
use freezing pulse and frost bomb. That's fine. It's not great. Studying for what? Studying the speedun. I was looking at my VOD and I was like, where am I losing time? Bam. Bam. I just saw this Also the chest. Actually, I like the chest. It'll make me alive during mud fights. That's good. [Music] Okay, three of those. I'll buy an iron ring. Every iron ring costs an alteration. You got to be out of your mind, dude. What? What is that, dude? Every one of them is an alter. Okay, dude. All right. Hey, no three
link, no three green. Hey, it is what it is. Oh, I like that quite a lot though. Those are good colors. Terrace, bro. No way. They put tariffs in my Path of Exile. You could also run Orbtorm Storm Blast mine, but a lot of people really dislike that build. So, not bad. No, no, no. We're going to We're going to play it out. We're going to play out the worst case scenario. How about that? I'm going to play it out and if we get under 20 minutes, then I'm the goat. How about that? That sound
good? No iron ring. Galvonic arrow. Yep. It doesn't matter that we don't have a three link here. We just need it by uh by the time we complete Tidal Island. Then it's really nice to have. Let's equip this. I'm going to try going top right here. I see gloves. I want to grab those gloves. Can't tell a top right or a top left. I'm going to yolo. I'm guessing. I love guessing. What is that? Fire ignite resistant. I might as well not have a mob. Serated air quiver. That's really
nice. Any sort of flat damage is really, really good. The worms will have to wait a bit longer for this. Uh, I want this helm. I don't think I have a helm at the moment. Just getting more armor and evasion is always nice. It's the reason why I want something in every slot is cuz uh well, mud plots was going to ruin my life as you can see by the rose 12 seconds ago. Let's see. Was I right? I was very wrong. Okay. Yeah, I couldn't have been more wrong. All right, let's go left side
then. Unless I mean, no way. I was Yeah. Okay. No way. If it's actually top right and not left side like over here. That would be weird. But it'll show itself in three, two, one. There it is. Sorry. Check out the chest. I like this home. The stats on this home are a lot better, but I like the colors of that home. So, I really have that home. Will bows survive? bows will be buffed. What do you guys think? Actually, Havoc posting his level 20 Uber Elder kill might just be what gets them nerfed. I can't wait to see
it. Yeah. So, it turns out that bow builds were doing uber elder at level 20. So, we decided to nerf it. All right. Turn around. I see the ledge. I want to hit level four. Need him before hail, but we definitely need on hail rake. We have shield charge colors. So when I go back to town, I'm going to try to buy an iron ring again. I'm going to try to find a three link. We're going to grab the quicksilver mirage archer as quest rewards. We are going to absolutely grab uh shrapnoblista. And other than that,
you can buy frost blink and shield charge, but you don't need them right away. It's like fine to grab them later cuz we get primal spirit. Used to go aspect of the eel right away. I found that I didn't like doing that. Sometimes you just get to Brutus. Is it Brutus or is it a Yeah, it's it's Brutus. Sometimes you just get to the first boss in upper prison, whatever that guy's name is. I've I've done this a few times and you just don't have a mana flask and it sucks.
So, and I'm going to buy an iron ring. And I'm going to buy strain ballista and frost blink. And it's going to get a little weird. We need uh the mark. And then we also need to get the dash gem. There we go. So, we have snipers mark. That's the gem that I grabbed. Okay, we're going to go this way. And I'm going to throw on shrapnel ballista. And now we're looking for a bow. That's kind of the the goal at the moment is to look for a short bow since I was too poor to buy one off the vendor
earlier. Let's go and put that iron ring. Not forget. I don't really want this coral. Like I I need to do the crimson or I don't want to do it right now. Set that could be more flat damage. Could be things like life or resists. Obviously, I don't have any scrolls, so it's just going to stay in my bags like after a little while. There's a wisdom. Kind of want to save it. Save it for what, though? All idea. One to three fire damage. Beautiful. Let's hope this isn't a dead end. All
right, we're good. I'm going to stop. Generally speaking, for XP, we're almost always stopping for loot packs unless they're super tanky. I'm taking this chest just as a backup. Green. Green. We have Wait, is this actually one three? Wait, it's actually one route three. Wait, it's perfect. So, one of the biggest problems that we can run into in speedrunning, especially in POE 1, this isn't really prevalent in POV 2, but the biggest thing that can occur is, oh, I found an amazing bow,
but I can't equip it. Otherwise, I go down to a one link, a large mana flask. So, to prevent that problem, I'm taking this chest piece, and we're going to equip it soon. The reason why I'm not equipping it right now is because kind of nice. The reason I'm not equipping it now is because it reduces my movement speed by 3% to equip a chest. Two streams in one day. Yeah, I uh didn't have enough time to finish the run earlier cuz I had to go to dinner. So, I just decided to redo it. So, here
we are. Hope you guys can enjoy. I'm going to try to do mostly commentary throughout the uh the run. Feel free to ask any questions and hopefully I'll be able to answer them. I have the hiccups. Type something to scare me. Uh, I like this helm more than I like that home. Just better stats. We're not like pure vision base right now. Any advice on not dropping a transmute? If you don't drop a transmute, you just complain. That's usually what I do and it usually works out for me. What level am I right now? Six. All
right, we're going to put this man flask. Only man flasks we hate are like instant mana flask or like recover mana at end. Suck. You have to play D4 for three days straight. God, I hope not. Why not cat ears? Well, this isn't a Rutu stream, so you know, I'm learning language, but I'm not like a native like he is. U more important than momentum, I would say. So, let's go with that. Okay. Yeah, M is like an insane gem. Also, yeah, if you're struggling on transmutes, you need to pick up more
magic and rare items. unidentified items sell for transmute shards. I can almost guarantee you if you get zero transmutes by act two, it's because you were identifying every like rare item you came across. But there's going to be a lot of rare items you just don't need to ID. And you also won't have the scrolls to ID everything unless you're going particularly slow. Any plans on four stone? I might do one or two before the new league. I'm kind of keen for that. Give me that.
Okay, there we are. I don't have space for this purse, unfortunately. I want new boots, an alteration, a wisdom. I can't pick it up. I'll die. This is definitely worth stopping to kill because it's just so much mobs. It's so many mobs. It's a blue pack. Short bow. You'll love to see that. All right, there we go. And like I said, it's the exact situation I talked about just 5 seconds ago. I have a bow. It's an upgrade. Can't equip it because my links are somewhere else, but I can because you
know I have a two link. Cool. Let's going to equip that. Thank you. And that that'll be our first like essence item. I'm going to go and drop that. I'm going to drop that as well. All right. Under 9 minutes to prison. That's fine. Get ballistics. And a common mistake people make is they'll go through that portal and they'll instantly press a quick silver. This isn't like long enough for us to have time, you know, cuz this only lasts for what, 6 seconds? Yeah. Uh,
this layout and flooded depths, you're kind of just going wherever the layout opens up. We have an essence here. It's kind of already popped for us. It's a content. All right. Done. And I should be able to equip this gem. Oh, it's not popped for us. Sorry, never mind. I mean popped in terms of like these crabs. They have a phase one and then they turn into this phase two. I could have sworn I had the uh the arc to the phase two, but maybe if I was mistaken. I'm just going to go and sell that down. And then
I'm going to take this bow and I'm going to go and essence it. I should have technically waited to see what this was cuz this is like a hatred or something. I definitely want to use that on the bow. Any sort of flat elemental is really good on bows. And then we need to identify these boots cuz they could be move speed. Uh I'd rather have the one with green socket, I guess. Yeah, 10ms. And we can just sell the other one undead. This one I'm going to grab faster attacks. I'm going to go and
sell everything here. I'm going to go and grab a momentum support, a shield charge gem, and I forgot to sell the armor sprout. And I believe I already frost blink. It's fine. Book a skill. Let's find a threelink. We found a three-link bow. I'll take that. But I'm not super happy cuz I already crafted my bow. Yeah, I should have bought that. I already crafted my bow. So, uh yeah, I I I think I just leave this on the ground. Unfortunately, I already used one. And this is like going to be
triple the damage of the other bow. We can greed essence it, but that's kind of a waste. This bow has really good flat damage, so we're just going to keep it. Level eight gives us primal spirit. Maybe that switch to the all. Oh, I don't actually have a shield for shield charge. Oh, yeah, you do need one of those. That's what I was forgetting. That's going to go momentum and faster attacks. Then I guess in that case, I should have a blue gem that I save somewhere else. get to the
home. All right. And I want to remove dash if I can. Let's go grab a shield. This game is so good. Amen. Let's get a shield. Uh shield of some kind. I want one that's cheap. I kind of wanted a movement speed shield, but that's fine as well. I'm dying. Help. Relief is the Wisdom. Yeah, we're super poor at the moment, so I will gladly take those. And obviously, shield card is going to be way faster than just deep ball walking for me, especially on a three link like this. Chest
plate. All right, Lucy boots feels so good this early on. Happy to see that off dweller. And where are we going? This way. I would like to break some of these barrels. Barrels can have a lot of currency. Honestly, I found a lot of success with barrels early on. I'd like to find the quicksilver little strong box thing side area. I don't know what it's called. I'd love to find that. Don't think I'm going to. This should just be an inside loop. Is it an inside loop? Is it right
over here? Yeah, I don't know. All right. Uh I want a little bit XP. I'm down to kill this whole pack. Unfortunately, they added like those ineval mobs to the lower prison. It's just really annoying. of yourself. All good. I'm going to go and just take out the chest for a little bit so I can get my 3% movement speed back. You jeweler's orb is worth it. And we're going to go and just frost blink over the boss. Frost blink is amazing because it's an instant movement skill and then it also applies chill. So
we love frost bling back a bit. I don't have any more mana flash, so I do have to be a little careful here. Shallista doubles as like a damage gem and also applies chill. So it's really good in that way. Take all the rare items. Rare items are priority. We'll sell those. I just want transmut right now, I think. Let's go and sell everything here. Uh let's go and buy our LMP for later. And we can also buy mana forge arrows later on if we find anything. No other three link could fit on bows, which is
just kind of sad to see. Unlucky. Bub gun's favorite strategy. Didn't he hate that strategy? Sworthy was like complaining about it every day. Barrels were too OP. Uh, we only need one large mana flask cuz we're a ranger build and we just get all our mana back on hits. I want this guy to jump down. Thank you. I'm killing rare mobs at the moment. That's my second, not my third. Yeah, I'm killing rare mobs cuz I need a lot of XP. We absolutely need to hit level 12 by Merville otherwise like
I mean you could do it at level 11 but you really want to be level 12 these kind of classes that go like a level 12 skill. So things that require like I don't know a brand of some kind. I don't know any build that does brand anymore unfortunately. But what does require level 12? Peacock. Peacock requires level 12. So must the huntress. Yeah. I can't think of any others at the moment. Thunder. Yes, Sunder is huge. I'm sure there's other ones, but like rain of arrows or lightning arrow. Uh,
by the way, the choice that I made of going lightning arrow, that is just pure comfort. I think they're about the same. I think if you look at a lightning arrow run and a ren of arrows run, the only difference between the two will be which run had the better bow. Like, that'll be it. I don't think you'll find many other differences. And then Havoc feels kind of the same. Maybe you could learn from him. Who do you think Havoc learned from? Oh [ __ ] he's probably still in chat. I mean, I appreciate Havoc. Yeah,
I'm following his POV here. Let's go way point to town. Drum [Music] rarity. Dude, that's like when I was talking trash about Rutu and then he typed his patented question mark question mark question mark. You learn from Crrame. Whoa. Now, I actually learned from Dead and Doo. I thought speedrunning was stupid and I thought it was dumb. And then I didn't want to be slower than my friend. So, I unironically got I unironically started practicing speedrunning right before 3.0 because I
didn't want to be slower than my friend anymore. So, the only reason I started speedr runninging is out of pure spite, I got frozen and then I became one of the best speedr runners in the world. Anyways, thanks. Thanks, Chris. Appreciate that. It's cuz my friend who got me into the game, Chris, he uh he had laughed me and I was I opened my friends list to see where my friend was and he wasn't just like like I was in act two and he was in the same zone in act two and I didn't understand why he
was ascended and then I realized that he did a full lap around normal and he was actually in cruel. Let's go. Aspect of the angel here. That friend Chris Wilson. Yep, that's right. It's the real one. I like the shield. I'll go and take the shield. Let's get the skill point. That's a pretty all right time. Pretty happy with it. Lightning arrow. Give me that. We'll just sell everything again. I kind of like the helm. And I'm going to go mana forged arrows. Need a lot of sockets to
be able to make it work. But uh this is pretty okay. Well, I was going to say a pure evasion base at this point is pretty easy to chrome to be over the three green. Uh the problem is that it costs um two transmutes, so I can literally never do that. All right. Word. What's my XP? 11 and a half. Oh, we're chilling. We are so up. Unfortunately, I did not find the other quicksilver in act one. So, that does mean that I have to do the den this oral. Maybe actually maybe we'll save for the next
zone and level 10, please. And if you don't want to do this, weapon swap cringe technology. Uh, you don't have to, obviously. It's purely optional. I just do it because it's obviously going to be faster than walking gr. Okay, we're going for a sub six is the goal. A sub6h hour two stone. That's that's what I'm hoping for. Uh strong box. That'll kind of guarantee that we hit level 12. And we're going to go lightning arrow. And I guess just I guess we can't swap over to
lightning arrow for a while actually until I have a three lane. I didn't really think about that. If we're too linky a gaming, I don't think I can I don't think I can play. All right, we're going to have to rely on something else then. We're going to have to rely on something else happening. I'm going to die. Okay, we're good. Yeah, I'm going to need some sort of bib up. Uh, we found a green and hopefully they lands five damage or something. The reason I did the le
mechanic is cuz I Oh, it dropped a level 15 item. Holy. All right, we're going to go aspect of the links. And yeah, I guess I guess we just stay with this. I I don't know. I don't really have any other option. I guess I could go with two link lightning arrow. Let's drop Gonic for now. We'll use Mirage for the boss, but then we'll obviously swap over to LMP later. A whole lot of that. That over. Move that over. I want to equip this instead of that. you. Ow. I really need to play my mark on
this boss if I want the projectile to chain over to other mobs. Okay, there we go. Yeah, that was just really bad setup by me. I think I was more worried about my inventory than anything else. I like my helm cuz that has a red socket for later. I don't know why I always struggle getting an angel annoyed. Okay, fire arrow cover. That could be huge. Mville drops the first potential pair of 15 MS boots. Sub 19 I will definitely take even if it is on a two link. And yeah, I guess we just uh I guess we
just dropped the rod for LMP. I don't really have any other any other real thoughts. I'm going to go and drop that. I think and will I do this for potentially 15 MS which we did find. Okay, I will definitely take that. Thank you. I don't need the red socket anymore. All these I want to hold on to that for a bit. Okay. Uh, let's do the belts. I'd rather have flash charges gained for a little bit. Yeah, flash charges gained is actually a better stat than being alive. Oh, hey, there's my three link. Okay, now we have
a good run. Very cool. I'm going to go and skip some mobs while I look for this. Uh, we got Mirage. I think the side area for Den is going to be somewhere over here. Yeah, I found that. Thank you. I'll cook that. Probably cook this helm. Yeah, I mean you can equip a chest if you ever just feel uncomfortable. If I'm playing hardcore, I definitely equip a chest. I'll take 3% of my loss. We're going to sell that for a chrome item. I'm going to hold on to this rustic sash that actually has stats for a little
bit. I'm going to go ahead and spec over to attack speed here. I already did a crimson ore. It's the uh the one that I need. I believe if I ever encounter like a boss arena or some sort of boss that I have to kill, I will click an oral node. Sounds good to me. Is this a rare pack? I didn't notice. Oops. I'm going to skip that those stone golems cuz they have a lot of HP. Generally speaking, I'm pretty opposed to skipping magic packs. I guess I will stop and kill. I want to see these gloves. Are
they any good? I should have picked up the rare item. I'm trolling. I'm going back. Yeah, I'm doing it. So, this bow is amazing at level five, and it's going to it's going to rapidly fall off. That's kind of just the nature of these like kind of like melee or ranged builds is these builds tend to fall off very fast, very hard. So, I'm going to sell five of these cuz I want another scroll. And there we go. I'm going to do both of these max charges. That's very
nice. Okay, what does the crimson do for me? So, we need one crimson ore and we need one or calcium. Obviously, this will go away in 3.26, but I'm just doing a small amount of the league mechanic. The minimum that I need for the league mechanic so that I can unlock Foustus. Uh, if Foustus is locked behind some sort of league mechanic thing in the next patch, I will do the exact same. Uh, having the black market online readily prints lucky items. It gives me like good forlinks. It gives me good
bows. Uh, there is no world where you don't get the market online. That's why he's back. That's right. Oh, hey. I just did the side quest for quicksilver and then I dropped a quick silver 2 seconds later. Let's see who the essence is. It's an angel essence. It's kind of a big one, too. All right, I'm down. Did I do those gloves? Yeah, I did. They didn't have any plot damage, unfortunately. It's a little sad. I don't need more scrolls, do I? Oh, you don't. All
right, good explanation. Yeah, let me know if you have any other questions. Hopefully, I can answer. Brought back gold as a prank. Yeah, guys. I mean, surely they wouldn't do it with it. Don't tell Jonathan about this. Skip. Don't tell him. Do not tell him. He might think that we're having fun over here. There is a fine line between consideration and continuing on. JD. This will just give you more dexterity, which doesn't really matter, but it's accuracy, which might matter if a mob is
like, you know, super tricky. I don't know. He's undercover. Holy. Be careful. Bam. Bam. Bam. Bam. All right. All right, I need at least one alteration here. Let's see. What do we have? We have one. All right, that's good enough. Sell these. I just saw the gloves. I'm down for a hero device and a blood rage. Give me blood rage. Oh, other way around. I had a blood. There you go. Noob hero on campaign start. When do you know when you have to kill more mobs or when your level should be higher? Uh,
comes down to a lot of experience. The general rule of thumb is like early game it's like you want to be level eight by Brutus, level 12 by Murvale, um 14 or 15 by Fidilitis, 16 by Weber, 20 to 22 by uh V Omnitech Architect, whatever that guy's name is. Act three, you want to be 24 entering docks, 27 killing py, and at least 28 killing dominus. So those are just like the rough numbers. After that, you want to be at least like three levels below the zone. And every 16 levels, that number increases by one. So if you're in
a level uh the most important one is like the jump from level 31 to 32. Uh I need this Yeah, the biggest jump is level 31 to 32. And the reason for that is because not only do you move up one level, uh I like a bit more. Yeah, not only do you move up one level, but you also move up like that bracket by one level. And so you technically like are able to be two levels closer to the zone or further away without being penalized. And that zone is perfectly the uh the comb zone cuz those zones are like level 37 just
about. Um, I have a space for Herald Device. I guess I can drop like I believe like blink hero that's somewhere and I'm always looking for flat damage gloves. I'll hold on to that. I'm going to go and equip that. I will sell that. Whatever blinker is, that's a bow only gem. I really don't like if I'm ever going to weapon swap to put my aura in my uh in my weapons. Like I don't want to like swap over to shield and then have to reactivate arrow device every time. So I'm I just put it in piece like that.
I'm keeping the gloves. Everything else could get vendored. Uh I can keep those gloves if I want. We can also sell a trans. That's fine. Why is that? Why is what? Why do you want to be three? Oh, okay. Just cancel everything. Why do you want to be underleveled? Um cuz think about it like this. You could be super overleveled and you could be really strong or you could be in Chamber of Innocence 15 minutes faster and farming like an actually good zone. The attack speed. I'll just take
that. Like it's just about the opportunity cost of like would you rather skip all the questionably like really bad XP mobs or would you rather just be in maps 10 minutes faster? You know, the other XP requirements are just what I've gathered from years of playing. Give me these. We'll get precise techniques soon. Hopefully, we hit 18. How do you calculate the level? Uh, three levels under the zone and you add one every 16 levels that you are. So, like if you're level 32, you can be in a
level 37 zone with no penalty. If you're level 48, you can be in a level 54 zone with no penalty. Boom. And here's a little here's a little little addendum to that. That number technically is one off because you can be like an additional one under and you only get like a three or four% penalty. The problem is that if you tow that line and you're right at that XP penalty, you're going to get owned if you ever get like further than that. And I don't trust you guys to not get owned cuz I
don't trust myself to not get owned. Uh here's the best example of it. Docks. I always say be at least level 24. Well, the problem is that Docs is a level 29 zone. And if you're level 24 in docks, well, you can only be in a level 28 zone with no penalty. But the thing is is that if you're level 24 in a 29 zone, you're still going to get like 95% of the XP of the zone. So you're perfectly fine. And the zone also prints XP. So there's no way you don't walk away at level
25. Fine. Yeah. If you fall like beyond that algorithm, you are just going to get deleted. Uh no other no other word or phrase for it. Can sell that. I really hate instant manifest. So, we're pretty much never going to run those. Minus three levels isn't good for the noobs. Well, yeah, but I don't think the average like noob is watching a tie killer speedrun video, you know. Do I share my filter? Uh, you got to sit through the ad. Unfortunately, it cost $500. All you got to do is buy my course, then you got to
recommend it. It's not a pyramid scheme. It's just uh it's just you got to download the filter, then send it to three or your friends. Again, it's not a pyramid scheme. There's just a lot of people at the bottom and there's not a lot at the top. Well, technically there's me at the top. 3G bow, you say? Where's that at? Recurve bow. Give me that. Uh no, it's it's completely free. It's on my Discord. Mm. What am I doing, dude? I'm choking. There's too many items. Uh we could grab
or calm here. Let's Are the gloves good? They're 44 life, which actually kind of messes up our precise technique. I'm going to take that big angel essence. I'm going to slap it on the weapon. We're our damage going to go from 250 to 567. That's just how these uh attack builds go. She doubled our damage. All right, we're good. So, like probably about Dominus. I want to say the inverted triangle strategy. Yeah, sure. We could find 15 mess on that technically. Um I also want to sell
this so I get more scrolls cuz this jewelry could be good. What's the marauder skill progue? Uh, typically it's just like ground slam into sunder. You pretty much always use sunder, even if you're a righteous fire build. Uh, I pretty much go sunder till cruel lab. I think lotus goes till about 55. I don't know. So, you can switch off whenever you wanted to, but oak. Yeah. I mean, these guys are just going to get obliterated with my new bow. Oh, we have a thrilling bow, don't we? We do.
I don't remember switching off the gems. Uh, we can use mana forge arrows now if I have the space for it. I'm definitely going to drop this burning arrow though. Neither chance or wonderful. What did I put over here? Mirage archer LMP. Yeah, okay, that's fine. Al is always on the same side of the road as the waypoint and weaver is always on the opposite side of the road. You can kind of confirm this cuz there's no spiderw webs on these trees over here, but there's spider webs on the
other side and then there's always a passageway. All right, this is the first time and probably last time we talked to woman all week. Let's get our 15% all res and then we just run straight down. I'll curse this guy. I like getting a lot of XP. Leather bro could be good. Let's get precise tech. Oh, I never put in precise technique for the bosses. You know, that is kind of a blunder. Just missing 40% damage on every single boss that I fought. All right, not bad. Well done. Tight. Well
done. What about Clarissa? Um, yeah. I mean, I guess you have to talk to her, but I kind of just Bender Walker. Uh, what's on the rings? That's a lot of fire res, which I actually really enjoy for this upcoming zone. Ball ruins is kind of scary. It's not really the bane of my existence, but it's definitely one of my bins. All right. Yeah, I did kind of grief by not having precise technique in. That's kind of the whole point of me hitting level 18. I mean, I even called it out loud. jeweler strong box when
level 20 zones could have like a two stone ring for me. This going to be a lot of XP rare heavy belt some of these. Yeah, I'm not looking for a new bow cuz I mean I just made an insane bow. What's my XP at? We're level 19. That's perfectly fine. Like I said, you want to be at least level 20 by Vol soul. Anything over that is okay. If you're like 25 by soul. Okay, maybe you're killing a little too much, bud. Where's this layout taking me? Two stun ring. I'm going to grab that. Reason why I'm
grabbing that. It's really good to take Oh, I got owned. It's really good to take the uh jewelry that is usually good around this time, like two stone rings or just a pure resistor ring. Throw it at the upcoming uh vault corruption chamber. 3G armor. I like that chest a lot more than my current one. Where's that ring at? I see it. Three passive points, but not a way to spend all three passive points. And I found that just going uh okay, corrupt and we found a rare ring. I kind of don't like getting a bunch of stats
on a ring. What I find happens is that the ring will give me a ton of like strength and int and then I'll level up my gems and then I'll go to like Yeah, like let me not level up. Shield charge, please. Thank you. I'll go to level up my gems and then later on I'll take off the ring and like nine of my gems require that ring to be equipped. I don't know. It's just it's annoying. I'd rather just not deal with that. That is all the stats, so I'll take it. Ever had a dream you're celebrated
as a hero for speedrunning? Uh, no, but I've had a nightmare where I was on the world final stage and I dropped a tabulant and I got fourth place in the race. Thank god that would never happen, right? Saved. Let's go and hit the next level up so I can equip onslaught node. Hey, what are you guys laughing at? That's so funny. Focus up, guys. Uh, we could do oral. I do need to start pushing the town. It's about that time. Level 21. Yeah, it's about that time. Could do the ritual, but you're
pretty much never going to find anything worth the value of just being in a map sooner. Uh, I'm actually kind of a big fan of the pause. I think that pause is a really good feature that should be added to POE. I personally would really like a feature or an option to toggle it off. Um, okay. Let me go and equip this instead of that. I'd like to be able to turn it off because currently we currently don't have any sort of pause. Yo, crazy. Thanks a month. Appreciate that. Yeah. Yeah. So, every time you
open the passive tree in POE2, it just pauses the entire game, which is good for new players and it's good for like, you know, the average Joe. But I really enjoy how I can open the passive tree right now and press a different move only command and my character continues moving or, you know, the world just continues. Like, for example, on V over coming up, I'm going to put in my skill points and the world is going to keep on spinning. It is kind of annoying that it'll freeze. I'm not a huge fan of the
change considering that it's speedr runninging, but I think that it's good for the game. If it's a decision between adding it or between adding pause or leaving it out of the game for like the five people that care, they should obviously add it. I just want the ability to toggle it off. That's it. That's why I requested it. Luckily, when I asked Twitter um if GGG can add an option, like a toggle for the feature, they were all very normal. They were all very sane. They definitely did not
threaten my life or my family, and there were a bunch of very normal discussions going on in chat with no name calling or anything weird at all. All right. Ancient pyramid. You're always looking for the opposite corner in that layout. And then it's always going to get smaller because it's a pyramid. Pyramids get smaller at the top. I'm going sell that. Sell this. I don't even know why I got the decoy totem. I'm dropping that. Moving that over. Was this any good? It's less
duration, which we never want. So, no, it's not good. I'm just going to go and put this now. Bam. Bam. Damn. Little bit of a Tetris real quick. This is 36 minutes. Everything done. I'm pretty up with that. Not bad. Why would anybody get mad about an option? Because I think people misconstrued it and they believe that I'm saying it shouldn't be added to the game, which is not what I'm saying. Um, there were a lot of people though that really were arguing. I really want to idea all these. That's
what unfortunately like pure in I think. There were a lot of people arguing that they don't want it added to the game because then everybody who wants to speedrun has to turn that feature off and so it's like an even playing field. There's a move speed crap right here by the way. So it's like an e even playing field if everybody has to suffer and has to be paused. You know there there was a whole lot of like well everybody has to do it so it's perfectly fine. Even though that's not
my point at all. Like you could reduce the speed by 50% to take out all the fun of the game and make it so we don't have any movement skills. I mean then you'd have PvE 2, but did I talk to Clarissa? I can't remember. I'm not good at talking to women. Yeah, but besides the point uh besides having PvE 2, you would just um you would have a situation where it's just like it's just not fun to play. And that's that's really all it is. It's just it's just not enjoyable. How's my
accuracy? 623. I don't even know how that's so good. We got no boost on that. Take this. I move that off tech need to be here just shield set up and a level 24 here after Tolman after the crematorium. We are going to grab haste and be even speedier. It's one of my better act twos considering how poor the run was earlier. Maybe carried by bows. I'm going to say it's all me. Do you need a weapon? No, you don't need a weapon because you can play peacon with shield charge, right? I just weapon to
find a green green red. So, is it correct to go south? I want to say it's generally not. I just had a vibe. Transmutes are amazing. We need those for fly damage per crafts. The flat fire damage is from the like little weird map room in Solar's Temple level two. Lightning damage from where Py is and then cold damage is from act four. I don't know why they moved to act four. Honestly, the fire damage craft that used to exist here on crematorium was goated. I'm a little sad they moved this
to be defenses. How's my resist looking? You know, if I ever run into fire damage, I'm feeling fine. Um everything else though, I'm going to be in pain. The shield char feel good. Yeah, it feels really nice. Uh the problem with shield like leap slam swapping for like casters cuz on Templar we like swap over to like uh swords and stuff to leap slam and then we swap back for goat horns because it gives us five damage. The problem with that is you can't weapon swap like while you're in that action so
it feels horrible but this it's pretty fluid. Let's go ahead and look for links since vendors are all messed up now and they can sell like items like way underneath the level. Let's do Joe. Where you at bud? All right, we'll go talk to Johan. Talk to Postess. Talk to Johan again. Then we talk to Ralph. Then we level up the town. Then we grab our gold. Then I'm going to hire some miners real quick. Okay, there we go. Hire five dudes. Then we talk to Johan. Then we add some gold. And then we build the mines. Throw
them in. There we go. Probably better if I logged out. Still need that haste, don't I? Yeah, I forgot haste. You can grab as well. I like grabbing both here. Angel haste. And I need level 24. Cool. I said what? Oh, they uh they go to the mines and they get ore for me. That's that's what they do. They're not anything else. Let me go and put just some sort of resist. Getting life on the chest means we can't get the mastery, but I it's like kind of a whatever burger considering the fact that we don't grab
the mastery, the life master that gives us max life if we don't have a life modest for a long time. Sewers is kind of easy. There's always one bust before the waypoint. Did I ever grab War Falcon? I want to say I didn't. I want to say I never did this. There's always one bus before the waypoint. There's always two buss after the waypoint. The room right after the waypoint determines where the last bust is. If it's large and open, then it will be at the top. If it's small and petite,
then it will be at the bottom. And let's see. Can I do this again? Nice. So, this one is small. This room right here. So, it's going to be on the bottom. You can remember the saying, the the big man is on top, the little man is on bottom. Can you copy my hideout? Excellent work hideout. I was going to say I'm gatekeeping, but then YouTube will get mad at me. Are you the All right, I'm not asking. I'm not answering that question. More transmutes. That's fly damage craps for later. Flight damage can go on bows.
It can go on rings. It can go on an amulet. It can go on your quiver. a lot of things that apply damage. Yo, don't be making fun of DM mods, dude. I haven't talked to dad mods in so long. What's crazy to me is I remember when that mod's kid was born. I was like, "Yo, that's sick." And now he like posts updates of his kid like actually being fully grown and like being able to like speak English. And it's I'm getting old, man. His kid's tw Okay, his kid is not
20 years old, dude. relax. I guess some years from now that will be true. But I was talking to my my good friend and he was he was talking about how when he comes back to my hometown cuz he's somewhere else for work for the next few months. He said when he's back in town we can go out for drinks and we could even invite my dad cuz he's a bit of a a celebrity, bit of a gigach if you will. And I said, "Yeah, sure. Sounds good." He said, "Yeah, it's kind of weird cuz
like talking to parents, like it's not weird anymore. Like I am like a full-on adult." And I was like, "Yeah, I know what you mean. Like I talked with some other of our friends parents and like it wasn't weird in any way." He was like, "Yeah, I mean especially cuz we're like almost 30." Yeah, that one hurt me. Going to be honest. I told him that uh if he ever says we're almost 30 again, I'm going to I'm going to do something that is not uh TS friendly on
YouTube. All right, it's going to remove these crimson ores. It's going to throw in the oral. There we go. Fake story. I'm not leaking DMs. Your oldest just turned 14. And how do you feel? How does that feel for you? You know what I forgot in act two? I forgot to grab elemental damage with attacks and trinity. That's how that feels for me. Okay, relax, bud. But most of your viewers are over the age of 50. Whoa. Are you like washed up and retired? Jesus. Shouldn't you be getting to the
retirement home? Holy. This goes on YouTube. I'm losing I'm losing at least one sub. Confirmed. Washed. And old. At least if I'm washed, that's the first shower I've had in a long time. Can confirm. Oh. Um, I guess. Congratulations. For some reason, that reminds me of a joke that I told in a raid the other day. We were talking in our uh in my WoW guild about how we're like struggling with the boss and like we're just kind of dying. We're just like losing people during like the Mugsy
transition. And I was like struggling with the transition. You know what? Good for her. And I don't know if it was if it was like a bad joke or something, but uh it didn't it didn't really get a good response on in voicecoms. It was kind of completely silent. So, hey, maybe they maybe it wasn't a good joke. I don't know. Yeah. The solve we had is we just marched somebody and then we said, "Follow the marker, guys. Follow the marker." Buddy, why are you not following the
marker? Yikes. Yeah. Yeah, Peon's still good. I mean, we don't know if it's still good in the new patch until we have patch notes. So, wait till then. How's the ring? Flat Fizz. If it had attack speed and had a cast speed, I would have been poging out, but no. Funny how it sells literally the exact same gloves. Should be level down. All right, level that up. I could grab a new bow. Where's my chest at? Let's grab a pure evasion chest. I'm looking for a fourlink of some kind. All we found a
fourlink. Horrible colors. I just want at least one green or one blue. Okay, I'm going to take this gold and I'm going to remove all the gold from the town. Thank you. And we could try to get like other MS boots. Let's go to act two. I need to grab Trinity and Edwa. Let's go and equip this. What's on it? Just a bunch of evasion, honestly. Oh, it's got 1.8 life regen, so it bricks the uh it bricks the mod. And we're going to grab Eda. Some people will say it's wed.
Those people I say are heretics. There's life and res. I'm kind of down for it. Sure, why not? Goodbye. I'm gonna grab anger. Did I ever put on haste? I hope I did. There we go. Copium that you're getting this nextly. What do you mean, bro? That, bro. Oh, I never equipped. I never equipped haste. Oh, my bad. Uh, in that case, I need to lock in, I guess. Uh, yeah, I actually just need to lock in. Uh, I guess we'll do the cringe thing that I said that I hate doing. and put the put the aura in our in our bow. So
now if I ever want to turn it on, I got to put on the orur. Did I ever put in press point blank? No, I didn't. All right. All good. Wed good. Edwas bad. Bro, don't be talking trash about Edw Havoc. Hang on. I forgot where to go in the passive tree again. I think I like going uh booming speed here. You can go the bow nodes actually. Bow CDR. Yeah, sure. Why not? I mean, there's there's 500 different bow nodes, dude. You really can't go wrong clicking just a generic bow thing the wrong
way. Oh, you're coping that I'll still have the gold shop. I mean, I don't see any reason why we wouldn't have the uh the currency auction house anymore. I think people would literally write in the streets if we didn't have uh house to spec next spec. I can almost guarantee you that the uh the gold respspec and stuff will will stay. Those are honestly some really good changes. I like those in Pew 2 as well. I like the uh gold respect and stuff. I think PE2 really needs to have regret orbs. Something about only
being able to respect with uh with gold, which is character bound, is it's a little weird. I don't know if anybody else feels the same way. I also think there needs to be maybe not needs to be. We're going to grab the lapis amulet, by the way. Give me that. But it would be kind of nice if there was a uh uh sure why not. That is open prefix. And we're going to hold another jewelry. Is there a goated piece of jewelry? Um, I mean, that one's corrupted and that one's whatever. So, we'll grab flat.
They have fire damage. Is Trinity even working? I have no idea. But, you know what' be cool is you get 20 up to 20 free respects in PoE just from completing different quests in the campaign. Each act has two quests or two regret points that you can get. And it would be really nice if there was a couple of those in every act of QE2. just saying I don't know. It It would help a lot with the Oh, by the way, we completely nerfed your build, Jungrone, and you have to spend 500,000 gold to completely
respect your character. Uh otherwise, you got to fully restart your character. So, you guys don't have gold? Yeah, I held on to every bit of gold. Not every bit, but I held on to a lot of gold just in case my character got like randomly just shot while I'm asleep. Funny enough, the friend that wants to get drinks, he played like this He played like a a crossbow character and I don't remember what they're called, but he played a crossbow and he tried out like 15 different skills. And
I said, "Well, dude, uh, everybody's Uhhuh. Oh, I'm dead. I'm dead." I said, "Well, dude, everybody that I've heard says that playing like gas arrow and like flame ball is really good." And he said, "Okay, I guess I'll try that." And he reported back that he was having a lot of fun. He actually was really enjoying playing PvE 2 for once. And then he woke up and he was like, "Tait, my build feels terrible now. I don't know why." And I went, "Oh,
I have no idea. Like, I wonder what could have happened. Like, maybe you just like hit a wall. You like hit a new progression system." And he was like, "I don't know. Like, I just feel so weak." It turns out he was playing the Rutu build and the Rutu build got completely shot while he was asleep and he wasn't even like following specifically like the Rutu build. He just equipped the gems and then his build got completely uh got completely gutted while he was sleeping. So, yeah.
I just have to grab. You can switch to Eon. Technically, you could go Eonk. Uh, it's probably faster and better. Uh, now that we found that Eon is an amazing leveling skill. Maybe I'll do a guide on that soon. We'll see. But for now, we're going to walk in on the bow run. I generally like to play a variation of what I'm going to play later on. That's kind of why I don't love going rain of arrows. The only exception is if like you know weapon swap ge charge is survival. Meta cuck. I mean I don't
think he like that. But what app do people use to track guys? I have I have the burpees today. I guess track splits. Uh we use live split. I used to use wsplit. Fortunately it's uh not something I'm able to find anymore but I don't mind using live split. Not a huge fan of splits personally. The problem is that let's say that you have two runs. One run you complete Murville in 17 minutes. Wow. With everything done, but you're level 11. The other run you completed in 19 minutes, but you're
level 13 and you have three transmutes cuz you've been gearing and focusing and you've got your three link ready to go for act two. I'd rather have the second run literally every single time. I'm out of life blast. Hopefully we don't die here. All right, we're good. Potentially a new bow. Love to see that. I didn't pull that. What's Eunk? Explosive concoction. It's a pretty cool gem that we discovered. It's actually very good in the speedrunning world. Nothing good here. I do kind of want
these boots. They're like pretty easy to chrome as long as they land moose speed. Yeah, they landed 20 of us. I don't need a 24 gem. Storm rain. Artillery blister. Do I have chance orbs? I do have two chance orbs. Let's go ahead and grab different rain gems. Blast rain. Storm Rain and we have artillery booto. Let's grab our quest. I'm going to go and chrome the boots to be like three green, one red would be perfect. Stop doing that. Okay, we win. That's unethical. Oh, it took 11 muds. Yeah, I mean I
guess we were like avidly looking for it, but you're not wrong. Probably more good gems most likely. I wouldn't doubt that at all. I don't have life tap, but we just go Edwa for now on the boots. Uh, I would have to drop angel, but we could just level it up somewhere else. The problem is this bow might introduce so much lightning damage that I actually have to go full time possibly. Uh, in that case, I would probably drop the element damage attack skills right there. I'll quick frost
blink here. How much stats does my current health have? Literally nothing. Oh, but it doesn't have any green sockets. I think I'd rather just sell this for a chromatic then. We pretty much want to be level 28 by lab and yeah, we'll be that by our isro. So, uh I just wait for the craft to drop. Like I wait to have enough bobbles for the craft. Otherwise, it just it just kind of doesn't make sense. You're just purely gambling. And even if you have a bunch of flasks, they're like
some weird mixture of like use when the adjacent classes you you'll never know if those are going to have the same amount of charges, right? So, yep. Missed the legendary crafting recipe. That one's attributes, I believe. I don't need that. I'm dead. No, his his question wasn't, would you use instilling orbs on your level 18 mana flask, which you can't use, but his question was, do you use instilling orbs on flasks or do you wait for the craft? I would wait to craft it. Wish they buffed what, bro? What are you
saying? par sight blink arrow CDR and I actually kind of want one with nature here. Um I want to try to keep this bow and see if it's better. I do too much fire damage, don't I? Just barely. Unfortunately, jar draws are going to make this fight a lot harder than it has to be. Damage is fine. What's the damage at? 1,700 to 2500. All right. Yeah, it's pretty good. Blink arrow. Oh, I never actually equipped blast rain. Drop Gonic Hero. Okay, let's do this. This This I'm missing a gem now. I don't know what gem
that is. Hero device, I think. It's fine. I wasn't running it anyways because I'm stupid. Yeah, I just kind of like forgot about it. All right, hold up. Some form of jewelry just dropped. Too late for that. Uh it would appear that I'm doing far too much lighting damage. So on bosses, I am in fact going to have to equip anger once again. Emperor strikes. Yeah, you can see the uh the trinity gem up there. Did not like that. So, my hair out of ice over here. Move that over. I'm just gonna
sell that for chrome. I'm down. Uhoh. Oops. Oh, I I have two different 50% ores on. I was like, what happened to my mana? Where'd it go? It disappeared. Help. All right, let's grab the probe. And yeah, we're perfectly fine as long as I have on. Uh, we'll swap between the two for clearing. Oh, I got to wait for this to rise up. What's on these boots? 20 MS as well. It's not bad. Hold on to them. Empire. What am I going to stash with? Probably the momentum now. I'm down to keep on to
that for a while. The chromes. I kind of need almost everything in my inventory right now. Lab stimulate. I've already crafted damage on. How's my fire res? Oh, it's capped. Okay. If you have cap fire res, you just walk over these as you can see. Just walk over, press a light blast, call it a day. If you don't, you get like completely owed. It's Angel, not. Uh, sorry, I don't understand. Listen, I've got the college degree. Do you? All right. Studied accounting for four
years. It's a Spanish word. I also studied uh also studied Spanish for 4 years. Unfortunately, I've completely lost the ability to speak it, but I can kind of understand it when somebody like is speaking, which is kind of neat. I kind of like that. Um, let's see if this bow is any good. Technically, that bow sucks. So, yeah, just dropping that. I think where am I going? Top right. I actually have no idea. This way. It's like a dead end. Oh god. I'm gonna go. You did accounting. You're a big
four director. Sorry. No offense, but sorry. We're good. Can afford to be promised. Yeah. Don't do where it was. Actually, Deoid's pretty cool. I like the most devious trap of them all. Before Eso. Yeah. Yeah, I agree. It is. It is pretty bad, man. Yep. Are you a martr? It's [ __ ] of the dog. All right. Yep. No, I agree. Boom. Boom. Boom. I got to be careful. Keith, grove bow. Potentially gloves. Although 73 life. Wait, am I even like accuracy is accuracy even higher than my D? It is. I don't know
how, but uh let's peep the bow. Was it any good? Honestly, kind of sucks. This item also kind of sucks. I want to see this bow real quick. If there's a lot of quality, I'll I'll go with quality. This bow is substantially worse than what I got. Uh 3%. We're going to try for a spectral hit or hit of the spectrum. Sorry, I'm a little on spectral myself. We go dead eyee. Here we go. Tailwind. Woman can change the world with a single. Just don't work on taxes. Don't worry. I
basically didn't pass my tax class. It is a miracle that I even got my degree. do anything I would don't I've forg you can cancel the font. Yeah, you just press the little X button, right? Little red X. American taxes only just made you drop out. I felt pretty similar. Um, I had this giant project where they wanted us to use like current tax rates and everything and I didn't understand the project at all. And I asked this guy who was in my fraternity cuz I was in like a honors fraternity for a semester
and I was like, "Yeah, I'm just really struggling with this tax project." And he went, "Oh, dude, I remember that. Hey, I could I could show you my old one if you want." I was like, "Dude, that'd be amazing." Well, he didn't have time to like go through with it or like go through it with me. And so instead, what he did is he uh I don't think I had Trinity on the boss. I was wondering why my damage took. So instead, he just handed me the packet. And I didn't copy
what he did. I looked at his formulas and I went, "Oh, that's where we use that formula." Okay. Okay. I used this formula here. Oh, and I used this formula there. Okay. Yeah, I follow. I get it. I understand it now. And I was like, "Oh my god, I finally get tax class." Like, this is such a joy. Like, normally I'm super confused. This is amazing. Yeah. Um, my uh my professor sent me an email saying, "I know what you did. Never do that again or I will fail you from my
class and I got like a like an F on the He knew, dude. He knew I didn't like like I said, I didn't forbid him copy. I I was not copying. I was using similar formulas and he didn't like the fact that I was using a previous year's uh formulas and it was like very obvious to him. I guess whoops. Yeah, I may have I may have flown a little too close to someone with that one. I guess I'm doing too much lightning damage still. Um honestly, my bow is pretty goated if I craft fire damage on it, which I can always just do
that. Yeah, I'm down. Let's do that then. That'll sell my damage. Let me go and grab this grove bow real quick and just slap some random garbage on it. That actually kind of owns. Wait a second. That's like more lightning damage and it's got other damage. That's also pretty good. But yeah, hang on. Wait a second. This item is amazing. Got 590 accuracy and 555 life. The way precise technique works, this node right here, you have to have higher accuracy number or your accuracy has to be higher than
your life total, which don't worry is very easy on ranger. We're a deck stacking class. Well, intentionally stack dexterity, but we just naturally get a lot of dexterity and then on top of that, we have almost no lives. So, use that to the end of campaign, you would think, but you never know. Is that a Is that my first sub one hour with lab? Look, it's a sub one hour dominus with lab, boys. You also have no life. Amen. Listen, bro. Would you rather have a life or would you rather have a sub one
hour dom with all skill points plus lab? Cuz like it's not a it's not a difficult choice for me. I'm just saying. 83 life on the helm. Let me just sell these bull. Actually, I'll sell one of these. Uh attack speed. You know what? It actually has a ton of accuracy on it as well. So, it kind of solves the problem that it introduces. Why not both? That's the most Havoc response I've ever heard in my life. I'm like, would you rather be like in the best shape of your life or be one of the
best speeders in the world? And Havoc's like standing over there. Let me grab attack speed. Give me that. Whoa. I'm dying. I'm dying. I'm bleeding out to death. Uh, I want to craft fire D. No, I don't. This new bow is going to save everything. It's going to save Pv2. How's the belt? It's all right. I guess life. I kind of like the res a bit more. How's the res looking? It's looking great. Is shield charge swap that much faster? Yeah. So, we don't have like like we
have blink arrow CDR. So you can you can actually just blink arrow the whole way through. But you can see the difference in speed. Yeah, at this point it's totally fine just to blink arrow. But this is the difference between the speed. Oh wait, this was never on attack of the moving. No wonder it felt so weird. Switch everything else on attack of the moving then. Uh this might be a dead end again. Uh it looks like that. Should we have more creepy bosses? I don't think like like I'm going to be
real. I don't find the whole like oh we need like a creepy boss or we need like a grittier game. Like I don't I personally don't care about any of that. You could make like Hello Kitty Island Adventure and if it's got the gameplay loop of Path of Exile 1, I'm logging in, dude. I'm just saying it sleep. Yeah. I also think that we're in a very different era of gaming. I don't think we're in the era of like fresh meat and then like some giant like boss comes at you and you just like start crying cuz
you're like 9 years old and you just discovered what Diablo was cuz your older brother told you about it. For me it was my uncle. But you know you can't call him bald dude. That's some path of mit. Relax. Yeah. Blink arrow once you have the CDR is perfectly fine. Like we can just we can just blink her up. I'm not up to that just yet. Oops. Um, yeah. I mean, I guess if we don't have Trinity while clearing, it's not the end of the world. I would like to have it though. What if I did the most degenerate
technology known to mankind and we swap between two actively? Can I do some skips in act four? Would you guys like to see some skips? See if I can do them. On this one, I have like multiple skips incoming. Hold up. Is it left side? I don't remember. Honestly, it's here. Here it is. This one's really hard to do. All right, we did it. Nice. First try. I think there's another one coming up. Can I do it again? The back to back. The champ. Holy. I'm not washed, guys. I'm beating
the allegations, not the other allegations. We don't have to talk about the Google doc, but you know, uh, we've got one more. I'm honestly just going to do one more cuz I just want to get the XP from it. I don't want to skip out on all the XP. One more coming up. Allegations. No, I'm not going to address those. I'm sure you just lost cage. So, what? We don't have to talk about it, guys. Moving on. Anyways, uh, what about this quiver? I actually have two Wo essences. So, what I'm going to do is
I'm going to do something a little strange, a little funky. We're going to go ahead and just wo essence a quiver to look for percent bow damage cuz that's what woes do on quivers. So, we got that. We got some res. We'll take it. Is that fire res though? Oh, it's lightning. Okay, perfect. I was going to say we don't need fire res anymore. Uh you'll notice that a lot of speedrunners what we do is we'll take this waypoint in the Grand Arena. We'll go back. We'll do the comb zone. We do
that because we're typically lower on XP or we want to be a little bit stronger for the boss fight. We don't have to do that on the bow build cuz we're so powerful. How's my accuracy? 650. We got 600. Yeah, that's fine. Yeah, we don't have to do the MO build cuz we're powerful and it's really really easy to get XP on a bow build. However, if you're playing some other builds, remember what I said earlier about level 32 being a huge break point. Yeah, this is this is that time where
you're about to level 32 that could be better than the other bow. What a weird situation. I'm in a weird timeline right now. is not possessed with the idea of can't even equip her device cuz I don't have another green socket. We got too many blues, dude. I got too many blues. I might have to jeweler the helm to look for a three socket. I do like the helm quite a bit of life. If it has open suffix, it's kind of the goat. Can I get some flat damage? Yeah, I can get some of that. Getting a mana loot is
also kind of cool. Tax evasion. Oh, I don't recommend that, dude. The IRS will own you. Holy, we got four sockets. Even better. Um, should I chrome that though is the question. I didn't even see if it had an open sop. I need a vendor. So, I'm going to log out. I don't know which of these items is going to be better though. Which of these two bows? Every item I have here requests all 35. Okay. I got a skill point. I hope I did. I couldn't remember. Force. Boom. Let's see if I can do the skip. Hopefully, we
have a comb skip. Tata. Not a [ __ ] crow. Let's see. I practiced it all night. If I don't get a p if I don't get to do it in a real run, I'm going to be really sad. No, I don't have it. No. I literally like sat there all night like a kid right before like a rehearsal so that I could show my mom and dad so that they could be proud of me. Now, stop lauing me, guys. I'm really upset about that. I was looking forward to doing it in an actual run. We can slam shaper elder mods. Oh,
wait, wait, wait. I have one. I have one. Hang on, hang on. No, no. No. Let me Aha. First try. There it is. Easy game. Holy. No. No. No, I'm not going to reset off messing up a a trick once. All right. Plus 2 seconds. Yeah, but the time save of actually getting it is way faster. So, you're hacking. It's like an age-old skip. And let me move these over. What if I said that I want to make a YouTube short of some different skips you can do with Blink Arrow? Cuz there's some Blink Arrow specific ones. That one's one of
them. Actually, I think I got to showcase all of them in this speedrun. There's that one. There's the one that I did in the trial in Chambers of Sin 2. And there's one in act 10 as well across the bridge. Don't skip ahead. Watch the whole blood. The speed is jarring. I mean, yeah, it's it's insane. I went and played PvE 2 for a while, like on the new patch, and I was having a fun time, and I went back to PvE 1, and I literally couldn't go back to playing PvE 2. Like, I could not I
Oh, wait. I just natty dropped flame dash. Uh let's replace frost blink then because I don't need that anymore. Technically we don't get flame dash till level till act six but uh getting it here is pretty good. Let's get hits. Have a chance to invert resist. Uh give me the quiver maybe and then maybe the hell. I'm too unlucky on space. U unethical. Nope. Okay. reset up that a gem that I'm getting slightly early life. How much accuracy do I have exactly? I have 688. If you don't want to worry about
accuracy at all, there's a little accuracy attack speed node. What is this called? Is it a cutie? It is. You can just grab that. That's perfectly fine. Grab it up. Okay, we have two bows. Problem. The second I equip a bow, it's going to like it's going to like mess up my Trinity or my Blood Rage stack. So, I don't know when I can actually like look at the bows outside of like a brand new instance. Let's see. I'll find out in a second here. At least I read the layout correctly. What is Eon? It's explosive
concoction. All right. 2700 to 3500 to 3,900. I found the winner. I found the winner. Any open like mods in this? I don't really want to craft hack speed. It's a really good bow, but I don't really want to craft attack speed. I'm fine. Yeah. Yeah. I'm not crafting attack speed. I'm not doing it. Am I missing a green gem? I swear I was missing something. Is this bow better? I swear this thing's better. I can't tell though. Again, the the mods just moving all over the
place. 760. Oh, I have this helm that has a ton of life on it, but it kind of solves its own problem cuz it has accuracy on it as well. Guess if I was secretly cooking. Yeah, I guess so. Blood rage. Haste. Drop that on the ground. Yeah, we had no idea. It's like It's like how Pock was playing like Armageddon. I don't think he was playing Armageddon Brand. No, he was playing Armageddon Brand with the rest of us. I don't remember. But he was using um cremation. He's using desecrating cremation and he
made it look so bad that every racer laughed at him and we didn't know that he actually had the next tech that we would use for like the next several years of speedrunning. 3,800 and this is also 3,800 but it doesn't have pierce. I'd rather just have pierce you know pierce is good. How's the light blast? Oh, it's literally just a light blast. How's the ring? Kind of sucks. Arma cream missile attack. You can just go firestorm. Uh there's a lot of like peacon racing now that's kind of
being replaced by Eon. The thing is peon is is like such a good skill mechanically that if you could just have one that doesn't remove your life blast and has better elemental scaling like explosive concoction does people just end up using that now for racing. But so yeah, you could we're good. Sorry. I try not to be super loud in these runs because I know that people like try to fall asleep to them. Guys, please stop low. It's It's going to make me upset. We're good. How much
time loss is this? Hang on. How much time am I going to lose? Oh god. No, I'm not going to reset off losing. Oh my god, it's 15 seconds. We might have to reset, guys. We might have to reset. I'm sorry about that. One of my least favorite things is I will watch I will watch Starcraft casters, whether it's Brood War or Starcraft 2, and I will fall asleep to it. And my least favorite thing is when they start ulting on the mic and they get really loud and their mic peaks because that always
wakes me up. I used to get really offended by people that would say like, "Tait, I use your videos to fall asleep." And I thought like, man, am I so boring that I'm putting people to sleep? And after falling asleep to Artosis and and Pig for like I don't know the last several years. Saying that they fall asleep to my videos is one of the greatest honors. I will take that any of the week. Uh am I doing too much cold damage or lightning damage again? Yes, I am. Hear casting. I love Hearstone's
videos. I don't know why I don't enjoy his casting style as much. Like no offense, but I love his YouTube series. I enjoy. Is it Embo or do I suck? But casting just isn't quite my style, I guess. All right, we're going to go fleet foot and then we're going to fix up this garbage pathing that we have. I swear it's going to make sense later. How much do I have? 1,000. Oh, how much res do I have? Okay, as long as I'm not taking cold damage, I'm going to be fine. And I think I need to replace this
ring. Can I replace that ring? I can't. Drama. I mean, we're in completely different spears. I don't think he even knows who I am. failed one skip. Well, we did kind of get a little slow on the act four skip. So, okay, we do have cold res on an essence. If we find like a big not like a big, but if we find like a normal uh heavy or leather boat, we can always just slap that on. I'll go and sell this as well. I'm down. I play Tetris a little better than this. I think I have no flasks at all.
Super good. Accept the gift of Got to be careful here. We're good. I do enjoy the uh the crossovers that I have though with like other communities just by like chatting in their in their streams. I swear I have like the coolest job cuz other people's networking is like being like a weird little Oh, that's 93 life with resist. Other people's business jobs are like and their networking is like being a little businessman and having like official saying. I'm going to get a what do I
need? I want barrage support for later. Like super later. Maybe I'll try using it bosses. Why not? But you know they got to have like this weird like networking. We're going to grab return projectiles by the way. And my my networking is going into someone's chat and typing catw, you know, like like it's night and day difference. I'm frozen. I'm just chilled. You always have desync on the Malachi fight. Yeah, it's an old fight. It's a really old one. Thai sneaky collab. We hung out at an
airport once. We were uh we were going home from the uh PvE 2 event because GG invited a bunch of streamers to play the Pv2 event in LA. And so they flew us out there, got us a hotel. We played like at the hotel. It was really sick. And on the way home, we had like these vans like take us back to the airport in batches and I just so happened to be in the same van as Sneaky. And then the van guy was like, "Hey, anybody that's in terminal one, uh, we're going up and I'm going to pull up to it." And
I was like, "Okay, I'm in Terminal One." Sneaky was also in terminal one. So, we get out of the van and I'm like, "All right, well, it was nice talking to you. See you later." And we go get our tickets and he's sitting there. He's like standing there waiting for me. And we start walking and he follows behind. He follows next to me. And I was like, "Oh, oh, my bad." I was kind of I was kind of tweaking out. I was kind of fanboying. I was trying really hard to not like uh
not fan girl out loud. I thought it was just like, "All right, well, see you later. I'm going to my gate." We talked about uh we talked about WoW like playing games as kids, how like gaming's different, how ratings going. Uh, we talked about League quite a bit. I need like cold and lightning. I think it's fine. 300 accuracy is pretty cool. Sure. 137. Just say you're a fan. Listen, me and not being awkward don't go well together. All right. I've just I just kind of accepted
that fact. Like the other day I was at the bank. I was at the bank and as I was leaving this girl, pretty cute girl. She goes, "Hey, I really like your shirt." I went, "Oh, thanks." It was a Jiujitsu Kaizen and Hello Kitty shirt. You know, it's got like Gojo Saturu on it and it's also got like Cinema Roll. And she goes, "Have you watched the anime?" Well, I thought she'd been Hello Kitty. I've never swatched Hello Kitty before in my life. I just really
like Cinema Roll. My favorite character. So I went, "Oh no, sorry. I only bought it cuz it had cinnamon roll on it." And she seemed really disappointed. And I was, she was like, "Really? You've never seen it?" I said, "Yeah, I'm kind of a fake fan. Sorry." I didn't know that she was talking about Jiujitsu Kaizen until I left the bank. And I was like, "Okay, do I walk back in there and tell her that I enjoyed the show so much that I've watched it twice, watched the
movie, read the entire manga, and then I just thought that it was a simple misunderstanding." Instead, I just got in my car and went, "What are we doing, Titan? What are we doing?" She asked me where I got it from and I was like, "Oh, I think I got it online from like Hot Topic." Okay, but the manga sucks, bro. We don't I don't I don't want to talk about it. All right. I don't want to talk about it. There's going to be some like There's going to be somebody that's not read it and I'm
going to start bitching. Some of it's goated though, dude. Some of it I cannot wait to see the scenes. You can't run that back. Yeah, that's that's what I figured is like I I sealed my fate. There's going to be something that's like, bro, it's never too late, man. It's never too late, dude. It was way too late. I'm not up to that just yet. Last 30 chapters, bro. You mean the last 350? Like, what are you talking about? All right, never mind. Life gave you a 4G and you sold
it. Yeah, that's literally like, oh my god, I can't wait to equip this bow and then I get the bow and I I vendor it right before I could equip it. You know what? It's not the worst story. All right. It's not the worst. Make a foul out of yourself and run it back. Nope. I just I'm going to take the elf. Oh, I never grabbed fleet foot. My bad. And gold. Okay, we're good. What level am I? Level 39. Okay, we don't need to farm chamber in cuz bows just get a billion XP for some
reason cuz we have like turbo offscreen clear. Honestly, bows always look great until you look over and realize that I've got 700 life with no defensive ores in act five. Like, it's always great until you look at that. Like, I want you guys to to know that like this is actually kind of difficult to play without dying at all. Your only defensive layer is, as Havoc would say, just don't get hit. Pipes/ deaths. I actually don't know what my deaths are. I'm kind of scared. yesterday. They were like
They're like eight. Holy. Wait, am I goated? Wait, am I him? The build's OP. Wait, you're right. Zaki, nerf bows. All right, time to get one shot on Innocence just to make the build look balanced. All right, let's move over that. Uh, this bow sucks. I think the boots also suck. They're like 25 a mess, but they are just like pure armor and sloth. They kind of mess with my colors. Yeah, they're just annoying. I don't really want to quit this home. It owns my accuracy. Oh, that is full on suffixes.
Oh. Oh. Oh. Okay, that changes things cuz this is resist. That one's resist with big life and open suffix. So, I can fix my my resist quite well, actually. How's the ring? Oh, is it's 50 life actually. It's not bad. How much do I have? Oh, I have 1300. I think I'll be all right if this is open suffix. This ring is amazing. It does not, unfortunately. Sad. Sad. How about this ring? Uh, what if we replace this ring? I think my fire risk gets completely owned if I do that. Yeah, it does. I would lose 40% fire
res. Does it have fire res? No, that's eight. What about the quiver? Damn to the bow skills. I It's got resist. I can craft fly damage. If I craft fly fire, I would have enough to maybe I have to use Angel 24/7, which be cool. Can I use this? I don't think I have enough fire damage normally. Oh, I do. I'm just I'm just silly. Okay. In fact, it's kind of a miracle that lightning even what? Oh, no. Never mind. I was looking at the wrong number. Yeah. No, I have to like turbo
mineral the lightning damage. I don't want to run. Okay. Well, let's just port out if you're going to be a if you're going to be a meanie head about it. Give me a jade flask, please. And am I selling everything? But the helm I think I am. We're holding another wetstone for later. And it's about that time to just put away all the gear that I have and all the currency. I'll take the barrage. Maybe I'll try using it early that I normally do. Return barrage is a later
gem. That's like a vendor recipe thing. This is like whatever. I can just grab my scope on here as well. All right. Um, as far as pathing is concerned, let's fix it up. Yeah. I swear the padding will make sense later. Trust me. How would you leak start scion solo? Basically, you're just playing a worst version of any build that you want in the entire game. Just imagine that, right? Sion is an ascendancy that scales into the end game cuz it's uber lab is like really powerful being able to start
anywhere and obviously like merk lab is a big power spike having two different mini ascendancies but until that point you're just kind of weaker right like your normal lab sucks you're getting plus 30 to an attribute your cruel lab sucks cuz you're getting like half of an ascendency sometimes it's good sometimes you get like a really nice ascendy burst nothing's coming to mind of like wow that's really OP for just like one your merk laby you kind of come online and then your group lab you're looking great
cuz you scale with passive points so well later on. Um yeah, it really just depends on what build you're playing. If you're playing like the captain lance RF build, I'd probably I think slam scale really well. All you need is a weapon and you're kind of on the like left side of the tree anyways. You could play rolling magma if you're going a caster like Armageddon brand. You're going a bow builds. I mean, you could just go bottom right. Just go like lightning arrow. Like like
I said, you're basically playing the same version that the base classes do. You're just a far far inferior version of it. Raider. I don't know what that is. That's what it is. I didn't see in my game. It's not real. It's not real. You should take Raider first. Wasn't that the onslaught node, man? What about Arch Mage? Firestorm. I mean, I don't think that build's really going to be around next patch. I don't know if Arch Mage is going to survive. Don't worry,
guys. They're going to buff Selfcast. You guys can come back to this VOD and type was right when they buff selfcast to the moon. Trust me, these items suck. What's going on here? Combat rogue. It's fine, dude. Outlaw has been bugged for several years, but it's going to be good next patch. Trust me. Remember, we do this for free. I think Outlaw was good back in BFA and that's it. I think we've just had like a mediocre spec since then. Surely selfcast gets buffed. I mean, it literally has to. All right,
they have to do it. There's no other choice for them. What's that damage of the bows per chance of lightning? What man? Yeah, it will indeed enjoy that. Level 42. We can equip a holive blast. Let's go and transmute this. I kind of really want an instant one. Bam. That alteration did nothing. That alteration did nothing. That alteration did nothing. Instant recovery on low life. Sure, but why not? It's not really what I'm looking for, but pick up other items. How's my resist
again? It's okay at best. Really in F5, I'm looking for like 105% resist and like trying to figure out how I can get there as like a giant puzzle piece. What are the boots? If they don't MS, then they then they suck, you know. Okay. Yeah, that sucks. Go and replace that. Move that over there. want this accuracy craft just in case I run into some problems soon. Does this chest have life? Oh, it has. This is the 1.8 life regen chest. So, I can't take the 15% mastery. Oh, this way.
It's time for GG to press the big red button. I think the last time we had like 20 quality life overhauls, it was because the patch itself needed some form of like extra little oomph to it to make it look like it had a whole lot going on. It's all right, guys. That's not going to happen this patch, right? 47 flag. Maybe that's good. Get inv. Uh, do I take life nodes? I'm dead. Life node, pathing node. Refund that node. Uh, we don't need the accuracy nodes cuz that helmet is giving us
accuracy, right? Yeah, you could take these accuracy nodes though. Accutility if you're struggling with accuracy at all. Damage is really high. Also, I spec, but I don't need that. I think we're good on everything here. We could go life. No. Uh, we're not going to go the life nodes. You could go life nodes and little like or like point blank is. I don't know what these nodes are called. They're really efficient life nodes. Thick skin. That's what it's called. Uh,
I'm kind of down for reservation. Like I said, you really can't go wrong with a lot of these ranger nodes. They're all just kind of pretty good. Yeah, I want this. I'm going to take leader of the pack and mana leech. And that should cap our get our mana good to go. I could make these into 30 MS boots. I don't think these like 11 life and 19 strength is doing anything for me. Oh, it's leveling up my anger. Oh. Um, if I need it for anger, then we're going to solve it by equipping a heavy
belt. It's going to be the strat. I need to like get away from this guy. I wonder if barrage would be good here instead of LMP. I want to say it would be I'm going to try it. I know later on Raj is like a 100% multiplier with all the projectiles that I have, but I don't think it's that OP right this second. If there's a new HTSSF race, will you participate? Probably not. I'm not very good in HDSSF. I don't find it very fun. I'm also just mad at the game in general,
and I kind of hide the fact that I'm bad by just hiding behind Software Trade. I'd much rather I'd much rather be the potential man of, oh, what if imagine if Tai killer raced rather than the guy that gets like owned by Azeri every single time. You know what I mean? real ones remember. You know what I'm saying? Hey, some of you know. Uh, I need to craft on the gloves and ideally want a new chest. I guess I can craft flat fire on the quiver. Yeah, sure. Um, what is it? Cold res, I guess.
Just on the gloves. Another choice. Yeah. Uh, yeah. I mean what we could do I can either cold res essence or fire resessence of heavy belt. Let's see. Let's see. We need somebody to be Ben. Yeah. Well, it's not going to be me, buddy. Uh heavy belt. That's 72 life on the heavy belt. That's pretty good. That is pretty good. Uh I kind of want to take these boots and 25 mess them. I'll have to wait for another. Okay. Yeah, I'm not super that though. That see 72 load attack, 1200.
All the life blast. Give me that ivory boat. I mean, we could find a one mod boat. That's just better. Ventura perma ban you cuz of your name. He was having a bad time. Yeah, I know. Somebody was saying earlier that K they were typing Lauo in K's check cuz he died in Gauntlet and they got perma banned but like as a streamer I've definitely been there. There was a Runescape streamer that my friend was uh was typing in. like he regularly went to this channel and he enjoyed the streamer and I guess
somebody like really pissed him off saying some like really stupid things earlier cuz he was like that's it idiot you're banned that's right you're perma banned get owned [ __ ] and my friend joined the chat late and he went whoa hey what did that guy say and the streamer went you want to join him bud fine you're peran too idiot it and like on the outside it's like wow way to not be able to like understand the social situation here. Like what a loser. But as a content creator, man,
I've been there, dude. Man, I have been there so hard. All right, we're doing Tidal Island for the belts cuz I want a better heavy belt. And then I'm portaling out to Twilight Strand cuz Portal is closer than either the waypoint or the middle of town from Logan. It could be banned for any reason. That's right. For some people, that's saying something stupid. For other people, that's You know what? I'm not going to finish that joke. Never mind. Aren't all con all content critics losers? Yeah, in
my opinion, content creators make the game make every gaming space worse by being in them. 99% of content creators are pure trash. They regurgitate garbage. Everything is like profit incentive. People don't do People don't do things cuz they're like Omega passionate. It feels like a lot of the time. I mean, even I even I'm releasing this YouTube video for money. All right. Don't get it twisted. I'm not doing this out of good of my heart. I'm doing this so I can make cold hard cash. That's
right. This is actually pretty good on the chest. Oh, I want life tap and I want Oh, that's my angel actually. Yeah, I guess I guess that's it. Um, grab the heavy belt and I can grab elemental hit. There's like a rare chance that I get elemental hit of the spectrum in uh Uber Lab. So, how's the belt? It kind of sucks. Kind of sucks. Let's see if we find any poor link here. I didn't find anything anything cool. Don't like that. Are you a gooner? Uh, next question, please. Next
question. What was I grabbing? I was grabbing lead of the pack and leech mastery. All right. I should have just run boths now. Chilling. Yeah. No more questions at this time, please. No more questions. Thank you. Do you bounce on it? Depends. Uh, I don't really want to get frozen by a strong box. So, I'm going to like avoid a lot of these. Oh, bubbling blast. Give me the gloves. Maybe they're better. That's how he done them. Boom. 96 armor. It's pretty rare that a gold ring will ever be better than a two- stone
ring, but I've seen it happen. You see I'm pub in rouge chat. It's a good emote, dude. It's a good emote. But yeah, I just I don't know. I don't like content creators, even though I have a lot of respect for a lot of them. I think that uh I think that gaming before content creators were a thing and before Discord was a thing. You'd like go to some like forum post and you'd see some like you'd see some guy that's like, "Yeah, I've done this raid before. Here's the
explanation of it." You don't see that anymore. All the knowledge is in like some random Discord and you'll talk to some somebody online like, "Oh, don't aren't you following the XYZ ta killer strat?" And you're like, "No." And you're like, "Bro, you don't even have the titular filters. They're on his Discord, bro." Like, it's it's cringe. It's cringe. I don't like it. But gotta play the game to win, I guess. Uh, ID. This is garbage. Be the change
you want to see. I I don't I don't even know what that would look like. You know what? I will be the change that I want to see. Fub gun. I'm going to start calling out consequ here back again with another T17 strategy. Yeah, today we're going to be uh scratching my ass and opening these boxes in T7s. Yeah, it's pretty good currency. Yeah, I'm just sitting on like five mirrors. every league, dude. It's the same video. And you know what? I've watched every single one of them. So, uh, keep up the
good work, Ben. Ruining the economy, man. It's been one league. Yeah. I mean, I guess it's literally just the repeat of the same stuff for all of Montre for hour. I hate the diff per hour metric. I am a D per hour hater, bro. Where's the fun per hour? Where's the whimsy that you feel doing a strategy? Oh my god, my HP. I couldn't care less if I'm running 17 smackaroons per hour or not. Good chest. What's the reason I couldn't wear? Oh, cuz that's where my fourlink
is, idiot. Uh, my bow is really good in act four and it has fallen off or is about to fall off. I think I already grabbed the trial. I grabbed that. Maybe this is the new bow. Imagine starting PvE content in settlers. I mean, I guess you wouldn't quit your day job, right? Would be a bad time to quit that time [ __ ] Are ready for made rude? That's not a thing, dude. You're just making stuff up now. Unless you're going to start it, in which case uh I'm down to collab sometime. if you don't. It's surreal. I
don't know, dude. R said that he was going to join me in Fenboy Fridays and then he never did. And I was a little disappointed. It's a little disappointed. D for hours is insanely cringe. I agree. It is cringe. I hate it. Catgirl patters. Okay, I'm not joining that Saturday, dude. Also, isn't that your everyday? Isn't that you on every Saturday? Hello. All right, it's logo. Ru dresses up. Oh, does he really? Oh, my bad. I'm not up to that just yet. Too, you prefer SSF because D for hours
is cringe. Yeah, I agree. I mean, it's the same reason why playing an Iron Man in Runescape is just better. True. It's Pride Month, guys. I'm not doing anything special for Pride Month. People that do things like specially because it's a certain month, I've always found that kind of weird. Like, I've always supported like people of color, gay people, trans people. I'm not going to be like, "It's their day. Let's go." All right. It's It's July. Close it up, guys. All right.
We're done. I'm not I'm not supporting this garbage, you know? Like, we're not doing that. I'll share a picture of myself. Okay. Contri, I don't want to know what you're going to do with that picture of me, dog. Not that I would have any of those, but you know, Corporation Cosplayer. Amen. What was my Settlers League start? I played Hex Blast Mines. I had really good I had a really good time until I started trying aspirational content and then I really needed like a sandstorm V.
And as I got the currency for it, it only got more and more expensive. So, I got increasingly more and more frustrated until about day two and a half. But that's what Blizzard Entertainment does. True. Blizzard's got it done right. The hard longtime paying customers are not players, they are payers. Honestly, that's how I should approach my own stream. Everybody's just potential subscribers in my eyes. A movie or show with a token character. Yeah, I want to see token characters that are actually just like
cool characters, you know? I don't want somebody's superhero to be like, and her superhero is she's a mom and being a mom is the hardest job on the planet. Like, no, dude. I watch these action movies cuz I'm a loser that wants to see like, you know, the loser boy be reincarnated for the 500th time. Like, just give me my slob, man. Give me the slob. You're saving your sub for an e-girl. Is that why you're not subscribed? Mods, ban that guy. Listen, if you're not going to
subscribe, it's just, you know, why you my chat? You play RF chieftain so you get AFK content. What if I told you that castin stun ultimatum or similacrims is some of the best AFK content in the entire game? I was doing sanctum on one account and AFK simulacrims on another account and I was printing. I didn't care about dip per hour. I was caring about fun per hour. That was a lot of fun. I hope both of those build I hope I can do both of those again next league. If I were to do it again, uh I made the
mistake of doing the sanctum armor on a second account. The second account didn't have any tabs, so I couldn't like stash away everything, so it got really annoying. Don't ignore my sub. Who are you, bro? Oh, is that Bredice with the 17 buds? Yo, thanks for the sub, dude. Appreciate that. Spectre Blight, I have no idea. I'm not like a loser, so I don't really play minion builds. Sorry. Wish I knew. You can go ask one of the minion losers though, so they would know. minus $6.
Amen. Listen, usually I'm in the middle of like ranting about some random thing. I don't actually mean to skip any subsort. My team won't let me play Econ. Robic, it's time. Tell your team that it's tight killer sanctioned, that I approve, that I think that you're in the right, even though you're usually wrong. How about that? That's 107 life with reds and no boost speeds. That would only slow me down. Uh we just kind of drop the hero device now. Oh, we have another skip coming up,
but it's not like a blink arrow exclusive or anything. Attacks with the bows. Thank you. We have like no HP right now. Again, you would grab a cutie if you needed more accuracy, but I don't. New Iron Man. Haven't played Runescape. Uh, mage training arena is good because you need bones to peaches for some content. That's a good unlock. And you need the boots because they're used for they give magic damage. You don't need the boots, I should say. Don't need the boots, I
guess. Wait, do you need the boots? I think you need the boots for the upgrade, right? I think I went back so I could upgrade from this herb thing. Uh, and then yeah, you can get the wand since it's used to upgrade Kodai. I think I ended up getting the wand just because I really wanted the mage XP and honestly it's pretty good mage XP. I always forget there's like this weird like mid game era that every Iron Man is in where like they don't quite have enough magic XP to like do efficient TR
like you can't burst yet but you're like past like the like teleport to Verarok is good XP per hour stage and like in my opinion that's a good time to go like high alking at mage training arena he would be for lightning strike uh I did a four stone run with bub guns lightning strike that build is very boots for the Cberus boots. You get like uh one of the stones for magic and then it upgrades it to uh higher spell mage damage cuz they did a big overhaul to uh magic damage calcs. Yeah, if you're
looking for a lightning truck build for next league, I would just anticipate it getting nerfed. Is this any good? It's 70 life and res. I think that's pretty dope. Open suffix would be amazing. Such a fine example of womanhood. Insane. That wouldn't disappoint me or my husband. Oh, it's for Lumby Dire as well. I was just kind of thinking about like like Bandos and Criara. I guess you use that Sarah as well. Do you use that as Zami? No, cuz they're demons. Ancient scepter. Oh, I I don't I don't
That's not a thing that I got. You know what I mean? Oh, lightning arrow. Yeah, I'd recommend uh Havoc's POV. Also, if you want like a little cheese, you can just you can do this and then you can go dork it in. Do something. Whatever you want. There we go. All right. That is not your guys' assigned to door. Just saying. It does waste a little bit of time though cuz you do go to the looting screen, right? I want the gloves and I want to sell like literally everything else. Am I still in the chest? It's
good. Oh, it's got 4.6 life regen. I didn't notice that. So, I'm keeping what the gloves and that, I guess. Yeah, I suppose so. Sure, man. Why not? Uh, I'd really like to have some leech. Is leech more important than Oh my god, I just got stunned in the global circle. Is that my first death? I think it is. I'm not resetting off deaths because you would never walk into Act 6 with 1k HP and we're going to walk into maps like 1.5k HP and it's going to be miserable. You would absolutely never do
that in hardcore ever. So, uh, potentially new bow. Is that 145? Did I do bull scope once? That seems rationally fast. Hardcore viable. Yeah, we're not playing hardcore with this build ever. Literally ever. Not happening. The belt is actually some lightning damage. Oh, it's movement speed as well. Shocks are reflected back. What if I use the Oh, I don't have enough strength anymore. All right, never mind. I was like, "What if they're hardcore viable?" You could technically take a bow build and farm a
little bit more and go a little slower and cap suppression and get good life, but then your damage sucks. You can't really do the melee thing where you click like or the alkaiser thing where you click like two damage wheels and then the rest are like either war cry speed or light or defense or max res. You can't really do that. Yeah, you can go Bama. Bam is really good. Uh, totems are probably fine. PR, whoa, I would not recommend that. I scopes, uh, peon. You're scared about PE2 design
coming to PE1. I was scared as well. Back in 2019, they overhauled act one. That's when they changed mud flats to be terrifying. They added those really scary mobs in lower prison. I think that's also when they added an evil to the uh cursed guys in act one or in lower prison I mean and I was like wow I really don't like this and then they changed act two and not much change but V ruins is noticeably a lot scarier than it was before and I was like I don't know oh they also changed Mervail in the
Metamorph update and I was like I don't know if I like this and then they stopped and they didn't do it anymore and it's pretty clear that after After that, after that patch, they realized that PE2 needs to be a separate game and they can't just continuously upgrade update the PE1 one into the new campaign cuz I think it was supposed to be like, oh well, if it's if it's like PE 2 or the second new campaign that they're adding is like super easy or super difficult and the old one's super easy,
well, people are just going to choose the old one. So, we have to like change the new one. That was like some pretty clear like PvE 2 game design coming to PvE 1. What's ideated it ever since then. Uh, please revert that. It's one of my biggest requests. It used to be that vendors would reset every single level and now they don't. They just reset randomly. And the biggest idea is because in PvE 2, you will run I'm going to essence this. In PE2, you can run into like a random vendor and find a huge upgrade
but not have enough gold to buy it, which is pretty regular occurrence. That's 100 life in dual res. Wow. Okay. How are the helms? Actually don't know, you know, for a fear essence. That really shouldn't have happened. Hang on. How much damage? 3,800 to 4,100. Yeah. And it's also 100 life. I'll take that. Do I have enough accuracy for that? Hang on. 1252 accuracy and 1241 life. That's my time to start taking some actions. But they changed it so that sometimes the vendor will sell an item
for an alchemy or sell an item that's much higher level than you, like three levels higher rather than one level higher. And then on top of that, the vendors will just sometimes reset, not regular reset. So, what do I do about this resist ring, though? Um, I have an axe ring. This kind of might own my fire res. Still about 55 60 all. Yeah, I'm down for that. Why not? Um, what is minion speed? Cuz that's what the that's what the fear essence is. At the end of the day, that's what it's all about. It
is a suffix. Unfortunately, it would have been really insane to have a three mod uncr. We can do elemental damage to attacks. I'm okay with that. proper, babe. I'm in danger. You don't have two alchemies in act one for like a three league. No. No, I actually don't have two alchemies in act one. Believe it or not, this bow I think is actually worse than my current one. this dude. Scary stuff here. Scary stuff. I need another red gem. That's what I want. Uh, you know what does have
a red gem? Is these gloves right here. 70 life. I need more accuracy. I'm struggling. All right. I have 1400 accuracy and 1383 life. Okay, I can't equip the gloves. Otherwise, I don't have enough uh accuracy to overcome my life. So, yeah, we're just going to grab a cutie then. You always die in this map. You just place a portal on the boss and just, you know, kind of burger it if you're dying on the boss usually where I find a lot of megas. I mean, you leave from the boss arena anyways.
So, how about just getting less life? Yeah, that I mean, that is an option if that's the route you want to go down. Sure. But usually die on the way to the boss. Uh, if you always die here, then get a bleed immunity flask or a bleed removal flask on life. Only you could on mana, but getting on a life flask will make you a lot safer. Sorry. Big fan of courage the cowardly dog. Why is everybody doing bow runs? Uh, the reason I'm doing bow runs and why everybody else is is cuz Fub gun is like you guys can't do bow runs. Bow
runs. Bose sucks in the game. Bose can't do anything. So, we're all doing bow runs to prove him wrong. And now he's got like 500 different bow runs to study from. And now he's like able to go. Hey guys, [ __ ] gun here. Yeah. So, after 500 different speedruns, we found the best setup. I didn't say that. You said bows can't do T7s without huge investment. Buff bows. I need other people to do the run for me. Listen, I know what your game is, dude. I know what your game is. You're playing
the long game, dude. I get it. And it worked. Holy. He admits it. He admits it. How do people not take damage while using the blood magic? Notable. They do. I'm not sure what you mean. Uh, typically in that case, they have so much regen or so much leech that they just outweigh the amount of damage they're taking. You're just going to go peacon and econ. Oh, well, I mean, yeah, you could definitely just do that. Honestly, that's probably a better play regardless, but I do find that XP in
this build is insane. The speedrunner nerds do the homework for him. these fields. The problem is that the build is so alienated from an actual bow build that like in my eyes, a lot of people would be very upset to level with like a completely different skill, especially when like leveling his bows is okay as long as you're okay with dying here and there since you got away. Yeah, fair enough. There's a decent chance that like some of these skills just like get randomly shot. So, Ailia patch notes.
Just remember that any build guide you see is pure speculation. And if it's not speculation and then the the guide is trash. Okay. You dislike it, huh? Well, maybe I dislike you. Sorry if you couldn't tell. I'm really bored, so I'm just like stirring up stuff. How's my amulet? It kind of sucks. So, if I find the thing, I'm going to go back for it. Yeah, I'll go back for that. Why not? Whoa. You prefer rain of arrows? Yeah, re of arrows is slightly faster than lightning
arrow. However, I don't like using it. So, that's it. That That's really the end. Can I Oh, I need that. I'm so glad I wasn't able to land the uh the linker across the the water. Six locker. Decent chest piece. I could yolo five link maybe. Seems kind of stupid to go for that. Wait, so when you're perma resetting act one, you go, "Guys, look, I'm doing I learned this from Tai Tai." And then you just reset the run. Is that what you do, bro? Oh my god, dude. Stop xding. It's a
lot of bow damage to the bow skills. I can maybe try to compare these two. Hang on. Let's see. Uh 6,100 to 6400. Yeah, sure. Don't I lose 110 life, though? Yeah, I do. Okay, never mind. We're going back to the old setup. 1426 1738. All right, now we got 1784 21 minute. Yeah, 21 minutes is fine for me. I'm getting sub 21. I don't remember what my act one time was. This one, uh, I need to go back and vendor pretty much everything here. How's the bow looking? Is the bow looking?
4520 to 4570. It is technically looking. Yeah, sure. Why not? So, I'm going to vendor that. I'm just going to sell everything here. No, I like these two items, don't I? Yeah, I do. I'm going to grab the amulet quest. I need three green, one red. Okay, you're not going to give that to me very easily. No, you are not. Put away the jade flask for now. I'll put away this ruby ring. I'm put away these gems. Play the shav item. Put away this currency art. Yeah, sure. The ruby flask honestly is just for
eater ex or exorc. So, I don't even need that for this millennia. Um, do I do too much fire damage now? I might actually just do too much fire damage. Yeah, I do too much fire damage. I could turn that off. Uh huh. This is a weird scenario to be in. The new bow does too much fire damage and I can't take key back do any take back seas cuz I already got a new bow. Uhhuh. Yeah, we're not proing Trinity anymore and we're actually losing an immense amount of damage. We do too much fire
damage. There's a net this run. That's not happening. I mean, technically, it's possible. Just improbable. All right, we're going to do the degen strat of activating activating angel, then turning it off, then activating it, then turning it off again, then activating turning it off again. We could run wrath. I No, I'll never be smart enough to use that gem. Yeah, it's not going to happen. I can get a new amulet. And maybe the amulet I can craft flat lightning instead of flat fire.
Hopefully there's no thing in the bottom left over there. I don't think I've cleared this way before. This feels weird. Ah, I found it. I'm do a much later lab. Usually I do lab right now after getting all my skill points, but I want in strength. Please be good. It's dual res. Hey, nice. And I lose the fire damage, which normally is bad, but here is good. Burning is the beginning. I have enough accuracy now to be able to equip this, I believe. Hey, stop. I'm going to take a quartz flask. You can
alternatively take diamond. If you're doing like a super long run, you definitely go crit, but I run will suited that. Let's go craft some res. Let's also go craft some flat damage. And let's make sure that my damage is fine. Yeah. So, our fire damage is way too high right now. So, I'm going to craft lightning damage. I can't craft a higher tier, unfortunately. This can have attack speed. Seriously. Six alts. I'll take it. Why not? It's a really good item. Um, anything else I can craft
on? I craft elemental damage attacks on here. I'm like completely out of alts now. Maybe that was stupid. Uh, this does have an open free. I'm down just to craft flat lightning. Never mind. I don't have four transmutes. And I need either fire or cold res. What can the belt have? The belt has nothing. Can this have anything? Can this have anything? We do like cold res, I guess. Um, yeah, we'll do cold res. Yeah, we'll do fire cuz I can have cold. Slap this on. We'll just hold on to that, I think. Put
these two items away. So, this Yeah, I'm going to I'm going to wait for X70 over to do my quest. There we go. Was I able to fix my dilemma? Kind of sort of. It's a little weird still. Yeah. I mean, I have to min the fire then maps with lightning. Did I ever explain how Trinity works? I feel like I've explained it like 500 times already. Basically, you want to do two different types of elemental damage. And you need to alternate, not alternate, but you need to at some point within 4 seconds, make sure that the
highest damage you do is one of the two. So, lightning is usually really good for that. Let's say that fire and cold damage are like between 40 and 50 and then lightning is like one to 100. not entirely number accurate or anything, but they're gonna have pretty similar averages. However, lightning will occasionally hit higher than 50 and it'll sometimes hit as low as like 30. And in those cases, in the second case, the fire hold will be higher. So, shadows with um sometimes we have trinity.
Sometimes 52. How much do I have? 1,600. Okay. I can't click the door, dude. I'm like too stupid. Door's stuck, man. Door's stuck. That will make sense to like five people. I swear if I find a bow that's better, I'm going be really mad. Okay, this bow is pure fizz, which also always sucks. Need more strength, bro. I've been trying to go to the gym. I'm bulking. All right, not gaining weight. I'm bulking. A ballista believer. Well, I have a one link ballista, so I'm not
up to that just yet. I don't know if I call it a believer. Oh, three transmutes. I need those sooner. Where were those earlier? Can I still craft flat damage? I can on this ring. Am I holding on to the ring for a long time? I guess I am now. Could grab a clover. Oh, wait. Did I craft res on this quiver? Oh, I can't have res. Uh, let me craft flat lightning damage on the quiver. Go with that. Have more than that. If you're struggling with accuracy still, even at this point, you just this
little master here. 500 500 little things. I'm going to go grab leech. I like the loot node. Let's uh fix our lighting damage issue. Let's craft flat lighting on the Oh, actually, I'll craft on this ring cuz I probably won't leave the ring on for very long, you know? So, like it being a pretty mediocre role is perfectly fine. Anyways, back to voice. We could already did an act eight, dude. That's the two hour mark. Kind of a crazy time considering I usually aim for entering
X7 at the 2hour mark. It already ate Silk, right? I'm going to be honest, guys. I used to kind of question mark uh Silk for getting with the spider, but now that I'm a little older, it's like I get it, you know? Like I would, you know? Hey, maybe maybe I'm alone in this one. Wins the mine run. Uh, well, I don't I don't believe in miners, so I'm not doing that run. Sorry, bud. I don't even know what mines are good right now besides power seven mines. Power seven m
just kind of BTFOs everything else. So, I don't think uh you really play anything else at the moment. And then it's going to get blown out of the water in the patch notes. I think it's going to get nuked from orbit. I think it's going to get destroyed, deleted, demolished. Pub sub barking, please. Thank you. That's what I'm saying. Kip. Seismic trap. I don't know what that one do. That one's kind of wild. Regret chance orbs. What the chances of that? Any movement speed? Yeah, that
that would be suck. Honestly, my life right now is looking kind of looking kind of good. Trickster's funeral. Will you be there? I actually kind of like this chest. Six sockets are really good because they're what is it? A lot easier to five link than they are like as like a five socket. And obviously trying to six socket your own item is kind of cockable to Okay, let's go this way. Uh hey, I looked into going the right way for once. Uh what is this? Chin. You can do chin. It's not a bad idea. Let's
give me some monies. I'm going to try a new pathing through act 8 that I saw. Power class astral projector. Well, if you have astral projector, then you have enough to go a lot of different really cool builds, but I ran through that. I'm getting silly with it. I love this barrage setup. Got to replace the momentum somewhere. Guys, please stop barking. I need to focus up. Listen, I was a Pyro Quest believer. You're talking to a number one Pyro Quest enjoyer. Even Even I think that gem is
kind of falling off. Unless you're playing Hex Blast Vines, in which case you can't level with Hex Blast Vines, so you kind of have to play Fire Quest M. Yeah. GG targeting nerfs based on Fub Gun's video. Amen. Get that guy nerfed. Get him out of here. I hate that guy. boots were your own worst enemy. Give me the res. This is three chaos resist. This is two weeks power cost the best skill in the game. Holy. Would you guys bark for a goth girl? You don't want to know the the the horrors that I would go through.
You know what I mean? The list would be long and extensive. No. Oh, okay. Oh my god. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead. Okay. Remember when I was kind of meeting on that heals instantly on low life? Just saved me. Pyro class dead eyee. I think we were in a different kind of mine back in the day. There was a race I was racing against Garatha and it was like a ranger race and I believe I died to DD, but he uh he was playing dead eyee and he was playing mines and I was playing like a generic
bow build and he ended up I believe winning the race because Hailwind scales mine throwing speed and the build actually looked really sick. Give it to me. Let's do these both. There's no move speed on these. They suck. All right. Yeah, that was a pretty ingenious build back in the day. Uh, chrome item. Give me that. Down to plan. Let's level barrage up in the off hand. I'm going to remove the momentum support over here. Leave the Ellie hit there. Let's get Clever Thief and then we'll take leeches
instant or uh there's a claw here. I don't need that, but I do need the boots. Should stay dead. It's time to let go. Did she just say that? I don't know. I don't really pay attention whenever women speak. At least I think that's what my last girlfriend said. Right before she broke above me. I don't remember. I'm going be honest. Wasn't really paying attention is decoloning. SGE. I mean, like I said, I wasn't really like I was there, but I wasn't really present, you
know. Let's see. All right. Let's see if I can do the new AFK pathing. Basically, it goes something like this. We grab Hang on. So, we grab the skill point and I want to look for the side area. Where's the side area at? I have no idea. I actually have no clue. Okay. Well, I don't know how this is going to work if I can't find the side area. There's like a little side area here. Does anybody know where it's at? I I don't know where it's at. Is it in a side zone? Like, is it in a All right.
Well, never mind. The secret pathetic was supposed to be like I go into like some little hidden cave, some little hidden caveat thing. There's a side area here in this zone that lets you go into the sewers and the sewers can take you to any almost anywhere else in the act 8. So you can go to like bath house, you can go to uh Solar's concourse, Lunar's concourse. It's weird how it spawns. Yeah, maybe I got to study up on that. I was really looking forward to doing it, but you've never found that ever. Maybe
I'll find it a bit later on. It's pretty common to find a Solaris concourse, but by then it's like, why even bother? You know, middle open area before the gemling. Oh, so you have to go back. Okay, maybe that's what I was missing. Yeah, maybe I walked right by it then. Yeah, it's not been in the game since that day came out. It came out when the uh like weird little extra things came out. Yeah, I we could just always do the old paddthing of just going to Solaris, then going to Lunarus, then walking
over. It's fun. Let's see. Three streams. Whoa. Any tips for Storm Run for campaign? always struggle on map frog. Uh yeah, always go for unwavering. You don't have to always go, but I like unwavering vision with uh map completion. So like plus one maps and then also getting Kiraak nodes is really good for sustain. And also just moving up in map tiers generally as we So I recommend looking at those nodes. I I also recommend grabbing the uh the betrayal points are really efficient. It's like four points. Low essence big
essence too. It's like four points for uh a bajillion XP and then also unveils are really good. And the thing is, yes, you'll be able to find unveil mods out in the world that you can then craft, but like the whole reason why you want the AoE or projectile things are so you can grab a plus two, not so you can just craft like pierce an additional time. Uh, you want the plus one min endurance charge. I'm going to hold on to those so that you can have uh, you know, endurance charge on kill, not just for the plus one min
endurance charge. Does that make sense? Basically, there's a bunch of There's a bunch of unveil mods that you want the entire thing, not just the like craft. So, there is also the the resist plus chaos res that you do want. So, that is that is a thing. Let's do leeches instant. Let's go life blasts or life nodes. Yeah. How do you set up betrayal? There's no like board setup. You just always choose to kill a member to level them up. Other than that, you either imprison them or
bargain. Like it's not like that. Yeah, I really liked old chaos orbs or old veiled chaos orbs. Those are some of my favorite currency things. Just like taking a random amethyst ring and slamming that always felt good in my eyes. They weren't always like well rolled, but they were kind of neat. Be surprised if they change how it works. Yeah, I wouldn't be surprised either. I mean, maybe it's a maybe it's a drop specifically from betrayal mobs to add more rewards because the mods are
becoming just findable on the Atlas now. Who knows? Yeah, I remember some chatter put me on them and he was like, "Why don't you craft with these?" And I was like, "That sounds stupid." And then I tried it and went, "Oh, oh, that's really good. That's bloody brilliant." Let's take this heavy belt. See if it rolls well. It rolled 94 life and strength. All right, I'm down for that. I'm playing D2 right now with this level of magic jewelry. Gravicious nerf. Yeah, I mean
graious on transportation giving you full diffs is kind of crazy. It's kind of nice. Crazy. We're kind of underleveled. Nope. We're perfectly fine. Uh you want to be level 54 entering BA. We're going to be level 56 and we're no close to BA. I am a okay with my XP right now. In fact, in these like two stone runs, we don't really even farm be almost at all. You guys can believe that you do want to be at least like level 58, level 60. We don't want to Oh my good. Yeah. Okay, sure, man. Whatever. You don't
want to go full havoc and be like level 59, level 60 by time, cuz in my opinion, entering maps at that point is a little silly, but you know. Can we change Friday to Thursday? Why such a lightning arrow at level 12? Let's grab plus one pro. Read 26 reveal. Oh, is the is the 5th of a Thursday? No, it's it's going to be on Friday. Sorry. I mean, think about it, right? A lot of people are going to come into the channel. They're going to be like, "Oh my god, I die. What do I play? Look at
the matches." At least 64. uh at least like 62 like bare minimum. Could be lower if you really wanted to but yeah when they added this little thing there's like another one in the zone New Zealand Friday. Yeah. I mean that's just how it be. Hey, look. As long as the patch is good and they don't announce that they're changing every skill gem in the game, but also they don't put the skill gems in the patch notes. So, as long as they don't pull that, then I think it's
fine. Masculine Monday. I don't even know what that would entail. Start a petition. Why? Oh, so that aligns up with fanboy. Okay, sure. Mask of Monday will require you to show. All right, you know what? Fire thanks to the four months and you had to save. Give me a thicket bow, please. It would be nice to find a new one. That bow sucks. No, I'm not adding new days, guys. Did you watch the race yesterday? I heard that it was super close and there was a hidden racer. Sounds kind of cool. Sounds kind
of neat. Ow. Scour alts. Give me those bower. Emple leveling econ. But I think those are chill. The muscle shirts. What do you mean? I'm already buffed. I don't need a muscle shirt to be having one of these. You know what I mean? Weapons of mass destruction. Check this out. Boom. Sorry. I'd say they wouldn't allow me into into some places like that, but they let me into school for so many years. Hard to forget that I'm in America, though. You know what I'm saying? Take your shirt off. Is there like a
Valerant streamer that like perma streams with the shirt off? That's 127 life. I don't need this crap. Give a license. Twitch is allow shirtless. Yeah, but he doesn't like show the nips. He just like you can tell that he's not wearing a shirt because he doesn't have any like his like shoulders are completely bare. Eunk is only better than Peunk for leveling. Peunk bouncing is super sick later. Probably the best Pv2 event. That's what I heard. The last Pv2 event was actually
really fun to watch. According to some people, maybe it's worth a watch. Worth a gander. Oh, big hatred essence. Give me that. Shark skin boots. All right. Give me those. Looking for better than 20 ms right now, aren't I? Yeah. Yeah, those aren't better. All right. Grace is really good for this zone, but I I didn't take the coward gym. So, Van. Yeah, but that was a long time ago, wasn't it? Bench the bar. I benched the bar. I think I put like 10 on each side. Allow your wisdom to be tempered by the
flames of the past. I don't want to hear from you, Bruce. I think the last time I went to gym was with Moa Girl if I'm not mistaken. She was on her gym, so I said, "Yeah, sure. I can I can go, I guess." Um, I went too far, I think. Let's go back. You put a 100 on just one side. Yeah. Don't do that. Listen, buddy. I don't go to the gym, but I can tell you right now that is not good. Turquoise amulet. Uh, porcupine diff. Yeah. What is that? Iborn bow. Hold up. Hang on. Wait a second. How
much do I have? I have 1,800 acc life. All right. Time to click the 500 accuracy note. We're going to be in some trouble if I don't. Holy. They're staring cuz they're jealous. Yep. That's what it is. They just They can't comprehend it, dude. That's it. You got it. I don't want to get frozen here. That would really suck. I don't want to get frozen. Freeze you when activated. Yeah, I would die instantly. Ranger Gaming. Yes, sir. This is a scary zone. I don't
recommend it. I'm frozen. Yeah, maybe that's why they're here. Who knows? Ow. one auto attack moment. Uh, we could make this bow be pretty good. Let's go ahead and just Do I want to throw the really big cold res essence on it? I kind of don't. I also don't want to alk it. Let's throw the medium cold res essence on it. Yeah, sure. Why not? It landed some lightning damage. It should be an improvement. It's also a sixlock kit. Time to slam. I We're not slamming anything. It's not
Pv2. Ow. All right. Um, let's see what happens to my damage. 6,100 to 5900. Yeah, we lost damage. All right. It's about what I expected from a millennial. This bow. Oh, it's not even 100 life. All right, never mind. That bow sucks. Can I get out here then? All right, give me my skill point and let's go lab it up. I probably should have done lab before fighting these two bosses, but whatever. Uh, what was I grabbing? I was grabbing accuracy. That's right. Plus 500. Cruel lab. I think I had that
pulled open, so I don't know. Is watching. I hope I do. Oh god, there was an update on June 1st. Oh snap, I didn't see that. Where are we going? Just waiting to verify that I'm human. There's a dark shrine here. I'm down for that. Also wants me to go top left. Sure. Uh, extra unique. I guess it's cool. Sure. What level is the slab? 55. Yeah. I mean, we're a little overlevelled for lab, but I kind of like the fact that, you know, since slab isn't like super important, but we don't want to be too
overleveled, otherwise we get penalized. OP. Weary traveler. We just swap back to bows once you get your merk lab. So, we're going to take far shot here because it gives us 30% more damage. It's just nice for break point of just being able to kill them slightly off screen. And it's endless munitions as well. And once you have endless munitions, you're perfectly good to go uh back to LA. It's also the time where if you're playing rain of arrows, you switch over to LA. Once you do that,
hopefully I didn't kill this uh portal over here. We did. Sad. I wanted that thing alive. So I keep spread if the forest is dry. One thing to note is that blood rage can and probably will kill you if you run through traps while you have blood on. So careful of that. Drop six link wind ripper. I don't think that bow is very good anymore. That bow used to be dominant for like numerous years and I think they gutted it. The scour. Did I leave a scour behind? Oh no. Oops. That gives you a key. Uh, dark
shrines have different effects. So they can give you a shrine. They can give you a key. They can give you an extra unique. Uh, an extra enchant. I don't know if I said that or not. Extra enchant's pretty much always what we're looking for. Or like an acceleration shrine. What do you do if you get bad socket RNG? Then you just suck it up and you just basically you always need a house. So you always need like your three link and later on you need a four link. Other than that, it's just a bunch of optional
things, right? Uh those are okay birds. Yeah, a lot of time you just kind of have to suck it up and take the worst item. Yeah, unfortunately I got to kill one of these. I don't want is to be jar joyed up. What is alive? Quick silver imbued. Gross. How do we have 2500? All right, that could be fun. There's a dark one in this zone. What is this? Oh god, that's not your nickname. Nobody calls you that. But yeah, if you get really bad socket RNG, you basically just put your three link or fourlink somewhere and you
just try your best. Like you have to think about like what's mandatory right now. I need to not get hit at all or I will die. Like what's mandatory right now is my lightning arrow links. Those are non-negotiable. I can't play without my fourlink. Ow. So I need a place for that. sequences reside. Other than that, I need to have like some assortment of like haste and danger like my auras, right? I need to have some assortment of like gar and flame dash. And if I find like a new helmet that's amazing, but it
doesn't have a blue socket. Well, how do I get that blue socket? There's also an archer in here if I find it quickly enough. Let's see. Let's see. Let's see. Let's see. No, it's it's not here. I didn't realize it was this cool play. All right. Unfortunate. Uh let's go and stash this. That's a vendor, though. Some T1s. That's a really good ring. All right. The boss can and will one-shot us. So, get your LFGs ready. To command is to act. I do too much fire damage again.
All right, we're good. We did it. Boots. Boots. Good. That's 20 ms with 70 life and suppression. If I don't know any better, I'd say it's my end game boots. Uh, we don't have qualities, so we're going to sacrifice lightning arrow. Ice trap, explosive concoction, wild strike. Nope. Okay. Anything actually good besides the boots. The gloves are pretty nice. I like the gloves. Can do Ubers? I mean, if I It's just a math problem, right? Like, do you have enough money for that? That's
That's a you question. All right, here we go. What is it? Be careful. Uh, what do we have? We have these boots that I want to make work. I lose my four link though if I do that. So, it's kind of bad, especially for just 20 MS boots. Man, 20 MS and 30 MS in an entire run is kind of, you know, also speaking of points. Um, I should get 10% move speed. If you've not been here recently, that's a really important node. Is it SF viable? Yeah. Um over in a timeline. I did a four stone uh ele of
the spectrum run. I think it was one of my fastest runs. I also got super spooned on uh all my like conquer drops though. So it was like really really fast. Sell that. I'm going to stash all these essences. Like what am I doing with all this stuff? I definitely don't need rogue markers. That's for sure. Oh, I have a red socket now. Oh, I'm silly. I should just have life cap in this. There is no reason not to have life tap on my main gems. Yeah. Whoops it easy. That is pretty bad not having that in.
Basically, life cap is some weird calculation where because you're not spending mana for the mana forged arrows, you're spending life instead. Because of that, you're always casting the gems. I don't know why it works like that. It just kind of does. So, it's like a huge more damage multiplier. They should. What? All right, subs. Everything done. Very nice. Hopefully that wasn't too slow. Any XP is level 58. Wow. Okay, then let's go and finish her up. Which content will be most
difficult to deal with? Um, living. That's going to be the most difficult content. I'm not up to that just yet. Hardest content is staying alive. No meme bro is goated alther specifically. I don't know if that's you know. Um I'm selling that. Selling that. Stashing these. I think I really want to make this into something good. But we're session pretty much everything here. I don't really want to use the quartz for now. Yeah. Uber Uber Elder out of all the like Ubers. Uh I think awakener would
probably struggle a lot more once I find Uber to be one of the more enjoyable easier quotequote easier fights out of the Ubers. What are you saying right now? I don't know if I like it very much. Mom, come pick me up. I'm scared. You know what's really good with this build? Uh, pierce as well. Ranger. Yeah, ground dots. Uh, there's no ground dots if you kill the squid dudes quickly. Technically, there's like a thousand more ground dots in Cyrus's arena, and they're all impossible to see unless you
have a magnifying glass. So, that's why I say that equipment. Um, a lot of people have been wondering why I take the farot node when we're clearly taking point blank. Uh, point blank is 50% more damage at zero range. So, it's just they do some more damage against bosses cuz you just play up in their up in their face and then it falls off as distance goes on. Well, farot doesn't like fall off. It doesn't reduce your damage if you're close by. And so, by being a point blank, you do 50% more damage and
then you do less and less as time goes on or as distance increases. But farot just make it so that it's like pretty much negated completely. Turd twister. Holy. And where's the thing? Is it over here? Hopefully it is. There we go. They both need a downside. Oh god, it's Gucci. No, dude. No more downsides. Please. I can't take any more gems that do more damage. Only on a Tuesday. Ah, I didn't grab the quiver. I'm going to blow up. does more damage if you've taken more
damage than you've dealt in the last 4 seconds recently. In the last 8 seconds. No. No. Stop. They're adding it as a support gem. Is this the sand? Yeah, it is. It's more damage if you touch grass with the like MMOs where like actually WoW did it where with like rested XP where like you get a benefit for like actually going outside. Where's an emote? I actually have no idea where it's at. Minus 5% move speed. Holy. Wait, that's more Gucci. Oh, yeah. That's the one. Luigi,
you want to go outside? You would play Pokemon Go. I have a couple friends and they both want me to play Pokémon Go. I don't know why. Is it like a girl thing? Cuz no guy that I know wants to play the game. But for some reason, these two girls like really want me to play and they're not like friends. So, I know they're not like playing together. Like, why would a girl ask me to go outside? Wait a sec. Guys, I got to stop the run. Okay, we'll finish it first. Listen, this Hey, I'm a little late. All
right, it's too late now. It's like the bank story. I'm going to die. Nice. I could have respawned in town. Okay, that's some schizophrenia. I don't know if it's I don't know if it's like that. I don't think it's that deep. Let's go point. Alkal G, by the way. Let's get a movement speed if we haven't taken damage recently. I'm going to grab far shot on this little little three node over here. And then after that, I'm going to get the projectile mastery.
Gain projectile damage per projectile speed. There's a lot of projectile speed on this like hard shot node on the tree. And then after that, we are going to grab life nodes. I thought it'll always be there. The run won't. Amen. My family is still harassing me to go on a family vacation later this year. And I had no idea that they were planning for the next league to be in October, but I figured there would be a big chance. Between PE1 and Pv2 development cycle, I figured there'd be a decent chance that
there would be a league in October. And sure enough, there was. But even before I knew, I said, I'm not really sure if I can go on the trip. One, I don't really want to go on the trip that much. I don't enjoy going on vacations very very much. And then on top of that, um I can't take time off work if uh if there's like a pew league. It's it's one thing because I have That's a lot of lighting news. There's like a there's like a concert coming up next month, a
week after league start, which is perfectly fine for me that uh if it was on League Start, I would just cancel my flight, cancel my ticket, or find a way to sell my ticket. But if I had like, you know, like other accommodations, it would be very difficult to get rid of those. And so, holy, that might be more damage as well. Hang on. We do 6,500. That is 5,600. This was 8400. Okay, this is definitely going to way too much lightning damage, though. We're definitely going to do way too much lightning. Hang on. How much
lightning? Oh my [Music] days. Uh, I have to like absolutely minroll on the Oh, it actually works. Wait, it works. But yeah, like I can easily cancel that kind of trip, but I wouldn't be able to cancel this family trip. And so I just told my family like, "I'm not going on the I'm not going on the trip." And there's like a level of, "Hey, we'd really like you to be on the trip." Like, "Oh, that's very sweet. Thank you for thinking of me." And they
went so far beyond that and they annoyed they like every sentence that came out of their mouth was go on the trip. Go on the trip. Now, we can refund this uh small little node down here. Like they got really annoying about it to the point where I honestly didn't really want to I I don't really want to call on the trip at all. Like I want to go on the trip even less after the 500 times that they mentioned it cuz they were just being bothersome about it. And so when I when I told this to somebody
else that I was skipping on the uh on the family vacation so that I can potentially play the 3.27 27 launch, they were like, "Dude, why would you do that? Your family won't always be there, but there'll always be more POE leagues." And in my eyes, I didn't I like couldn't comprehend what he said cuz in in my eyes, it's backwards. My family will always be there. However, there will only ever be one 3.27 league. Do I know where they plan on going? Uh, I don't remember. You're seeing Marie. I don't
know who that is. I have one though. When's the last time you did something with them? Uh the trip that I went on to go to my cousin's wedding and I Yep. That was definitely one of the things that I went to. I didn't have fun. I just kind of went along for the ride. Obviously, I went for my cousin cuz she got married. Good for her. Bless her heart. Pull a Quinn and play from the hotel. Uh no, I don't think that'll work. They did say that uh they have like Wi-Fi on the ship and I can stream from the ship and
I was like yeah no I that's not like I'm not going to be like hey guys here with my beer sanctum strategy. Of course, the my uh my great aunt, she did have a great question, which was what happens if like there is nothing because you're taking the time off like just in case there's work, but what if there isn't like a a league? And I was like, well, that's definitely the worst case scenario, but we have a concrete date. We're doing more sanctum practice. Oh no. I'm waiting for patch notes to
determine what I'm going to do for starter. That's my plan at the moment. FB. Let's get long shot and then let's get that mastery going. That'll be good. Take them to New Zealand. Uh I have a lot of family members that want to go to New Zealand. I don't necessarily want to go to New Zealand with a lot of family members. You know what I'm saying? Yeah, I kind of understand why a lot of POE streamers will like they'll start their stream in the category, stall for like two or three hours, then end
stream. I It's kind of what I did for a long time as well, so I I understand it. How much your income is based on League Star? Um, a lot. Like a lot a lot. For me, it's weird. So, a lot of content creators, they do extremely well on League Start. I do extremely well right before League start. And I didn't understand why. And then I sat down and thought about it. Everybody wants to learn how to level right before a new league. And they they come to my channel as like the guiding light for how to
level. And it's not like I'm disregarded or anything. It's not like people are like, "Oh, I don't want to watch you anymore." But it's um gigantic. It's like when my channel spikes in popularity. As this increase in reduction of projectile speed. Oh god. I just got chilled. And it totally makes sense. I would do the exact same thing. I mean, I I do the same thing when I play a new game. I'm like tier list video for Gooner. Gotcha game. Definitely regarded in some
manner. Thank you. Don't want to feel bad comparing on day one. Well, I have a lot of viewers on day one cuz I'm like purely speedrunning. group players have gotten so good that I don't get naming lights being a solo player anymore. So, I find that kind of sad, but it is what it is. You're just washed, bro. I don't think I can do like a a sub 220 all skill points plus lab run the same way that uh Havoc's team can. Like, they have they have ascended. They are way too good now. play soft course. Even
then, I have to kind of like sweat to beat uh either Kellorn or Lotus. Both those players are pretty good. Tai 23 would do it. Well, I guess that's the difference. I'm not Tai 23. There you go. Listen, I just want to chill out, do some casual run, talk about some fan boys. That's about it, you know. just don't get skill points. That was the PC strategy back in the day and used to piss me off cuz he would he would join a race and then he would skip Dweller and then I'd be like, "Huh,
how's he in act two already?" And then I'd realize that he skipped Fair Graves cuz I would enter the he would like enter Murval's caverns and then he'd enter the second Murville's caverns and I go, "Wow, he's going really fast." And then I would be the first to enter the Fair Graves caverns and I'd slam my keyboard cuz I was really upset. Good times. That was some good times, Gucci. I remember casting those races. I think they were some of my first YouTube
videos. I can go back in time and look at my recap of them. Holy. When is the cyclone build coming out? If I got some spare time before the new like uh league, I'll send a two stone cyclone. I think two stone is like kind of a meh category for build testing overall. But yeah, the method uh GSF race yeah before all the Josh stuff and then method and then the Q streamers left me. That was such a step back, man. Like I felt like we were taking like five steps forward with like Kiwi content creators getting sponsored with
like a huge team and then like literally one guy ruined it. That was crazy. Insane. I need life nodes though. I think life nodes would be good. I have projectile nodes, I believe. Um No, I need pierce nodes. That's what I want. Yeah, sure. Power of one guy. Yeah, literally I'm dropping this. I don't know why I even have that. It is technically a no life mod chest though. What did he do? Um, some essay. Oh god. Uh, basically he uh, how to phrase without getting demonetized on YouTube took a girl without her will and
then everybody on the entire guild knew about it but they didn't say anything. Yeah. What's a good allrounder to do fresh start on? Well, we don't have uh we don't have patch notes. We don't have patch notes, so anything that I say can and will be used against me. And like, Tigga, you lied to me. That wasn't a good build after all. So, I would wait for that. I have a I have a tier list of currently good builds that you could follow. Liar. manipulator. That's me, dude. It's my two favorite activities,
actually. Play whatever Grath League starts. Dude, Grath has been the goat the last decade or so. What's a bad build? A bad build? Uh, I mean, I played some bad builds for four stones. They're basically just builds that don't they like scale really well, but they're horrendous. Day one. Yeah. Uh, I kind of like this pathing a bit more. I'm going to place the portal here. We're going to go get the way point. I'm going to go back from that. I'm down for that Karui chopper.
Holy. All of your builds are horrendous. Day one. I mean, like a build that needs like a pinnacle unique day one. Like some mana forgeos. Like maneros without indiggon. Like that build. Lauo. Yeah, it's Fender. I need the silver flask. I'll equip it later. Actually, I have enough leech to be able to just equip that up, I think. And then here's the other skip. Remember how I was talking earlier about skips? This is the other one. Watch this. Unless you work a GG, then don't watch. Oh, you're a hate watcher. Don't
tell Connor, dude. Don't want to get perm. Listen, I'm not saying I'm a hate watcher, but Rust King is definitely an Uber boss fight. That's all I got to say. Fire grass builds. Those were some cinema different times. What is this invalid run? Why is this good? That's 129 life with 300 accuracy with resist. Is that open suffix? No. But I still think they're good enough to use for the entire run. I'm going to for link those. Those are amazing. They solve every accuracy problem I
could ever have. They have tons of life and they even have a resist. Uh, you mean one banner left? That guy's the goat. Uh, let's arm scrap this a couple times. four socket or link would be cool here. So then I can have some pressure relief from my Okay, that was annoying. Uh three green, one red. Actually, I want three green, one blue. No, we'll do this. And this allows me to equip the boots, I believe. I need to socket the boots so I can get a red socker real quick. Okay, perfect. Now I can place
these gloves. Now I can replace the boots. Am I replacing both? I think I am. Oh, I lost a lot of resist though. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, it's too late now. Points. And I believe it's lab time cuz I've already done the other lab trial. Yeah, I'm skipping Valenta for a little bit. Yeah, it's lab time. All right, cool. Poison tornado shot run. That will literally never happen, Fub. A poison tornado shot run. Why would you even consider something that stupid? There's an Argus here. Uh, I think I do too much lighting
damage again. I was just kind of lucky for a little bit. I could go for an extra key if it's right here. Why not? Yeah, there's a lot of fusing on that. I really don't like using fusings cuz they turn into one to one to chance orbs. And chance orbs are good for maps. So, I really despise doing that. But what can you do? Move over treasure key. Love that. You killed my boy. Is it possible to run an eonger trickster? Yeah. Did we get that gem on trickster? How much lightning damage do I do? Way
too much is the answer. All right. Every now and again though, we will min roll and that's good enough for me. I'm fighting a boss. It'll be up. I just can't guarantee it'll be up consistently. You know, I really want dark shrines, but they're not available till midway through lab. Fortunately, cool news is we get to replace our LMP soon. That will be really nice. In fact, I could probably just replace LMP right now. Where's barrage at? Did I go the wrong way? Oh yeah, this one doesn't even connect to
the boss. Okay, please be close by. Oh god, it's going to be super far away, isn't it? No. No. It is actually super far away. Bam. Been away for a while. Fan of PE2. I'll answer that question. Let me put it this way. I have been feeding for races for the longest time. And the second that I heard that there were Pv2 races, I fell asleep. The weary travel. Skipped races cuz I'm scared of Enormous. Yep. That's it. You got it. What are these fonts and jar oils? I hate that. I don't want any of
those. I don't want to deal with it. I don't want to mess with it. I probably should have waited to kill one more font, but whatever. Sweep the trappings of past emperors aside. Make your empire a new. And Gormas is sus. Why? Why this has to be better than other players? Uh there's a dark shrine here. There it is. Goes to bathroom. What do you What do you mean by that? Dark influence. Uh additional unique item. I don't think there are many uniques that I really need in this kind of
road. Right. Please stop following me for the whole zone. Please, man. I'm so slow. Stop. Temporales exists as an outlier. Uh I think in my opinion that a very good mage blood build absolutely smashes a temporalis build out of the water. And when we talk about speed, we're not talking about mage blood and like head hunter and like these endgame builds. I'm talking like right out the gate, I hit T1 maps and I've got onslaught. I've got a quicksilver flask. I've got like more movement speed than I
know what to do with. I've got tailwind. I'm like sure these things exist in PvE 2, but are they good? I don't know, man. POV 2 is just a little too slow pace for me. And I think as we get creeping more and more towards like more and more power, it'll get better. But right now, the game just feels awful to play, man. Uh, which way is to the boss? Top left is to the boss. We are missing a dorky by doing this. Might be a bad idea in Merk Lab. I would love to get transform a gem into its
transperson. Uh, I want to move artillery blista over here. The reason for that is so that I can put on momentum. Just a silly little gem. Okay. So, I'm slowed and I'm vulg. That's what you're telling me. Can I kill these? It'd be nice if I could kill these without me to deal with it. I can I can also just kind of kill him by proxy. Well, he took too much damage. He just kind of died of cringe. All right, I guess so. Yeah, it's not going to be better. Um, top right. Top right. There's a dark shrine in both.
Very cool. I don't want to press a butter rage. I think I'll die if I start pressing that. Yeah, probably. Most likely. Oh, you know what? Pierce nude. Where's this at?ursuit. Momentum seizes. That's probably one of the worst ones cuz I don't care about lab traps in the lab fight. Definitely better in merc than a normal lab. I don't know why that's still possible to get a normal lab, but dark here. I will go out of my way. So, because we have so many dark shrines already, because I already have two of
them, the next one, well, it's not guaranteed to be divine font, gives you an extra enchant. It's a lot more likely, right? Because we've already got these ones. There's not many more. It can be. It can be drops an additional key, gives me a shrine effect, or it can be plus one enchant. And we're hoping for plus one enchant cuz these can also give like good quality. Merkel lab is just good to farm. Uh, we got an acceleration shrine. That would have been amazing on the first room. We'll still take it, I
suppose. I don't think I'm ever picking up gloves ever again for the rest of the run. An aspirant can afford to be It's going to be shrine. How did you know, dude? How did you know? All right. Um, vendor. Hold on to that. All right. Is everything here just a stash? Guess so. I stand over here so I should slam that. Never mind. Uh, the unique is a winter heart, which is actually very good. You need cold resimation bow. Let's get endless munitions. Is this a Russian streamer raiding me? What's going on here?
Lightning arrow, transfigure gem, DD scavenging, bladefall, mirror arrow of bomba. Yo, lotus. Thanks for the raid. I'm dying. Help. Lotus, please stop garing. I know you brought your viewers over here. But like, come on, man. You're a moderator of my chat, and you're just going to sit here and just type Garf. Seriously. Okay. I'm missing Valento, but I believe that's all. Yeah, it's just Valento. All right, now we have multiproge. We can take off. Oh, wait. Um, where did I move that gem to? I had
return projectiles somewhere. Did I not? Did I drop the gem? Wait, I may have put the gem away. I barrage support. Where did I move return projectiles? It's my stash. How we doing? We're doing all right. Burn. How you doing? I have not leveled return projectiles. That's a mistake cuz this gem loses a lot of effectiveness. All right. Raw archer, lightning arrow, return projectiles. We have pierce. So, return projectiles will actually work. had to make sure of that. I have not made a divine life blast.
That is a blunder on my part. I definitely need to be doing that. We'll be good. Grinding Vorcat. Love to hear it. I did something very uncharacteristic today and I reached out to an old friend. And I said, "Yo, what up, dude? I'm a huge fan." And he said, "Funny, I'm kind of a huge fan of you." And I said, "Yo, can I get an autograph? saw you were on Runescape. What you up to? He said that he resubed to Runescape with the boys and they're doing Bandos right now. And
I told him whenever you're done doing Bandos with the randos, you can hit up how about you do some next with the best. And he said, "Ooh, we don't have enough quest progression for that." And I said, "All right, we can do some chambers or Tob." He said, "Yeah, we could do Chambers." And I was like, "Dope. Sounds good, man. Is it just you and the two boys? Like the two of our old friends?" And he went, "No, it's there's actually a third of our friend or our other
friend is here." So there's like there was like four of them. And I went, "Yo, that's sick." And as I'm finishing this conversation and we're like, "All right, man. I'll definitely hit you up later this week. cringe. I mean, listen, dude, we already established the cringe part. All right, as I'm finishing this conversation, I got a I got a message from one of the people who I didn't remember who they were on my friends list. Like, I couldn't remember who they
were. And they were like, "Yo, Pog." And I thought it was that fifth friend, you know, like the other guy that we didn't know about, or I guess the fourth friend. And I went, "Yo, this is so and so, right? Like, you're our other friend. You're the fourth guy." And he went, "Hi, Tai. Do you not know who I am?" And I was like, "No, I don't know who you are." Oh, I just got smacked. I got rise QTED. He went, "Hi, Tai. It's Darth Microtransaction. You added me on
Runescape." And I went, "Oh, yeah. Sorry. I just, you know, I just don't keep track of like smaller streamers, you know, like I was like, "What are you up to though, little guy?" And he said, he said, "Oh, I'm doing fishing." And I went, "You know, life is kind of like fishing. There's big fish and there's little fish." You pick one to put down [Music] here. Let me just put away all this [ __ ] man. Uh, yeah. Let me do this. Ed, what map do I seriously have one of
every single type of map? That's kind of crazy actually. It's pretty uncommon. Instant life flask. Cool. And I think I'm just going to run this. Yeah, why not? Oh, I can't run L restoration. It's not feasible. And then let's try to make this one good, I guess. Where' the transmutes go? They are res. I'm going to need that in about 5 seconds. Yeah, sure. Where's my other flask? Uh, I need another flask. I need a jade, I think. Running a jade. Restor. I don't like
reduced duration. Attack damage leege. Sure, man. Why not? I will hold on to the amulet cuz I'm pretty sure cold is what I'm struggling on right now. But if I take this off, my whole build breaks. So, an ego streamer. That's me, dude. Oh, what was I getting? Oh, HP knows. That's right. Yeah. Yeah. Now you're playing tank DH. Oh, this time I must Did you like hit some sort of wall and you're like, "Man, I don't know if I want to do this anymore." So, you switched over to DPS, found
immediate success, cuz you can play DPS with your eyes closed and your hands be tied behind your back and then realize that you were just doing something fundamentally wrong. So, you're going back to tank. Is that what happened? 2 in is pretty big, dude. 2 in is massive. All right. If you don't believe me, then you should just Okay. Well, never mind. Actually, don't don't do the test. You know exactly what happened. Damn, that's crazy. HPS is going up. W Your GF said three is the perfect size.
Don't worry, babe. The big ones hurt. Am I really about to sub three with everything done? Oh, I don't have Valenta. I'm cheating. Wait, I actually don't have Valent. That's going to be annoying cuz I'm going to have pretty bad res. No 4G armor keys tomorrow night. Uh, I need keys before before raid on Tuesday. I think I'm going to be busy tomorrow, but I definitely need them by like before like like on Tuesday before raid. Does that make sense? Like I want to fill out the
weekly vault, but both days. You'll have to ask our uh our associate friend. You skipped Aberthoth. Whoa, that's cheating, dude. That is cheating. Yeah, doing Valenta earlier would have made that fight so much easier for me, though. Let's see. send a DM. I mean, as long as it's on reset, it's fine. But, uh, I'm pretty sure if I cancel plans again for like the fifth day in a row tomorrow, I'm going to get murdered cuz I may or may not have I may or may not have told somebody
that I was down to play and down to hang out. And then I got too tired from streaming for 10 hours straight and went to sleep. And the next day I had to study for a run. And the next day I Well, that's today. I decided to do a nighttime stream. My mana is gone. Always available for you. Would you count would you call out a work for like just a random burger day? Didn't think so. Let's do something. is coasting. Any cool games to play? Uh before the new PE League? I mean, honestly, I would just tie up whatever
real life stuff he had. I'd play like probably a Terraria run, maybe Minecraft. Who knows? Just time me out. Any predictions on the other teasers? Uh, no. Cuz if I start predicting, then I'm going to get disappointed if they're in any way, shape, or form disappointing. All right, resists are about to get owned in a second here. Oh, I can craft the rest of these boots. Man, these boots are just better and better by the second. The helm has nothing. I do have a better helm though. I have a ton of accuracy
here. So, can't fly damage on gloves. I don't remember. Play clear obscure. Oh, I heard that game was amazing. Uh, you know, for some reason this helm isn't as good, excuse me, as I remember it. Nice res, bro. Hey, look. It's going to get better. All right. Look, if I just equip a flask that gives me uh resistances, it's fine. See, does it kind of sub three? No, cuz I didn't get Valent. No. Sad. Hey, I got like a 30 10 or something earlier. So, I will definitely take the 302 or something. 301. This is
kind of like a lot more. This is a lot closer to an IMX all time than a titiller time. So, I'm pretty happy with that. Unless I die right here. There we go. Chance orbs. We need those. Wonderful. 150 107 125. Yeah, but aren't you a chieftain? You're also an hour slower. Okay, so you're just making stuff up then. That is an insane chest. Holy. I would prefer it if it didn't have life on it, but I think we throw fusings at that. I'm going to try for a fourlink first and if
it doesn't hit, then we go I don't know. I maybe gamble. I'm not sure. This bow is honestly fine. I could just craft damage on it. It's fine until we're a lot higher level. Like once I get higher level, we definitely want to gamble for better. But we have a lot of skill points we can grab. I can grab thick skin. How much axe do I have? 29 hundo. In that case, what we're going to do is we're going to drop the onslide nodes. Yeah, I'm down for that. Talk to Lonnie. Get my passive point.
Get my other passive point. I'm going to sell these garbage items. I'm going to sell this other helmet. I'm going to take this chest. It has chaos res, too. I want a 20 quality if possible. I have no fusings whatsoever. It's fine. I got chance. I got jewelers one. Uh, we four linked instantly, but I'm going to try for another fourlink. I don't know why. Don't ask why. All right, I'm just going to stop on that. I don't want to waste too many fusings. We're going to go
through three green, one blue, three green, one blue, three green, one blue, three green, one blue, three green, one blue. Hello. Where's the chest? All right, maybe I'll go for a different for link then. Okay, I I'm just I'm getting pranked. What the How did it even four off color? I'm out of chromes now. What is happening? All right, give me three green, one blue. I I I've got no words. I I'm I'm going to have a stroke, dude. That was the worst experience of my
life. Plus 200 HP. [Music] Exile. Exile. Uh, if it opens up, it'd be even better. But no, I like it because it has chaos res. It has a lot of evasion. So, we're going for 400 to 800. And then it's also got a lot of suppression or not suppression. Has a lot of chaos res. And I can't equip the am. It'll break my entire build. And this one's okay. Dropping that. Dropping that. Dropping that. Dropping that. Selling this. I seriously don't have any map like completed fully. I don't have two
of them. financially recover. I actually have not because it's like a ton of chance orbs. These I don't have to take anything. Just transmute these all power charge. Sure. And let's get pierce another pierce node. And I'm down to path through these. And I can go and refund these onslaught nodes. Oh, I can't refund these cuz I'm taking leader of the pack. I kind of want to go for the mana reservation on the right. Then just gamble. I mean, gambling is kind of goated. Won't lie.
of nature is absent. Yeah, these aura nodes are four points compared to the three points that the other ones are. They also get flat amount of mana per hit. I kind of like the reduced mana cost. It's kind of sick. This is also effect. So, it's like what? 2% boost speed. The world's smallest bit of fire. Honestly, the effect is kind of kind of trash. I'm down for the extra passive point. Why not? Let's check these two. Let's get banner reservation. Unspec these four points
here. Thank you. What else do we grab? I can grab the mark nodes. Oh, you know what's huge? You know what's absolutely massive is grabbing forces of nature. Let me double check and make sure that I'm not missing anything huge. Okay, every now and again I'll just miss like the piety skill point. It's kind of embarrassing. Nope, we got Valent. We got everything. I'm dying. I'm dying. I'm dying. We're good. Yeah, I'm a big fan of I'm a right side believer. Kill boss. Maybe kill a little
bit more. Okay, not see anything I like through our campaign. Yeah, but I was cheating, right, guys? I was cheating the whole time. Yeah, it's pretty true. Let's grab our first tier three map. Complete it. That way once we complete these other tier 3s, I reflect Ellie immediately. Just coming out the gates swinging. All right, I got six chaos swords for some reason. Reflect Fizz. Will I die to that? Probably. I'm going to click this Pantheon. That's kind of messed up. All right. I don't like
that. I'm going to go over and click these nodes. I'm bleeding. I don't have CBT removal, do I? No, I do not. All I have is a life flask and a dream. I am actually going to bleed to death if I keep bleeding like this. All right, we leech it up. Okay, I we could find a better I got to stop picking up those road markers, man. I got to stop that. I am hoping for a tier four. That would be dope. That would allow me to run tier twos afterwards. Pause. We're going to full full this map. I have so many T1s at the
moment that I'm not like in any desperate need to absolutely sprint towards uh you know full clearing those. But this can drop us a higher tier map so we always full clear it up. Buff bows. Amen. Relic chambers. There's the tier four I was looking for. Wonderful. I'm dying. I'm dying. I'm dying. I'm going to bleed out to Blood Rage, aren't I? Yeah, I will. I saw Havoc kill uber over level 20. That's you right now, bro. Actually, the voice. Uh, forces of nature. That's a
billion damage. That's fact checked by a real PO. Uh, another tier four. Okay. Arch strong box. Always click on those. Heroic shot is one of the best gift cards we could possibly get for this run. Just period. Just 17 chromes right off the bat. Light up the dome. And then I want these chromes as well because I'm just I'm going to struggle on those. I can almost guarantee you that right now. The fact that I even had to convert over my jeweler's orbs makes me a little sad thinking about it now considering how
many of these I got. Oh my god, I'm going to die. I had a leech. I'm dead. All right. Well, we're done with the map anyways. I don't want to run the tier fours until I complete the other tier ones. Let's going to complete those now. What did I get? Garbage. Garbage. Garbage. Garbage. Yeah, they're all garbage. card. Stop lowing me. Listen, we're entering maps with 2.7k HP. It's actually a lot better than I thought. Life of all right. How's the resist? Oh, I see what
we're doing. Interesting. I figured out the problem. We're not capped on res. Why do you run, Jude? Uh we're looking for unveils and every time you interrogate or kill or you know whatever bargain with the the betrayal guys, they give you a huge chunk of XP. Like when I actually have the node spec pretty soon here, watch what happens to my XP bar. Just look at it. And then also they can give you maps, but it's pretty uncommon. Uh we're looking for a little bit of unveils as well, like getting um slow me down.
Endurance charge generation on kill means that we have a lot less deaths over the course of the entire run. So, it's really nice. Uh we don't run safe houses in two stones though cuz we don't need the XP. We just need to be like level 80 and we're fine. And bows overkill so hard anyways that I usually end up like 84 which is way over. Seven. Okay, I have forces of nature. I'm not sure what to take now. I guess more life nodes. Yeah, I'm kind of struggling to come up with other nodes that I want to
take. Like I said, can't really go wrong with 90% of the tree. You just start clicking stuff. A lot of these items are straight garb. Might skip June with the changes. I mean, that's fine. I find that the point investment is so small since it's right there. It's like really nice. A lot of League mechanics, it's like, oh, Legion without all the nodes kind of sucks. Breach without a ton of nodes kind of sucks. Betrayal is one of those like, oh, I grabbed it and it's instantly
really good. Nice. There's no way these gloves are actually better than my current gloves. 126 life, tons of accuracy, resist, and open suffix. Hm. They're similar but better than my current gloves. But I'm going to hold on to those. Interesting. Interesting. That's the chest. Garbage. How about you skip dying to Rose in the mud flats for change? Oh my god, you're getting alted on, pub. I'm just copying. All right. Um, yeah. Remove that guy's mod, please. Mods, please remove his balls.
Thank you. I got 3k accuracy. That's it. Uh, we could always take I don't mind removing the blink arrow CDR. Please stop lowing me. I could always remove the blink arrow CDR since we're not perma blink arrowing like we were earlier. This is not a thinging anymore for me. You know what's really good actually is focus blista. I really want focus ballista on my archer blista setup and I'm going to look for uh instant life flask with like CBT removal or just something really uh rank up rank up quiver
baloney. Yeah, man. I get it. And we got a T2. So before we run that T2, I'm going to grab a T4. But before I run the T2s and T4s, I'm going to run this. Actually got quite a few T4s here. For a bit of completion, a little bit of a completionist run. That bow sucks. Let's go and unveil this. Lightning Chaos R still. Still sucks. What's the reason running higher tier maps before lower tiers? Uh bosses can drop a map tier. So like I'm running tier ones rare and I think like unique mobs
can drop like plus one of the map tiers. So like they could drop adjacent T2s or any T2 I've completed. But a map boss a map boss can drop two tiers higher. So they could drop a tier three armor right now. Siege not it's honestly not a super important rule until you're like later on in maps then it's super important. But yeah. Oh, I missed a currency rare over there. Whoops. Chaos. I'll take that. What do we got? Incubators. Skitter could be really good. It ends up being goated. Unique
item. Uh, I'll probably keep the chest to the longest. This one's an abyssal item. I doubt that'll be good, but I mean I could see like hypothetically a really good stadium device. That could be a thing. Grab that. Oh, you know what? My heavy belt with like literally no resist on it at all. We should probably replace that at some point. Yeah, that would be nice. We'll find a replacement eventually. I mean, we have to, right? Surely make sure it's not Ellie reflect so it doesn't instantly murder us and
then we're good. Yep, we're good. Um I believe I was taking life nodes. I believe I took the master, right? For movement speed. Yeah. We can get suppression if all items have evasion on them cuz they do. Better nerf bows. Amen. Uh, that is a very good chest. I will force locket that and forlink it. 43 dual res, a billion evasion, hunted traders. Uh, I'm not max T4. Maybe run another relic chambers. Not sure. And I don't need to absolutely full clear. Like I don't need to check
every single like side area in this cuz we just need to uh get the completion. Well, I have two T4s, right? So, it's not imperative that I absolutely full clear. And then I mean sell more stuff anyway soon when you're holding hands. Never. I don't like touching people. That's a T5. Lovely. Uh don't curse the skeleton boss. He will kill you. He will summon the dogs on you. Uh same thing with uh slow down. Was it like Necropolis? No, it's um cursed crit. That same boss shows up in another
map and he will kill you if you curse him. So, any advice in gearing? You really struggle with it, especially in two stones? Um Fostus is kind of your best friend. He gives you a lot of gear. Uh, I like doing unveils cuz sometimes you'll find like a really sick jewelry piece. Basically, you need to find like a way that you can enter into a thought process of what's the minimum gear that I need for all these bosses. Cuz if you can look at a gear piece and be like, "Yeah, I can kill you during next arc
with that." Then it's like, "Okay, I don't need to pick up any more chest pieces." I have a nasty habit of picking up way too much gear. Like literally compared to every other speedrunner, I will pick up way more gear on average. That's just kind of how I am. Maybe I'm compensating for something. Who knows? No, I will not be DMing Ru with that with that build. Thank you, though. Let's get life. How much accuracy do I have? I have too much I have too much uh life and not enough accuracy. So, we
take plus 100 accuracy per bow socket. There we go. See, like my gloves are good enough to uh to do the rest of the run, but I am still going to pick up gloves cuz I might find a better piece for now, you know? Like that's just I'm just a believer, dude. I'm just a believer. You know who I am. Uh, I'll just use 124 life [Music] accuracy. Uh, evasion rating any suffix. There is an open suffix. There's also potentially a thicket bow. Got a peep. It's okay mods, but it's not
great. Let's get rid of that. What if they're GG? Yeah, like I don't need any better gloves right now than what I currently have or the other gloves on my stash, but I continue to pick them up. I don't know why. More alchemies. Alchemies are amazing cuz they're fly damage crafts. They're big resist crafts. There's just a lot of good stuff with those. Can I craft this to be better? This bow. I mean, maybe slam like a big essence or something. Did I drop a T5? I believe I
did. T4. This dry city T3. Okay, pick that up. I'm going to hold on to this bow for a sec. Go under this. Let's run a T5 quickly if I drop one of those. Yeah, ancient city multiroj hunted traders. Expedition scarab. Sure. And I'd like to be able to roll this flask to be instant and like bleed of some kind. I see bleed. We need it to be instant. Freeze is also fine. Instant and hinder. No. Instant and recover. No. Bubbling and ignite immunity. I I'll take bubbling over this. Throw it up.
Bubbling and minion. CBT and saturated. Instant and chill. All right, we'll take instant and chill. M down. what I used to gear for without gambling. Let's say gambling was removed completely. I mean, ID scrolls are perfectly valid. Um, other than that, I guess there was no reason for me to throw expedition on. Like, am I really going to do that? Probably not. No gambling. Uh, essences are your best friend. You can click some essence nodes on the tree. If you want to like really slow it
down, just do some more maps, you know. kind of just ID everything angle really. I don't want to get lipped on. If this guy leaf slams on me, I am 100% dead. That's not perfect. Four times jewelers. Is this guy soul leader? Why is he so powerful? Yep, he is. Classic quiver boots. Give me those. All the items suck. ID NPC would be nice. I actually do kind of like the uh ID all option. What if they remake the trade site? Okay, see that's this is where like what if we start speculating on the
new league and then we get our hopes up and then we don't get what we were hoping for and then like all of a sudden the league is a disappointment even though it's like a really cool like idea that they have. It's not the idea that I had, you know. It's like Chad asked me like, "What do you hope for in the new league?" And I say, "I hope we can get items that we don't have to identify." And instead they drop identified and then we can filter by the items so that
we can get really excited for them and we can make like tink sounds kind of like how you can do that in Last Epoch. And also the filter systems in game and then instead they have like just a really cool league mechanic and a really cool concept. And I'm like, "Oh man, I was really looking forward to having items be identified, but I, you know, hyped myself up into to uh what's it called? Something that doesn't exist? Sanctum 2. No. Brandis forum gold. All right. That would be the worst thing imaginable.
Genuinely, that would suck the inbalmer. These guys are pretty good. I was hoping for a yellow map from this. That's why I'm like full clearing this entire T5 six socket. Okay, it's not going to help me. I'm not up to that just yet. Uh hoping and praying for a T6, but I'm not seeing it. Yeah, I'm not seeing the angle. Sanct any of these actually. All right. No. Punch a hole. We did complete a T5. So, we complete this T3. am down. I can gamble for bows if I want. We can also do that soon if I would like
to. Some of these maps are already completed. How many missions do I have? I should check. Diagonal map still work. Yep, I'm doing it right now. Did I get the life note? I did. Let's get a 50% chance to suppress. Got things on all the vision gear. How much res do I get? Okay, we're not capped on res, but I do have 55% uh 55 spell suppress 100% of the time, so that's kind of cool. Yeah, we should probably cap our res. Um, honestly, it's probably going to come down to the belt. I It's fine. Bows are a piece, so
just don't get hit. Well, soul eater strikes again. Also with life regen this time. Okay. Can we not play this game, please? Thank you. Just don't get hit. Amen. I'm not even kept on fire res unless my flask is up. Even with the fire Even with the flask being up, I'm not kept on fire res. All right. Amen. What's that? T4. Okay. I don't think this get belts anymore. Rachi, aren't you the leader? Yeah, you are. What are you doing here? I probably don't need that. Shock
removed. That's probably fine. That could be potentially a very good build, but unfortunately I do need a lot of strength, so that makes it a little weird. Carell, you're just by yourself. Drop a map. Sure, I guess. That item is interesting. Not good enough though. What is that? A lot of cold in that one. A lot of cold. I think it's a drop. I shouldn't be doing research. research is just kind of a waste of time during these two stones. You can do them. What else do I need to mausoleum?
You say I should probably go for more completion then I mean this could have the most insane mod known to mankind. It did not. That was insane mod. Belt could be better if it lands 500 strength on it for some reason. 200DS is actually a really good mod. I like 200 DS regen. Okay, let's uh gambo for a bow soon. Not now, but soon. All right, we have two Carrick missions though. That's kind of dope. I like that. We can buy probably a tier six if I had to guess. Should probably do before running these tier fours. Yeah,
we can buy the tier six map. Dispatch, it's always a castle ruins. And I have a lot of chromes, so I probably don't need to pick up chrome items as badly as I used to. Arc traps or arc mines? Both of them are terrible. Power seven mines a little bit to go. Graveyard map sucks. I hate that map. That boss terrifies me. Haunts me in my dreams. No music. We play uh I'm playing in-game music cuz I think it's better for YouTube. Generally speaking, I I don't know. So YouTube can let me know what they like cuz basically
if I play music on stream I have to like remove it from the VOD. So then you just have to listen to my voice and that's it. There's like ambient game sounds which might be fine for some people. Hopefully the in-game music is appreciated. I don't know. I couldn't tell you. I'm just doing what I think will make me the most money. Call me Blizzard or any company nowadays for some reason. codes. Um, let's grab chances of press and then chances of press is lucky. And down for that, I think we'll stop
clearing up this back right here. Yeah, sure. We'll do the T6 as long as not reflect. It's interesting. Kind of bad though. No, kind of bad. Uh, you know, I don't think I'll be listening to AI garbage on my uh on my YouTube channel. Thank you, though. Or just period. Um, this guy is healing quite a lot. I am Zeps. This guy's stealing charges from me. He's stealing frenzy charges. Like why is he full HP again? Uh I'm going to die if I fight this guy without any flash charges up.
Okay, there we go. I have to kill it though cuz it could drop a T7 map. It did not. Lucky. You weren't subscribed to my YouTube channel. Yo guys, if you're watching this late into the YouTube video, please subscribe. It helps out a lot with the algorithm. Thank you. and # ad. That's right, buddy. That's right in the middle of my video. That's live, by the way. Gloves. Okay, we're just not going to find better gloves, though. I'm going to be so real with you, Tito. It's not
going to happen. Imprison, thank you. Quiver dual res on the quiver. There's a lot of potential in the room right now. if and when but never is. You know what I'm saying? Uh go. There's a Riker baloney here somewhere. I can tell cuz he disappeared and didn't take any damage. Yeah. Uh rank up. Rank up. Maybe I'll teach you guys how the mechanic even works. I don't think I want most of these quivers. Most of these suck. That one's 141 life though. Hold up. All right. I was not familiar
with your game. I apologize. Opinion on new orbs. I really enjoy them. I like more options. I am a I am an enjoyer. I also love veiled chaos orbs, so I like to see those back in the game personally. Ancient city. Is that a Katava's thirst? You know, I did a four stone run recently on uh arch mage ball lightning hierofant. No, I didn't get ball lightning. I got frost ice nova frost bolt thing and I got owned because I couldn't get kava thirst. It was still fine. I still finished it and don't even matter.
It's still one of the best in the game, but it was annoying that I couldn't find kava's thirst at all. Good suppression. That suppression is lucky. Don't think I'll take the full wheel. How much do we have? 3,700 in overtime. This quiver could be insane. That quiver could also be really good. Which one do I want to ID first? Sure. That sustain. Yeah. I'm looking for a T7. So, we're absolutely full clearing. The bananas out of this map. We got 21 mobs remaining. Dude, I think
it's over. I think it's time to move on. Any sort of two stone ring that has endurance charge on it is just going to be the goat here. I'm going to need the the worst one. We're set up with two. Okay, that one's pretty bad. Um, strengthen it. Honestly, it's better that fire res. I'm totally down for fire res. This one's way better, I think. It also gives chaos. It also gives Edwa. Yeah, this I mean there's no world where this isn't just infinitely better than
the other officer. I supposed to max cold res, bro. Uh, this one does 17,000. That one's 18 and a half thousand. All right. Um, let's unveil this ring. We're hoping for plus one endurance charge. I was hoping a little too early, I guess. Yo, Miami 3 months. I really don't need to stash those completion. I don't really want to buy a bunch of these at the moment because I could find them. Natty. Yeah, I shouldn't be buying these right now. You know, I thought you asked a valuable
question and then I realized what you actually asked or what you actually said and now I wish I didn't have views or eyes. Nice. Well done. Appreciate that, bro. Very good. Uh, did I ever fix my res issue? No. In fact, somehow I think it got worse. No, it's better now. We're definitely looking better. Uh, could have crafted res in the weapon, but I don't really like capping res on weapons. So, you were fishing today. Hell yeah. Love fishing. I'm dying. Hang on. I can't focus on your fishing. Sorry.
Sorry. It was good meat. Yo, I love to hear that for you, Autumn. That's awesome. I actually really enjoy fishing. I was talking with some friends, like a couple IRL bros, and we were talking about like manned things, and we were like, "Dude, what if fishing is cool?" So, we went out and we bought fishing rods and fishing licenses, and then we went out fishing, and it actually kind of owned. So, we planned a a trip to go fishing and we brought a couple other friends. One guy brought his
wife. The trip kind of sucked, but the uh the fishing was fun. I really like the fishing uh boots. Gold ring. There we go. Thank you. Good piece of mind. Amen. Brought his wife. Well, one guy brought his wife, then the other two brought their girlfriends, and I um well, I had um I brought a lot to the table, you know. I brought my personality, right? Anyways, I don't even remember what we were talking about, so I'm focus back on the run. I still don't have CVT removal, do I? No, I don't. Um, please stop
bleeding. Penetrating real quick. We're good. Could have bought your bomb. I don't think I gone over very well, be honest. Uh, old veiled chaos orb is one of my favorites. Yeah, I was really mad when they removed it for a veiled orb of like pure gambo two garbage. Uh, do I ever replace this quiver ever? Possibly. Probably not, though. Probably not going to happen. Okay, wait a second. Hold up, dude. Every pack is bleed, man. What is going on? All this is a T3, right? Yeah. Okay. I'm out of here. Could have
brought their bombs. You know that is a cook. You're not wrong. All right. One of these bows might be better eventually. 18,000 to 21,000. It is better. What? Holy fire damage. Uh, you know what? Let's get focused ballista up in this focused ballista. Thank you. And I don't need that old bow anymore. Honestly, if the damage is substantially higher, but the attack speed is substantially lower, it just means the on hit damage whenever it does attack is going to be popping off. Oh, I didn't get the I didn't put the
points in. I thought I did. It's unfortunate. Let's see what's on this legion. What can I stash away? Not the graveyard to run that map, man. Dark forest fog. And then yeah, other than that, we just have some characts to run, I suppose. And then it's off to the races. Hope for higher tiers, I suppose. I guess not. What map is that? Scriptoriium. I already ran that. These are all stashes. Alterations are cool to find. Do enjoy those. Passiporns. Was I getting uh chance to suppress is lucky.
Wonderful. What's this? Did I catch any fish? Yeah. So, I caught a single fish the entire trip. Nobody else caught any fish. I We believe that we use like the wrong kind of bait, but I caught one fish. Um, another friend cut it up and cooked it while I was asleep. They ate it without me. They said it was horrible and they threw it out because they didn't use like salt, butter, and other stuff to make the fish actually taste good. I don't I don't know what was happening there, but they were like,
"Yeah, we're we're saving you the trouble. We figured you wouldn't want to eat this garbage." So, yep. Yeah. That's not why the the trip sucked, by the way. The trip sucked cuz anytime we weren't fishing, I was like, "Okay, so you want to do anything?" And we sat in the Airbnb, watched TV for like hours on end. I went to my room, uh, watched Starcraft Witch, and then I went back and I was like, "What am I doing, dude? I'm on vacation with my friends right now. I could do this when
I'm home. In fact, I do do this when I'm home. What do I want to do with my friends? And then I went back out and they were still watching the same goddamn show. So, I just I just logged out. Dude, you know, let me get uh the bleed node over here. Let me take that. I really do like this quiver, man. Blessings. Uh yeah, did you favorite? You're supposed to get hammered. Uh I mean did have a beer, too. It's all right. I don't know. I'm kind of past my like let's get like sloppy
drunk. Let's go clubbid. I like had a pretty big party phase during college cuz it was uh my roommate was in a fraternity. He would play like Super Smash Brothers and he would invite like his uh fraternity bros over and I thought they would like make fun of me cuz like League player that also plays osu lau but they were totally chill and they really enjoyed hanging out and they would sometimes come over. They would be intoxicated as hell, but they would say, "Bro, that's like sick, man. Like, how
do you even know like how to click that fast?" Like, that's insane, dude. Like, bro, that's that's [ __ ] nuts, man. You know, just totally tripping balls. And so, they they would invite me out to go partying and it was always my roommate's job to make sure that I got home safe. And so, I would party with them pretty pretty regularly. 90% of the time I would not 90 but at least half the time I would say that uh we would we would go out to pregame before going to a party and then every party that we
would think about going to would get cancelled or they would get closed or just someone didn't want to go cuz XYZ person was there or you know it's at this person's house and they don't anyways most of the time we would just end up going home after that there was no party but I I would say I went out like at least a few times games a week. And the final time that I went out, like I said, it's my roommate's job to uh make sure that I get home. I went out with my roommate. I went out with some of his
fraternity bros and a couple of our friends from uh slow down from the like floor that we were on. So, we're all bros. We're all friends. We're hanging out. And we go to we go to a party after the free game and it's not very much fun. So, we moved on to the next one. Well, my roommate's like crashing out and he's like, "That's it. I'm calling an Uber." For some reason, the Uber only had two spots in it. I don't I don't know the lore, man. But the Uber only
had two spots. And the uh one of our other friends, he was also crashing out. He was mad cuz of some I don't know, petty petty drama. And he was like, "I'm going home. I don't care what anybody else says." And I was like, "Well, I'm still willing to go out, right, guys? Like, we're still down to party." And it was like, "Hell yeah." So, we went to another party. It was honestly kind of lame. I lost my other friend that was there and then it was just me and some
of the bros, you know, me and a few of the bros. So, we're hanging out and they say, "Hey, we can go home or there's another party. It's like a mile walk from here if you're down." I was like, "Dude, I'd love a walk. Nice refreshing. Good weather." This is why I hate graveyard. This map just sucks, man. And so we go to this other party and the other party is closing. It is finishing up. And we're like, "Where did everybody go? Why is there like five people here?"
And they go, "Oh, dude. Uh, everybody's there's like a designated driver coming by. He's like doing rounds between this party and the next one. Uh, if you want to wait around." We're like, "Yeah, sure. Why not?" So, I saw another girl that I knew there and they were like, "Yeah, come on. we can uh we can go on the next uh the next ride, the next taxi service basically to the next party. I went, "Okay, sounds good." Well, the car is completely full. Like I'm sitting on
some guy's lap and I'm like, "Yeah, I don't want to do this." And he's like, "Yeah, bro. This is a little gay. I don't know." And so I get out and I'm like, "Yeah, I'll just wait for the next one." And somebody in the car goes, "Yo, go inside and ask if there's any [ __ ] that want to that want to hop in." And so I went back inside and I went, "Hi." Um, are are there any um nice women that would like to uh to ride to the next place? There there's a
spot open if if you'd like. And they were like, "No, thank you so much for asking." And they're like, "Oh, okay." And then they left. The the the the driver left. And then I realized I now have to sit with these women. And they asked me for my name and they were like, "You're a freshman, right?" And I went, "Yeah. How could you tell? They said, "Oh, well, not only did you not call us [ __ ] which they almost certainly did cuz everybody else says that, but um your shoes."
I was like, "What do you mean?" They said, "You have brand new shoes." You know, like every freshman they uh first thing that their mom does is they buy them new shoes before they uh go off to college. And then as you get older, you don't really get those nice things anymore. Holy 128 life. Yeah, I had a feeling I'd struggle on strength, but uh I could just take a strength point later. I'm down for the the new belt, though. My goodness. Any of these actual completion
or no? No. Kurick gives me completion though. And I was like, "Oh, I didn't know that. Thanks for letting me know." And so, uh, we talk some more. They're like not really like in a sorority, but they're they're like their own friend group, so they say they're a sorority. Uh they asked me to drink with them. We had a fun time. We were hanging out. Uh I took the the cab or whatever, the taxi service, the DD guy, to the next party and I was like, "Yeah, thank you so much. It was so nice meeting you
guys. Thank you everyone. Um have a good time." They were like, "Yeah, have a great time. See you around." Tight tight. And so I'm at the second party and I'm just talking to different people and standing off in the corner somewhere and then I'm playing a party game with somebody and and I go, "All right, it's probably about time for me to leave." And I realized that I was in the middle of a conversation with some guy that was like a senior. I was like, "Hey, man. Do you
have any advice for like a new freshman?" He goes, "Yeah, man. My advice is just like find like what works for you, man. Like really? Like my advice?" Oh, also and one other thing. Oh, and also another like I actually was just trapped in a conversation loop for like probably half an hour straight. Well, I wasn't a PE racer at this time. I just like played pew casually and I would stream it to like maybe like five viewers. I was like baby basically. It's all garbage. He was trying to get with it.
baby. And so I I am stuck in this conversation trap for God knows how long. And I finally realized it and I looked over and I was like, "Hey, wait. I got to get home soon." So I looked around for my friend group, you know, the ones that I was supposed to go with to the party. They um Yeah, they were nowhere near there. I I couldn't find them. And so I decided to text one like, "Hey, bro. Uh where you at? Um you ready to go soon?" Haha. He said, "Oh, you're not with us, bro.
We left without you, I guess." Okay. Well, my phone is dying. I have no money and I have no way of getting home and I'm panicking and I don't know what to do. And I saw one of the girls from earlier and I went, "Hey, so sorry to bother you, but um you know, I and I explained the situation and she gathered the other girls and she was like, "Oh my god, we're going to we're going to get you home. Don't you worry. Just sit right here." They got me some water. They sat
me down in like a bean bag chair. They were like, "Wait right here until we're ready to go home." They got me safely to my dorm. And then they asked like I was like, "Thank you all so much." One of the girls was sitting right next to her boyfriend, but she was like hugging me the whole time. I don't know. It was kind of strange. And so as we pull up to my dorm, I was like, "Thank you all so much. I really appreciate it. Like, it's so nice like meeting you all." And they said, "We'll
go with you." And I went, "What?" They said, "Well, we want to make sure that you don't like falling any stairs, so we'll go with you to your room." And I am like shaking cuz, you know, I've seen this situation before and I was like, "Is it what I think it is?" Holy, there are three cute girls. And so they go up to my room and I go, "Thanks. Have a good night." And I shut the door immediately. And I and I went to sleep and I remember waking up and I was like, "Man, that was
a weird dream. Why did I dream that they that they came up with me?" I remember went, "Bro, what the hell were you doing last night?" I went, "Oh, I just like went to a few parties." And he went, "No, dude. Like, why were there three girls in our room? What were you doing last night?" And I was like, "Oh, like that was real. Like that actually happened, huh? After that, I uh I made an Instagram and I tried to find the girls and I never could. And to this day, I have no idea who they are. I
don't even know what their real names are. I don't even know if I'd be able to find them. But if you're out there somehow watching this vault, thank you. Appreciate that. 104 life with the res. Yo, hold up. Yo, hold the phone, brother. I need strength real bad though. Yeah, take a strength node. So, you're a player? I'm not a player. I'm just very nice and considerate and I don't hold anybody on a pistol. Honestly, I throw away more opportunities that I know what to do
with. Maybe they didn't exist. Maybe that would be kind of crazy. I mean, it could be that my my my roommate just made it all up, you know? Could be. 100% certain like to kill monsters a lot. We have Tusen again. Um, could help this guy for some currency, but I'm not struggling too bad with currency. Unless it's chance orbs. You know what? I'm going do chance orbs. I mean, curses. Sure, whatever, man. Yeah, why not? If he gives me chance orbs, it's like 100% worth doing this. Got that OT RZ. What do you mean
by that, goat? What do you mean by that? Or trans orbs. Yo, they're probably in the chat right now. What? Is that true, chat? Is that true? Type one if you're a really cute, attractive girl. I just need to see something. All right, it's me. [Music] Holy. Wait a second. Yo, two coinage. Wait, I never find coinage in these runs. 5C. Can I even buy this? No. Honestly, 2C is like not that valuable either. This is probably more valuable, I guess. Um, five ouch is okay. a coin. I'm just looking for alchemies
or chance orbs. That's it. Literally just chance orbs. And of course, I can't buy this now. Did I can't buy anything. All right, please. Okay, I got chance orbs. I don't know how many I just got. A lot. I got a lot of chance orbs. I win. I win. I have 16 in my inventory. One's like that weird AI one. I don't have any AI stories. I will say that my usage of AI has gone up slightly and I do believe in it a little bit more but only only because Google is so bad. I tried googling
like not like methodology but like you know like what is the process of like moving out of my parents house and all I got were a bunch of articles about how difficult it is to move out of your parents house and I was like yes I know but like how do I go about that and they're like just start saving money just make more move to a lower cost of living like place get a loan get a house why do you need Google for I need exact instructions or I can't function. And so I was like, "Fuck it.
I'm going to try asking AI." And AI was like, "Here's what you want to do. Go talk to a financial advisor. See if your bank has one." Uh I think it was like, "See a financial adviser." And I was like, "Oh, I think um I can go to the bank for that cuz my bank offers that for free." And I went, "What should I bring to the financial advisor meeting?" And they went, "Oh, you want to bring these these documents. You want to bring this from taxes. You
want to bring in this to show like proof of income and like have them walk you through the steps of what it looks like." And I went, "Oh, okay. That sure sounds good." And I did all that. And the guy was like, "Wow, you're really well prepared." I bet I was, dude. I bet I was. But if I didn't have like stepby-step instructions, like it would have been over, dude. I wouldn't I wouldn't have been able to do it right. Yo, Kadex the 35 months. Appreciate that. I guess I'll pick up everything
that I find. How old are you? Where do you live? 25. And I live in the United States of America, brother. I don't need this. Yeah, Google first page is horrible. And it's intentionally horrible. This map is scary as hell. I might not be able to do the other things now. Let's grab the strength node so I can replace the belt of the amulet. I mean, the amulet's insane, dude. 100 life. Like, I'm not beating that. Oh, I need more strength. No kidding. 21 strength. Wait, this has strength on it. Is it just ins? No way.
It's missing like five ins, so I can't equip my gear. That's crazy, actually. Um, if I have an implicit change, I could do that. Ooh, another T6. All right, I'll take that. Yeah. So, I mean, I I want to move out with Pub Gun, but I We're both streamers, right? So, we're both lazy. We're both like not really going to do anything. Uh, so I just wanted to know like, hey, what does that process look like? Like what what do I do, you know? So, it was uh very very good for
that. Is he in California? Yeah, but we want to move to Texas cuz that's where the uh servers for Kiwi are located. Like I was talking to a friend who lives out of Dallas and his ping is three. That's his connection that he just plays on constantly. Just three ping. On top of that, whenever you get into a loading screen, it unironically because the servers are based in in Texas, the duration of your loading screen is dependent on like, you know, your computer and stuff like that. However, the instance creation time, the
time that it takes to actually make the new instance is based off your physical proximity to Texas. So, if you're sitting in Loading Korean for 9 years and you have like a top-of-theline PC, it's because you live far away from Texas. like no meme. You are just at a disadvantage. Holy. What is that? Ancient city. Really don't want that. Do want a bow though. Your ping is eight. Your ping is eight, but your instinct creation time is probably 10 years. I just got smacked. All right. Next map, I
guess. Uh I already have a castle ruins, but I guess I'll run another one. Infeeble. I think that owns my uh my accuracy. Hang on. Do I have an implicit change? I do have one. This is 16. And now it's 19. And I still need more. No way. Dude, I need two more intelligence. All right, what I'm going to do is I'm going to take both of these. I'm going to scour both to be deleled by one. That kind of sucks though cuz Angel really wants a lot of levels. I think what I'll do actually in that case is
I'm just going to No, I need the gems to continue leveling for now. Yeah, we need those gems. That's not like an option really. Can I craft anything? I need a res, don't I? Can I take this off? Okay, life cap does not need to be high level. Let's be real. I'm like kind of risk up now. Let's do that. New York data centers. Uh, it's expensive, dude. Your gay center suck. Just saying. Get owned, noob. Alteration. Hopefully I drop an adjacent T7. That would be cool. Maybe that happens to me
today. Who knows? Did I ever gamble about? No, I don't think I gambled anything really. I should be gambling something, but I'm not gambling anything. Don't know for why. Central or West Coast. True. Is it better to have central servers or like split between like east and west coast though? Like let's think about this. Would you rather have a game that has like two different servers, but they're good? Ping for most people or just one. End of the last stream. Yeah. I uh I had to go to dinner. Uh, my dad made
barbecue ribs. Oh, we did drop G7. Lovely. So, I realized I couldn't finish the run and I just I was already tilted. I was already mad, so I just canceled it. But, we got the run here. This is the run. If that especially if it's a T7. Oh, it's a T6. I didn't know Buffer was a T6. Whoops. I didn't mean to leave them out. It's not an FPS game. Ping hardly matters. You say that unless you're Dude, this guy has never played on land before. If you've ever played PoE on
zero ping, oh my god, dude. Those Exocon races, I can't even describe to you like the difference that like 20 ping to zero ping makes. Like, talk to Havoc about how he feels about zero ping cuz I it's indescribable. Every action you take is instant. There's no delay. We're making hundreds of actions per minute. Like it's some kind of Starcraft 2 game or Brew War game, I guess. Either Starcraft really. And every single one of them is instantly registered. Nothing is delayed. There's no movement that's like
ever like weird, which is weird because you actually play around the fact that it's going to be a little weird sometimes. A lot. uh any other Jason maps. It's a lower tier map, I guess. I don't know if that's the exact word I'd use to describe it. Let's do the T7 first before running the uh T5. I'm down for that. Uh no reflect. It is ali resist though 60. Any 30 ms in the chat? Nope. These all suck. Oh, we got a no making. Nice. Hey, sorry. I'm a noob. How come you
start to play lightning arrow? Isn't Ellie hit stronger? So for Ellie hit you need elemental hit of the spectrum and that comes from lab. And the question is would you rather farm merk lab for an hour and a half or would you rather just go play lightning arrow? And the answer is I'd rather just go play lightning arrow. Yeah, it just comes down to did you get the gem? And we didn't get the gem. So yeah, we're not doing it. of your weakness. Stop that. This I don't want that. This doesn't
really matter. Yeah, you can see my XP just space gliding up. Wait, this could be huge. This bow right here, maybe. Who knows? Would be cool to get a endurance charge ring as well, but I think both my rings are kind of loaded at the moment. I think they're both pretty good. Can we stop this? So annoying. Um, island's already high level. Reach is a high level. This guy on both of these. There's no rare item. I'm down. Unless they're both garbage like that one is. where that came from. It's
going to be reachi gloves. The fist convert. I actually don't remember. I don't think plus levels matter on this build. It would matter if we were uh drop that. Oh my god. It would matter if we were uh elemental hit of the spectrum, but yeah. Have you done a trickster explosive? Uh no. And I don't plan on really doing trickster runs cuz I think trickster is going to get deleted from the game. So oni goshi probably never uh slayer is good though. I don't I don't think slayer I mean we might see
like an endurance charge nerf but you know how is it going to get nerfed? I don't know. Wow. My damage has fallen off a cliff. The bow is like the biggest problem at the moment. The bow was sick in act 10. It's not so sick now, especially in an Ellie res map. Okay, can we fix it? I think we can. I mean, maybe we get a five link bow and gas orbit. Craft it a little bit. Who knows? Glad he streams so early. Nice. Yeah, normally I don't stream at these hours, but I am today because well, I have to finish the run. Is that
a five link? That would be cool. It is not. That both sucks. I'm Drop that. This bow is interesting. Actually don't know what to do with that. There's another bow in there. Okay. Well, hang on. Fix the inventory right there. What are we doing? Put everything away. 16 qual. This could be instant. And bleed removal. That sounds kind of nice having bleed immunity. Alice invitation already. Unveil. Give me that. Um, chance to deal double damage actually isn't too bad. 21,000 to 13,000
to 24,000. That one's better. It's also plus one bow gems. Interesting. Not bad. Air contains good guaranteed. Okay, we need a fulk of the map though because it is a T7. We have a T8 on our hands. I would like to run that. Nice. Lions spell. I do need a gambo as well is another thing I need to do. What did it end up rolling? Another forbidden woods. All right, we're sustaining yellows now. So, that's kind of nice. Grab this point. I think I was grabbing in so that I could replace the amulet and
stuff cuz we're going to run into in problems pretty soon. And now I can replace this amulet. See how's the resist function. It's pretty good. Is that more lightning damage though? It is. Also, it does a ton of strength. I might not need strength. No, I do. Fine with the strength on that thing. Uh, what I need mostly is a bow and or chest. How's the pastor? Worried about my actual resist. I made a run to maps. Yeah, that's why I don't like theory too. Maybe we're missing
tech. It just doesn't feel as in engage to me. A reflect build reflects two physical damage. I didn't even notice. You know what? The reflect two physical damage is probably doing so much that I didn't even notice. It's probably doing all the clear, too. All right, I'm out of this map. Get me out, dude. All right. Hopefully we finish this in the next hour. That would be six health. That is a very good item. You know what? Hang on. 25,000 to 7,000. Okay. 5,000 to 9,000. The amulet or the helm. Pretty
good. Unveil this. Converted lighting. I should have done damage while leeching actually. That would have been nice. Uh I think this bow is honestly good enough to just craft bomba attack speed and call it a day. What is it? T2, T5, plus one bow. Sure, I'm down just to craft attack speed and call it. 9%. Sure, why not? I'm going to try to gamble for a five link. That seems like a value basis to my currency. Clueless. Don't need that anymore. All right. Where's the evasion items?
Can I get better boots? I could get better boots. Let's look for 30 MS boots. might be a might be a waste of time though. I'm going to look for five link. I think it's more important. Some of these items are so well rolled, man. That would be a good item to throw fusings at. However, I don't want to throw fusings at that. I would rather use them on chances. Yeah, I'd rather use them on chances. Sorry, but also I have like the most insane forlink ever. Uh like that's really good.
Looking for a five link. Can we get it though? That's pretty crazy. That's pretty insane. All these are really good actually. Huge evasion rules with like Yeah, I think I think we just take one of these two. Which one's the bigger winner? I think this one's a larger winner. No, no, no. Definitely this one. Yeah, that's a huge win. The reason why it's a huge win is because it doesn't have any life rolls on it. So, we just craft huge evasion rating. We have 2,000 evasion. And then we quality it up.
Fortunately, I can only do it a few times. And we look for a four socket. Fortunately, I'm missing a lot of things here if I do that. Oh well, too late. Okay, now we have 8 trillion evasion. And one thing that's really cool is we can just refund a node somewhere. this small node and we can go 50% max life and now we have 3.5k HP. We are unbelievably tanky with how much evasion we have. Also, we put in this thing as well. The mods are amazing, but we're going to have some problems with things.
Let's scam for a helmet as well, I think. Uh, evasion helm. What do we got? 120 life res. I'm kind of down for that. Yeah, sure why not. I want to replace blood rage is what I'd like to do. Flame dash. I do need a flame dash somewhere. I have 36 chromes. I think I'll be all right then. Let's make sure I have enough accuracy, though, cuz I know my current home gives me accuracy. 4200. All right, I think I'm f. Cool. And I wanted to go frenzy. Where's frenzy at? Did I buy a frenzy? I don't
remember. Barrage support. No, no, no. We're good. Uh, we're going to go frenzy support or frenzy gem. Another mana forged arrows. Then we're going to place the blood rage. This way we have generation on single target. Let's make sure we're res kept. I'm missing a lot of lightning res at the moment. How many castles do I have? Eight. That's fine. I can craft res on this helmets. Lightning res. And yeah, we're kept. All right, cool. And this amulet. Uh, we can I mean, we could craft res. I
think it's fine. Uh, ideally like to be able to replace one of these. What about the quiver? Nothing. This craft a res technically doesn't craft like some sort of damage, right? Yeah, some sort of lightning damage. Could do face converted as well. We don't really do that much though. This is like kind of silly, but technically works. All right, just get back into maps is what I need to be doing though. Go to pinky dick. Uh maybe a mark on hit. Not sure. Oh, you know what would be good is
linking my uh weapon to be a fourlink and throwing that on it. Yeah, that would be nice. Let's just start running every map. No to mankind. Do I have any Kurrick maps? some maps, please. Thank you. Dunes, flooded mines, dungeon. All right, probably ran them before the tier rate. What else? Why is there no crit multi? Uh cuz I have precise technique, so I don't benefit from crit at all. I'm frozen. Just mean fully linked items. Would be awkward to find a five or six link for right now. How much
chaos do I have? Minus 16. Dude, I shouldn't be dying to chaos damage. Almost at all. That's kind of chill. Uh, cryptography scarab. Oh. Uh, that's really good to run in these actually. Insanely good to run in these high tier maps cuz we're about to get uh we're about to get unwavering, which means that we can never put uh scarabs on the map again. Yeah, it's pretty good. Scour are also nice. Aldrich eye. Cool. How much suppression do I have? I have 90%. Okay, so I just need 10% more. That's it.
That's what you're saying. I don't know how to get a clean 10% though. I know to get like five and five or like eight and eight, but I don't know how to get more than that. If I get the other scarab wheel or the other wheel, I think it solves my entire suppression problem. You know what I'm saying? Like if I get this right hand wheel over here, in veterate instead of the other suppression nodes, then I can also take uh reduce damage taken from suppress. And then we are just immune to damage
forever. Damage might be a bit of an issue. Um, yeah, the only thing I want right now are bows and boots. I think everything else is irrelevant. Yeah, I want bows, boots, and completion. That's it. Everything else does not matter. I'd like to get to red maps in the next 20 minutes. That's what we're looking at right now. What else do I need to make the run better? Or link on the boots or just better boots. I'll just wait for gamble boots. I'm not just yet. I hate those seared searing touch with a
good item. RF two stone chad. I kind of want to do an RF run. I don't think that'll be anything insane, but I know it's a very favorite archetype. Uh, okay. There's less than 50 mobs remaining. We didn't find a map. Little sad. Grab suppress. Where' the boss go? The boss like disappeared on me. It's probably following one of these like little side areas, man. It's probably like over here and then it Nope. Nope, it's not there. Um, I don't know where the boss could
be. Boss is so weird, man. I don't think it's in the middle or anything. It's got to be connected to one of these and it's there's like some giant pathway. Where is this boss? It's up. Oh, I see it. I see it. Yeah. Okay. Just a little dick piece right here. My bad. I didn't see that. We got like 10 mobs remaining after this. That arm sucks. I don't really want to use chaos to spam these. Ow. These guys being ghosted is really toxic. I don't like that at all. Okay, potentially do boots. Stand behind
Solaris to dodge your spear throw. Stop alg me. Stop it. There's no way we're going down in map tears. Although, we're not like popping off in the collision barn right at the second, so I think it's whatever. There's 30 mess dual res. Do I just take those? I'm down. And that guy. Amen. You did the best. Uh, we lose a bit of evasion, quite a bit of life, a little bit of suppress, but we do gain 30 MS. Yeah, I mean, why not? Just look for completion in these maps. Nothing else. Six socket.
Look like it translates directly to fusings. I want it. I think it's over here, right? The boss. I see. I've already got I need that dunes as well. Special defenses. Just make sure there's no reflect on the map. That'll instantly kill me. Yep. Oh, wait. You know what? The map tab that I have isn't even functioning. It wasn't even turned on. There's probably somebody out there that noticed that like half an hour ago and they tried to say something and I just was not paying attention. Okay, let's
try to get four sockets on this. Fix the colors up a bit. And I want and haste and snipers mark to be over here and angel to be over here. And I want to go crafted life on the boots. Crafted life 69. Nice. I want to get a heater currency on the chest. Fizz taken as lightning. And then I also want mark hits. Thank you. Cool. Now we have way less buttons to press, less slow presses. Good stuff. Yep. Chat, I don't see any cold damage on his gear. You only need two. Uh, typically lightning is always one of them. So, you
can high roll lightning. also like the base jam and just having on us enough to proximity. Yeah, we're good. This is what T2. So, we just run in kill the map boss, I guess. Well, now yeah, I guess so. Marches. Have I completed the marshes? I have not. long as it not reflect, it's perfectly fine. This should be like an easy one, two, three. You know what I'm saying? And I don't want to overdo it on the completion. So, let's try to move up a map tiers. I should have grabbed these
before they ran the T8. Let's grab every adjacent node. No to mankind. We got a few more to go. Do you have the mana? Yep, we sure do. It only cost 62 mana. In which case, I actually do kind of want to go uh like cap on that. Let's link it up with the boots. Link her over here. Beast over here. And this is like probably my last one of my last gene map. Oh, I never ran that scarab. I never ran that scarab. I threw it away. Well, it's gone now. And like I said, this is like one of my last uh
June maps. So hopefully we get endurance charge on kill. That would help out survivability tremendously. If not, I mean, I guess I just die. See? Yeah. No, we're not getting that. It's not happening. But this is life cap actually. Oh. Oh, I need that red socket though. And I don't have a way of getting like another green on the helmet, I don't think. Not really. I mean, I could go frenzy, man, arrow, life tap, and something else. What else can I get on that? Take it all out here. Dead. Got
138 decks. I mean, it's not impossible to get one red, one blue. Like we have enough mana for the mana gain for the mark on hit, but it's like just a little weird. Everything else we got here. Let's try to get the uh red socket then. I guess I need a blue and a red with 35 chromes. It's doable. All right, we got it. Poor Linked. Could I get two red on this? Would that even make sense? No, it wouldn't. Well, it could make sense. I'm down to yolo it. Got 28 fusings or 28 chromes.
Two red. Nope. Land a blue red. Plant a blue red again. I got it. All right. Now, we need a three link. I think we got it. Reason I wanted that is so I could life tap this set up. That way these don't cost mana and that way we don't have any constraints whatsoever. And now we just basically run every hydra that we own. Yeah. Yeah. Let's just send it. I don't care to even look at these items. Sure. Whatever. Man have the build. Uh, this is a copy of Havoc 616 build. I need to game. Oh my
goodness. A T5 T7 from this. Yeah, mana is a lot nicer now. Stop looking at that, please. Thank you. Prominade. All right. Like to see that. Actually, it's not Ellie reflect. Okay, we're good. All these gems here. Oh, you know what I really want to do though? Take out these suppresses. Lucky. And then take this entire wheel. And let me make sure that even with life tab, I still have 100% suppress. I do. Okay. So, I don't need suppresses. Lucky. We're taking less damage from suppressed spells. Hang on.
How much do I have? 4,200. All right. Hell yeah. Okay. We set up absolutely everything. And I don't know how I managed to do that. Consider I can have a six in either one. Either my weapon or my chest. If I really wanted to, I could gamble a new bow. That'll probably be the biggest upgrade I could possibly find. Tier sevens. Nope. Nothing. Yeah, suppress cap and a two stone is wild. Definitely don't need to do that. And I definitely lost quite a bit of time doing it, but allows me to do stuff like this.
Real stupid stuff. Chateau map. Okay, I should be popping off. Like I said, I want to be in red map soon. Should be good. What do we got? Weapons. Probably not going to be what I want. full attention to you. We shall see how far I have grips. Type something to scare me quickly. What is he time? 3 hours and 1 minute. Something like that. 2 minutes. What do you need to do? So, uh, right now we're trying to get to like T8 through like tier 11 maps. that will allow us to put like exark reader influence onto maps. Basically, it just
add some monsters and some alters onto the maps. And XR and Eater are only interested in maps of a certain like tier. So once you put in a like tier 9 map of a with a boss, so like I'm going to put in this um arachnid tube. Uh, Xark has no interest because we already ran tier eight on XRP. Get a little bit more adjacent chance. So, Xark has no interest in this tier eight. So, what I'm hoping for from this tier eight is to drop a tier 9. So, I drop a tier nine, then I put Xark influence on that. And we just keep
doing like tier 9, then we drop a tier 10, put in the tier 10, and XR's interested in it. So, we run that. We just want to keep going up and up and up all the way to T16. And we want to do that for both Exark and Eater. At tier 11, we have to fight two like different kind of bosses. One of them's the Shrek boss. The other one's the uh uh hot cold boss. I'll explain how that mechanic works when we get there. Prescript. Is that the map I'm looking for? No, that's minus one
actually for mission. Bounce on it. No, you're a absolute psych. I mean, yeah, you could go for uh the other watch stones technically. Sure. Um I don't recommend that, but that is an option. We got an immortal flesh. If I was an RF build right now, I'd be popping off. I'd be ulting. But yeah, the biggest problem and the biggest constraint with these runs is going to be red maps. It's pretty much always red maps. The watch stones increase the chance of you dropping a higher tier map by
25% on for each watch zone you have. So getting two of them means that you pretty consistently drop red maps. And without having winning watch stones, well, you're not, you know, you might be struggling quite a bit. So, oh my goodness, my HP. That's why we got the life. Okay. Uh, yeah, I don't think we're missing anything else gear wise. We just kind of send Haunted Mansion. Tier 9. I will grab bows. Bows could be good. Tier 9 map. What do we got? So, like I said, XRX interested in a tier 9
map. This both a wash. Cool. Gigachad minion run. There's no such thing as a gigachad minion run. I'm not a minion cuck, so I don't know how to do those kind of runs anymore. I did a bam run. That was a good build. Let's prevent 3% of spell dam. There's six chancellors in this. There is a small chance that this is going to be good for me. Met actually needed completion very low though easy recon yogurts I don't know what that is I'm using raw archer I have uh lighting arrow returning frog marcher
trigger you can see the giant green thing above my head he like scared me for a quarter of a second and then I remembered that I could just look above my head and it's right there so from this tier nine we're hoping for a tier And uh we went down. I've got minus one. I said Marger is not a minion, guys. Okay. And I will not believe any propaganda that says otherwise. Take a spine bow. Essence it actually kind of good. It landed fire damage and plus one gems. Wait a second. Nope. No questions. I'm not
taking any. Nope. Grow up. I just died. I got owned. How much damage is this? 28,000. Okay. Yeah, that's a bit of a DPS loss. Yeah. Karma. Nope. That doesn't exist. Stop alkal. Stop it. Ow ow ow ow ow. I'm dying. Help. Where's that mob at? We got a revenge. Nerf bows. Troop. Ow. Yep. 30 mobs remaining and no plus one map. That's fine. What do we have? Um I want a high tier map. I want a tier. The highest tier I have. The highest tier I have is a tier eight, I guess. Sure. Do I have
any yellow cur? I do. Before I do that, let's put in a tier 10. In fact, I'm not even going to open that. I'm not going to bother with the tier eight cuz I've got another one right here. See the tier 10. Hopefully from this tier 10 we drop at tier 11. That would be the best that we could hope for. Might be able to buy one something from Kira. Special move. Yeah, it's my good use out of Kick though. You stuck on bow runs. This is the final run ever. Trust me, for real this time. Didn't I have a high quality
life blast? I think I did. Probably rolled that. How far back in the past? It would have been so far back in the past that the VODs aren't saved from that. Sorry. Unless they were saved, but I don't think I did. So, yep. We can ask questions for the run. I mean, let's be honest, this league is 11 months long. You can type exark series and it'll come up with the Google doc. No, not that one. The other Google doc about uh or sorry, the spreadsheet. It'll come up with the four storm runs
that I did this league. I think it's even mentioned in my uh my tier list video, man. Oh, snap. We got tier 11. Uh yeah, that's that's good. It's good enough for me. So for another one or something. A tier 10 would be good. So then I don't have to waste one of the missions. But it's not bad. Could drop another tier 11 off the boss obviously. So, I'm going to chisel this. My scarves are completely useless. My scarf's just completely garb on. So, I'm going to hold on to this and hold on to that. And
if I wanted completion, I'd run the dudes. I don't think I really do. I mean, it's going to take me 30 seconds to go for that map boss for some adjacent chance. Sure, dude. Why not? Oh, you know what isn't full length actually is my uh artillery blast is not full length. So, it's missing some damage. My bad. No bow or no no map. Sad. Why don't you upload your runs to YouTube? Uh cuz they're usually garbage. Usually I'm just like having fun. It's like just a lot more fun to hang out
with a video than it is to like really try hard. This is the first run that I felt like pretty Rrated. I don't think it'll be anything groundbreaking, but it'll be good enough to throw on the on the tubes. Usually, I'm embarrassed of this thing or another. You like garbage. All right, fair enough. I want to chisel alk and probably not evolve. We'll just chisel an elk. Yeah, it's too early to devolve for me. Even though we don't get completion for it, it's still fine. SL
here. There we go. Imagine W. That would be a huge announcement. I don't think that would just be like a random QL teaser. I think you're uh I think you're cooking a little too hard. I I don't think that'll be a thing. I'm just got to be real with you right now. Oh, is that a T12? Oh, it's the 10% quality that I put on the map. I knew it. Um, I am going to have to be careful though of doing uh aling these maps cuz putting on too many scary mods will definitely kill me.
And not like slowly either. My mana is gone. Oh, you know what? I'm still using my like giga early game leveling filter even though I'm like the red maps. I was like, I'm seeing so many items, but I'm not sure why. Yeah, that kind of makes sense, huh? Whoops. Why am I seeing so much? Another T12. Wow. Amazing. And hopefully we just plus one everything from here on out and finish the run in the next half an hour. I'm aiming for sub 530. That's kind of my goal for the run. I think it's pretty doable if I'm
able to stay in T12s. Barrel. No, it's so hot. Thanks, bro. Appreciate that. Six socket. Six socket. I mean, I don't think I'm gonna do better than my current chest. Just be realistic. All right. Single target's going to suffer a lot because I do not have Uber Lab. And I found out that Uber Lab is just like minus 12 minutes to the run. But there's time for the trial. There's time for the run. You got to like go through the whole thing. T12. Wow. Okay. Okay. T12. I could run that on a
dude. Seems like a stupid idea, though. It's cuz it is a stupid idea. Where are these nodes even going, man? I have no idea. Where's P? Help. All right, it's time to stop yoloing their own. What do we What do we actually need? Hang on. Uh, these are some good essences of throwing bows. You want Take that mastery. Yep, I got that mastery. Heart of oak. I guess if I just want more life. Basically, I want to be able to survive auto attacks from Exark and Eater. The problem isn't going to be
spells. It's going to be getting auto attack to death. That's going to be the problem. Those mobs absolutely slap. So, got to plan around that. Ow. Good essences. Get our inner influence. And I believe I believe this is the exark boss, the mini demi boss. I want to say it is, but I could totally be wrong. Nicely and my scour on opal ring. Interesting. All right. Nemesis and a mage blood. No, I don't think we do. A five link would be nice. I won't argue with that. Tier 11. Okay. Uh heater does need
that. Another tier 11. Okay. Eater does need that. Looks sub six to me. Yeah. Yeah, I mean if it's not sub six, it's I'm doing something horribly wrong. The question is, can we sub 530? Breaking world records. Maybe I don't know if Havoc is a sub five, but that sounds like something Havoc would do. Out. I got to f up. Hoping for a plus one map of some kind. Looks like a massive sub. What do you mean? Better runs your reds without completion. Yeah. Uh so we run out of all orbs like super fast by corrupting
maps. So we kind of like save them for like wow I am like desperate for plus one. Another thing is the only map mod that is dangerous here is well I mean besides the damage is uh damage is extra chaos like that map mod alone can and will kill us and as you saw I mean we just died to chaos. I mean I died to me being stupid right? But there's a lot of like map mods like that. Yep. We got the invitation. But as you can see there's like there's like a handful of map mods that'll just straight up kill us. If we
get a bad combination of those we brick the map. The map is gone. But we can't run in anymore without dying six times, right? Uh it's not safe to say that because um even though you kill so much, you just die so much that you end up losing time, right? The time that you lose like like if you're playing a slams build and you just do Oh, I'm going to die actually. I need to log. I didn't realize I was standing in the wrong side. My bad. The way this fight works, the way this fight works is that
you stand in one side to build up resistances against that attack. So like for example, I'm going to stand in the cold side. It's going to build a fire res. And then I can just tank this uh fire beam. I'm going to kind of shuffle between the both of them a little bit here and there. And then now I'm going to stand in the fire one. And the reason I'm standing in the fire one is to build up cold res for Astral Avalanche. Now I won't die to that anymore. Yeah, my damage is horrendously bad. Um,
maybe I switch over to barrage. Yeah, that would be good. That would be smart. I am kind of down for that. Oh, you know what node I don't have that I really should have besides part of oak. Are the mark nodes? Yeah, the mark nodes are a lot of damage. Kind of forgot about those, huh? I think about it. Yeah, my damage is a lot worse than it was yesterday. I mean, if the boss wants to like do some weird bugging out and not actually move anywhere, whatever, dog. Give me that skill point. Thank
you. That's another plus one adjacent. And I believe we're just looking for the T12s trying to move up in the world. We do transmute these maps. We don't want them white. Um, ideally the maps do drop more maps. That's that's ideal. Uh, no uber lab. So, single target is going to suck. Yeah, another problem with uber lab is uber lab also gives a lot of gem quality. Can I find any of these? I need two more ins. That's h that's interesting. Oh, you know what? Angel hasn't been leveling up for the last 20
levels. So, now it's level 13. Way to go. I died. I don't even know how I managed to do that. I stopped leveling up 20 years ago and it should be level 19 right now instead of level 13. Okay. I have made a grave mistake. That makes sense why I'm missing so much flat damage. Any bless uh for the amulet? No, I used them earlier. Play storm raid. Uh I like artillery blister or sorry, I like mana for heroes more than artillery blister, but you'll notice that I'm using both because my single target
sucks so bad that I need to use the crutch of using both things at once. I go to the content creators uploading builds before patch notes. If there's speculation, that's fine. If somebody's like, "Hey guys, here's my trickster lightning strike." Then, yeah, maybe that guy has brain damage. But if somebody's like, "Hey, I am planning on playing this build." I don't see any wrong with that. I do think that it's in the clickbaby era, but like as a content creator,
there's not much else that you can do besides just speculate and just say like, "Hey, I hope something like this is cool and I cooked up this idea, you know, for my starter." Like, I have a good idea what my starter will be, but obviously it can completely change. Respect the hustle. Yeah, as long as it's not like you guys need to play this. If there's like the best build of PoE 3.26 before patch notes, then like yeah, that guy it should blow up. Especially if it's a build that is
100% getting nerfed. Like if you throw uh any sort of trickster like power siphon mines at me, I'm just going to laugh in your face. I'm putting this stuff away, I think. Stop alkaling me, guys, please. Uh, I'm going to gamble some bows. Maybe I get something cool. That could be kind of cool. That bow sucks. All right, never mind. Why even have heist markers, man? What's the point? Oh, wait a second. 25,000 or 27,000? Oh, yeah. That's a banger right there. Flat fire damage craft on that.
Holy. Yeah, that's a winner for sure. 20 qu baby. 20 qu. I need like five sockets though, don't I? Yeah, I actually do need five sockets. That's really awkward. What's this way? Plus two. I don't know if I can get the other flat fire craft. [ __ ] This is actually really awkward that I needed to be five socketed. Cuz now I waste a lot of time doing this. Hopefully I don't roll over it. That would be awkward. Lock in. I did it. All right. Four link. One, two. Perfect. Oh, wait. Does this actually
need to be three length and two lengths? Wait a second. I think it does. Actually, it needs to be weird like that. C multi sub. It doesn't matter. It doesn't change anything. Actually, those are not the links. It needs to be like Okay, wait. Hang on. It actually needs to be very specific. I only have two more. Oh, yeah. It needs to be like that. 21,000 to 24,000. It's the world's smallest upgrade, but the reason why I want this cuz I can craft fire damage. It's from silo. Yeah, that's
why. So, from 25,000 to 30,000. There we go. That's a substantial DPS increase. I will take that any day of the week. What if this one's better? That would be awkward. No, it's not. All right. Cool. All right. Throwing these in the garbage. Garbanzo. Okay. Courthouse. Did I finish the map? I want to say I didn't kill the boss. He's throwing. Wait, what do you mean? The only throwing I would be doing would be closing this map. That would be an insane throw. That would be a freaking air
ball. All right. All right. How do I stop dying? Chaos orbs. Yo, I'm down. Uh, you know what? Let's change over to the real filter now. Hang on. Where's the real filter at? Feel the DPS difference. It's pouring through my veins. Ow. Ow. Ow. Okay. So, uh, well, considering crit requires like 15 different nodes to be good, we're just going to stay PT the entire time. Swords here. That's kind of nice. I got to drop me a map. Drop me nothing. This guy's shield charge will probably
kill me. I guess that took way longer to kill than I would like. And it also didn't draw me a map. So the loot filter. It's on my uh Discord. Not this filter though. This one's private. I'm a f gun. All right. Let's back it over to Mark nodes. I'm really sad that my angel is level like 13, though. That's probably the biggest mistake that I made. It's not up that job. Yeah, that adds a lot of flat fire damage that I'll just never see again, sadly. Unfortunate. What can you do?
What do I end the encounter? I don't really think there's like that many jewelry pieces that could be better than my current thing, you know? I don't know. My current setup. I need a T13 is what I need. Just leveling up a little bit by bit. You have a pet build. Minion build. Uh not playing minion builds. Yeah, that's probably the best one that I played. Anything that isn't minions. I mean, Jardian is cool because it gets the the big RF guy. That's probably the best minion leveling you
can ask for. It's just a giant Saiyan that burns Lost Creed. Rotor is not a minion. We're not discussing this. Taste of cornbread in my mouth. It's not a bad taste, but taste. Yo, where are the maps? Hello. I need an adjacent T13. Please plus one. Your family's worried about you. Um, do I have missions? I don't know. How have I not dropped in map? I think I have to clear a bit more. I mean, I don't want to go back down to tier 11s. Really? That would kind of suck. Okay, we're have to go back down.
Yeah, to go back down. I have to clear more. I need to be less than 50 mobs remaining. Uh-oh. Uh, Volide Arero, save me. Please don't have reflect on. All right, we're good. 50% res, huh? P2 map drop technology. I don't think it's coming to our game. Got to be real. Chance of me dropping aside or a map from here is like one in a trillion. And then even on top of that, there's also the fact that like I can't drop a T13 even though airs are plus one zones cuz there's just nothing cuz this this
is a side. like not even connected, you know. So, we're kind of living on a pair right now. Yeah, I got nothing. All right. Um I guess I'm going back down to tier 11s. That definitely sucks. Unless Unless I am unleash. We got mobs over here. Got mobs. Oh, we're less than 50 mobs remaining. Oh, no. We do have a red mission. I don't really want to waste it on a T13 though. That would kind of suck. Have much of a choice though. We're going to run this tier 11 and then we're
going to run the other tier 11. Just see where it takes us. See what [Music] happens. Let's take this. How much accuracy? We got up. How's the res kept and minus 16 still? Wonderful. Splendid. You like Oh, yeah. I think specialist will say I'm like 99% confident on that. It would be weird for them to have a currency auction house and then be like, "Oh, by the way, psych, we're removing that." Also, you won't be able to gamble at them. Uh, white cur won't help us to
reset the shop. That won't help me in the situation cuz it won't sell 21 T13s off deck cuz our Atlas completion is what it the shop is based off of. So, it won't uh offer me stuff since I don't have a death completion. Start offering more stuff. Necropolis tier 12. Love to see it. All right. Do we just run that then? Yeah. With the cur mission. I think we have some safety here. Sure. Oh, we have two missions now. Oh, yeah. Big available to gamble. Uh, it should be available to gamble. I mean, that's
how it works in PE 2. It was a testing feature for PE 2, I think. So, it'd be kind of weird if it just wasn't offer. Actually, I should kill every rare. We need a T13. And right now, not a tier six. Tier 13. It's kind of chilly in my room. Definitely feeling the coals. It's a little nifty in here. My dream for one of the quality lives was remove on death effects. What is this weapon? Oh, it's one of those weird ones off screen though. This you can get spun locked by that guy really easy.
Plus one all max res. What? Attack speed 200% global damage. H I don't think that's going to be very good on my bow build for some reason. Not sure what I got a pure map. Is that adjacent to this? It is that are we minus one? When I say that I plus one or minus one, we have so many map has a chance to drop an adjacent node that it will either drop the adjacent map that's a higher tier or an adjacent map that's a lower tier. So when I say that we minus one, I mean that we went down in the map
tier. Oh, okay. We won plus one. There we go. That's huge. Is this a Shakira infused? Yeah, Shakira touch. I'm going to clear a little bit more of the map down bad and get version build. You can do T7s. Yeah, when you get mage blood um from farming Legion for two days straight, you can do T7s. Yeah, that's you wish a hero would what? That's a vanish, dude. It's called settlers, not visitors. A med blood neiod bow. Yeah, I mean it's the number one reason why Pub Gun complains about bows. I mean, not only
are you super squishy, which I guess we aren't in this run, but you're just Oh, is that another 213? We are winning at the moment. Winning streaking. Hips don't lie. My hips definitely are not lying. Don't I have a Oh, have I had this infus? Have I had this boss fight the whole time? I hope not. That would be kind of bad if I had the boss fight for a long period of time. Let's grab these up. I only have three walls, so I'll take them for now. has a point though. What do you mean by
that dog? Oh, you know what? Where's that barrage support at? Instead of return barrage, let's put barrage on cuz like 100% more single target on this buildest with spell suppress cap. Can I tank this? I can. I can't tank this though. That suck. Follow me. Move. Oh, it does like do some weird thing where it like instantly flips around. I don't know why it does that. Get me out. I don't want to be here anymore. Stop. I not concerned. All right, we're good. Uh, we want to move in the direction of the the
garbage, the pooper. Bung 3:00 a.m. I'm sorry to hear that. Does this reach? If it does, I'm dead. Bunger. No coal. Unfortun hate this boss. I don't know anybody that likes this boss. This is probably one of the worst designed bosses in Pv1. All right, we need to kill this boss before the uh the fog rolls in. I see it, dude. The fog. The fog is coming. All right, we log out cuz it's actually faster than waiting for the fog to roll away. You have a life tab in every setup pretty much. Yeah. How could you chill?
Was the fact that I'm like permanently dying? Maybe. Maybe. All right, we got T13s. Love to see it. Let's go and involve one of these. Hope for a T14. Didn't land it. Uh, that's a T11 though, isn't it? Where's the other T13? They don't have two. Oh, it's the arcade. It's this one right here. All right. Hoping for a T14. And we didn't land either one. That's fine. They're both good. Push Xark. Hoping for a T14 first. I need to grab that gem back. What if I dropped it on the ground and
then just left it there? That would have been bad. Okay. You're looking life bar ping ponging. Amen, brother. Amen. All right, let's get to that T16. Juicy juicy T16 number. You know, I don't think I found a trial. So, if I was looking for U overlap, but I could be really mad right now. Got two Kurick missions. The higher tiers we go, the better our Kurick will be. If it's T15 on the Kurick mission, then that's perfect cuz then it can drop T16s. That's when we want to use red
maps. The best time to use red maps, I should say. This basically 90% of the run comes down to can we get two tier 16s for the run. If we can then enjoy we win. Well, obviously we need 215s with oil, but you know, you get the idea. All right. So, plus one time login. Ever play Path of Exile 2? Um, when there's a new season. Yeah. Uh, the problem with Path of Exile 2 is it's not a game that I'll ever play off stream. Like I played a few maps off stream and I went, "What am I doing?"
Dude, P1 is actively so much fun that I will like stream for 12 hours straight on like a few days after League start and then I'll just want to sit there and farm maps for like another 4 hours while I watch like YouTube content. The whole time I'm playing PvE 2, I'm like, "Okay, how do I make the next YouTube video? How do I make more money from this, you know? Like, it's like the the problem I have with content creators, but I'm the problem now. Okay, mark damage. Beautiful. Get rid of
assassin." No, assassin's beautiful. You leave assassin alone. That damage is not looking so hot though. So something on this. Oh, it's monsters have endurance charges and 40% boss life. Also 40% of life is extra ES. Oh, we minus one. Yeah, I think we minus one. Unlucky. And then what do we have besides that? We should have T12s. That's it. Jonathan Stan. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Oh, I never said that. Guys, guys, guys, come on. All right, I'm feeling sick in my stomach. I
got a forbidden tome. Is it time? The sanctum pivot. Drop two divines into buy the watch stones. More necropolis maps than I know what to do with. Yo, Pac is loading up the run right now. What's he playing? Dot chaos blob. Holy. He's doing it. I'm dying. I'm dying. I'm going. I'm a little sad that I wasn't able to get a plus one charge ring, but it's a really nice mod to have. The D charges are OP, dude. And because I have no fizz mitigation at all. I want the T14. Beautiful. Hang on.
I I see your question. I don't know if I can answer that. It looks like a really good bow. I want to get into PvE one next patch as a new player. I'm afraid I'll be over one at the end game content. I don't know where to start. Uh start by picking a build off like some tier list and just literally play the game. That's it. You don't have to be a master of everything. Uh, I feel like as soon as you understand that 99.9% of players that play this game will not understand even a small fraction of the game and
most players are just talking out of their ass and they know nothing. As soon as you realize that, it'll feel a less overwhelming. It's kind of like how being an adult is like a really scary and daunting experience and then you realize that everybody's just faking it and nobody really knows what the [ __ ] is going on and somebody way dumber than you is in some position of power and they're deciding how you live your life. It's kind of like that except it's Jonathan and uh you
know projectors are fired or random direction. All right. Stop peing. Yeah. I mean, it's just one of those games you play for 10,000 hours, then you're like, "Oh, I didn't know that was a mechanic." Oh, I'm learning. I hope I didn't put eater on the last map. I hope not. Hang on. 35,000 to 18,000. Yeah, I'm not wearing that. Oh, maybe it's because this might give my accuracy up just cuz the thing. Yeah. Okay, maybe. Who knows? Give me the kills back, please.
Thank you. Um, I believe that was the last of the completion that I needed. Use this anymore. Take this, I guess. Oh man, I started feeling really sick to my stomach all of a sudden. Hopefully I don't throw up. That'd be really awkward in the middle of my room. It's a new League. Um, well, the title says that it comes out on June 13th. So yeah, man. It's live. It's live right now. All your friends are playing. You're missing out on it. That's right. You're missing out.
They're all making fun of you. They were actually messaging you saying like, "Wow, it's really cringe that that our friend isn't joining." T is the only one streaming it. That's right. There definitely would not be 25 times the viewers if uh the pee patch was live. It could be June 13th right now. Imagine if you could bank sleep. So you just sleep until patch notes, wake up for a few hours, then sleep until leak start, then obviously for like two weeks. How many you guys
would do that? My advice is don't play this game and get buried instead. The majority of players of this game are not buried and they are borderline autistic. Excuse me. Borderline low. Um. Oh, you're required by your job to sleep bank 80% of your weekend. Oh god, you're right. I didn't think about that. The profit incentive. That's like, hey Jim, I know you put your time off for that day so you can spend time with your vacation. Yeah, we're going to need you to sleep bankank that one for us.
Thanks. Yeah, I mean it's just it's tax season. You get it? Hey, bud. I am married to a skilled gem. All right. I mean, it's better than some 2D waifu. I mean, that would be really embarrassing. Or yo, we dropped T15. I think I'm winning. I think we're up. Uh, drop to T15 and then we can cure it up if we need more maps. Um, I mean, there's just a chance that we just space glow up to T16. I'm going to grab the quantity. Um, it will meteor the hell out of us, so we can just straight up
die. Um, one meteor will probably kill us, I guess. But six royal bow. I mean, I got some banger essences, bro. I don't think you know who you're talking to. kind of the goat right now. All right, drop another T15 for me. Be a doll. That would be real sweet. I could even go barrage support here if I want to the return. Where's the boss at? He's gliding on me, dude. Oh, I can I not name lock him if it's like far away? He's actually like glad. Den for life. Amen. Please. Uh, we went minus one to
T13, but it's fine cuz we also got the other map. So, uh, are you interested in T13, though? No. I don't know if I skipped one of the maps. I don't know if it's interested in T14. Let's hope that it's interested in just a T15. I don't know. I have some essences here. Let's take them. That's pretty interesting. That's a lot of lighting. I think that was just the essence though, is it not? No. I'm looking for something like absolutely incredible. Oh, it's I2. I
thought it was I3. Okay. Well, I just wasted like 60. All right. All good. High percentage of players going to have a similar hideout. I have no idea. I imagine that you guys are going to probably be trading with a lot of people with this hideout, though. I mean, we can't all get in trouble, right? If we're all using the hideout dude, I am like permanently dying to CBT. I should have placed in a portal, man. Um, I have a life flask. Let's get this. Let's throw the last two claw on it. I need like
bubbling or instant and then CBT removal. Yeah, I got to stop running that. Like freeze, I can like kind of live through that. CBT, not so much. All right, there we go. So, it's 150 more life or something like that. And it's also going to give me bleed removal. So, I stopped dying to that. I'm not up to that just yet. Like I honestly don't know where all the bleed is coming from, but I'm sure I'll forget someday. I'm picking up too many things again. I think I'm probably pretty sure I'm
picking up too many things. Foundry tier 11. Uh let's hope for tier 16. It would be dope if we get one watch just right off the rip. Just rip the bandit off. I guess the reason why blood uh what's it called? why CBT and why bleeding just absolutely owns me is because um even though I want to take more damage while moving, I have so many life capab setups that have just kind of kill me as this runs away. Yeah, this is fleas. Nasty mod. Um, you know, I don't want to run either one of those actually. Those both
sound awful. Even though the little minion guys could draw me T16. 600 chaos damage per second doesn't seem very good when I have negative chaos res. Yeah, being in the negatives like that seems horrible. You're not a what, fub, bro? I've seen your I've seen your history. You want me to pull up the DMs right now? I'm down, bro. We can go banan for banan right now. DM for DM. Caught minus mana. I mean, I guess we're pulling up the waharu. I mean, you need that map for completion anyways. So,
what are these emotes? I have no idea. Somebody kept adding them. It's like a rogue mod or something. I think his name like Fub Gun or something like that. Okay. No clue. Wasn't me, though. It was not me. Like, look at all those emotes, dude. Every single one of them. Level 82. Uh, I mean, we could get coal. What else can I get? Uh, a little bit of life. Never heard nobody, right? Little bit more HP. I mean, a lot of time when I'm living, I'm like barely alive. My mana is gone. Ow. See, barely alive.
Uh, I mean I could get life blast. No, it's too many charges away unfortunately. Would be cool to get life plus charges or like sustenance. The life gain on hit from that is like actually a cheat code if I'm able to path out there. Problem so many points to do that. A residence are minus one super hard. Airbolt. All right. Tier 14. As long as it doesn't have reflect on it, it's fine. That is a bit of a stinker though. You hate to go down in map chairs like that. Demon, stop staring at me, dude.
Stop staring. What are you looking at? There's nothing to look at here. All right, we're hoping for another tier 15 from this. Otherwise, we're going to be real sad. That hide out. Sweet. Tax hide out. You would like it for free and some P1 my HP. We're good. How was uh what were we playing? You were playing Elden Ring Night Range. Am I mistaken? I was keeping up, dude. I was I was watching a little bit. How does he know? How was that going? Caldera, did we just minus one again? No way,
dude. No way. We went from a T15 to a 14 to a 13. See what I'm saying? only minus one doll. If you don't even play League, you don't even know what that means. All right, stop minus oneing. Night Room is so fun. You guys talk like it's in the past. Like, man, remember when Night Ring came out? Bro, the game came out like two days ago. You don't know my life. I know your life. And your life says [ __ ] League of Legends. That game is trash. You said I've seen what that game
has done to people and I will never play that game. Okay, stop base ging my friend. Stop that. More alchemies. I mean, there's no way I struggle with alchemies at this point. I have said that. Yep. You're a legalizing survivor. I'm sorry to hear that you have true peace. See, what's what's messed up is I got addicted to the game and now I've got like not like urges or anything, but like you know that feeling of like, wow, I just absolutely [ __ ] on the enemy top laner and I froze the lane for the next
5 minutes and he just typed FF for the next four minutes straight. Like, man, there's no there's no feeling quite like that in any other game. Um, you know, I don't really want to die on this map, so I'm just going to run it a lot easier. Okay, it gets real awkward if I don't get anything from this. People still care about pro play. There's still pro play. What has the highest down vote comment notes, comment ratios? What is that, the League subreddit? Imagine pressing Q E ignite R as Garen.
Or I can imagine playing a champer that actually requires some skill. You know, like Trendir for example. I could just full yellow this T16 and hope I drop another one. We don't have to kill the map boss with T15. I'm down just to clear most of it. Yeah, we should have one more 16 and then we go fight two bosses. In fact, I could just go into this T16. and just full send anyways. That is an option. How much more of this T15 do I want to clear? Oh yeah, cuz walking into Ether right now is definitely
viable. Are we looking at Wreck? I don't know, man. I don't know. I can't tell. Lorlo clip. Holy. Lolo is a name I haven't heard in a while. I don't know why, but I feel like I ran into Lorlo in solo Q a lot. I don't know if he did like a lot of like weird challenges and like master GM. But yeah, I don't really want to fight this boss. Be real. Another porcupine. All right, we got our T16. Can I regen? It's a little annoying. Sure. And I don't have any of the T15s, so yeah, it's it's all on you,
little guy. It's all on you. It's time to win. Hopefully I didn't mess up the uh the map tiers anywhere. There is a small chance that I just like missed one. Like if I accidentally put in a tier 15 when Eater requires a tier 14, then technically I could be putting in a tier 16 right now when Eater requires a tier 15. But I would never make that mistake. Right guys? Why guys Garfield so much? I think both will be buffed. I have no idea. They'll probably stay the same. Let's be real. I can't predict what's
going to happen to balance after league has been out for 11 month straight. Going to guard me. What does that even mean? You don't even know what that means. Stop that. I'm dying. It's not M Craig Monday and it's not Gar Monday either. Stop it. If you guys are going to gar at least stand at attention soldiers salute stand up mods ban the garers please All right, at ease soldiers at ease. Darf it up cuz it's not made Monday. Don't believe f guns propaganda. Where the Where's my adjusted or not my adjusted
Where's my adjacent T16 map? I don't know if there's an adjacent T16. I think it's only a T50 maybe. I don't know. It should drop me at least a map though. That's good. No, it's not that kind of Monday either. Uh, quantity and rarity just for a simple 100% more damage mod. Seems easy enough. Give me the map. Give me another T16. Help. Give me a map. Yeah, having 100% spell press is pretty cool. I like that. Uh, any maps? Any maps? Any maps? Any maps? Any maps? Oh, T15. That works,
I guess. Wait, where's my eater boss? Guys, guys, guys. Um, I'm not up to that just yet. Hey, remember when I said if I didn't actually um have the right configuration of missions, it won't drop the uh the invite. Guess remember when I said that? That's really weird. That's Yeah, that's I mean that's really strange. Okay, that's remember when I said that I might only have a T14 mission for this airball. Okay, the Nameless here. What do you got, bud? Give me a mage blood right now
to make up for my sick cos. I'm down. Sure, why not? Ow. Stop. Stop. Stop. My life. You know what? I deserve that. What if it still requires a T15? There's no way it doesn't require a T15. That's kind of wild, dude. That's insane. All right, we have a singular T15. And that's I guess that's pretty much it. If you don't get it, we got to go back to Kiraking. Well, I can't believe I did the thing, but you know what else? Chest. What? We got damage taken recouped. Sure. What do we got on helm?
Uh, landing damage of spells. Sure. What's the ring? Your gloves. I mean, crit chance multi. Yeah, why not? All right, we lost one of the tier 16s that we needed, which really sucks. H, maybe I should have ran the tier 15 Kick and then tested to see. I mean, I didn't know, right? I didn't know. I did the thing. All right, we just need to drop double T16. So, if we drop a T14, I'm going to start crying. Don't do it. Don't do it. Don't do it. Your bag arrived. I don't know what
that means. Enjoy it. I the quests aren't shown. I hide them cuz the quests are really annoying and I Oh, you know what? Actually, the quests do say what map tier you need for them. Oh, yeah. Huh. I guess I could have known and I just died. Proximity shield. Anybody else gonna die? Oh yeah. Proximity shield again. Oh, T16. Never punished ever in my life. GG noobs. GG noobs. All right, that's definitely like minus quite a bit of time. It's definitely minus some aura as well, but losing focus. I am losing a little bit
of focus. I would be lying if I said I wasn't. Is it worth full clearing this map though? I'm down just to kill the boss and go T16 to grab the uh the eater. Getting at least one watch stone is huge cuz then it increases the chance of us finding another T16 by a trillion%. And we could always just cure and yolo T15s or 16s and hope for drop the map or something, right? That is viable, I want to say. Or we just drop the other T16. And then we just go fight both bosses and get both of them out of the way like that. Yeah,
I'm down for that. Let's not forget to uh put the influence on the map. The quest. Just making sure once you 16 influence, man. Let's think about FEM boys. Bro, guess I'm doing that, dude. After the Quinn 69 clip where we were talking about height and I was talking about how I'm not 6 feet and I'm only 5'11 and I'm not going to make it and I need to be a fanboy. That was one snippet of my stream and Quinton just so happened to be tuning in at that one exact moment and he was
like, "Why is this guy always talking about fanboys?" I don't always talk about them. All right. It just shows up more often than others. Uh I accidentally ran this map completely unided and I don't know what's on it. Yeah. Okay. Sure, bud. Oh. Uh I How many streamers do Fenboy? I didn't place a portal, so I had to start the map. That's an alkal minus one minute. Boom. You guys happy? It's distracting me, dude. Not up to that just yet. What is it you like? What is
it that you you don't like? You know what I mean? Okay, I definitely added something to this map that I don't like. Dude, they seem so fast. Am I trolling? Get away from me. Get away. I thought I would survive with, you know, how much suppression I have, but maybe not. Um, wait, am I not suppressing C? 96%. Wait a second. I thought I was suppress capped. Oh, wait. I had the quartz flask on, so it was over capping my supp. Okay, hang on. Where's the other boss at? I need to finish the map
first. I was not a knower. Are boys med? Yeah. So, all right. So, you're telling me that I just so happened to get absolutely owned? Okay, hang on. Do I have any more respawns? I do. I just so happen to get owned during that 4% down. Oh, I maybe should not have ran this before doing uh another map so that I can level up real quick for another level. Oh well, it's fine. I should just be able to full face tank. Um, not quite, brother. Not quite. Uh, I don't I can test and see if we can lift the beam, but I have an idea
of what will happen to me. You know, if I had endurance charges, maybe slotting endurance cry. Uh, I will never survive that attack. That's for sure. Should we test the beam? Should I live the beam? That seems just kind of dumb. I don't think I want to do that. Yeah, I don't want to try. I'm good. Bunger damage. This is the damage that you can expect when you're doing eer X this early on. Also, buff bows. Get off me. My audio. I mean, yeah, slams do unironically do triple the damage, but remember we
skipped over this run. So, I go poop RF damage, but RF is tanky. Yeah, sure, bud. But you're not getting here at 5 hours, you know, on RF. I don't think so. I don't know. Never done an RF red. Stay tuned for the righteous fire run. Oh, get off me. Seek. I can't see where that's going. Oh, I found it. Where's it going to Paris? What's out there? I'm going to do this deathless. Hold up. I got to die really quick so you guys can alfg. That's how this works. It's got to be in like some stupid way,
too. rest. Can you die, please? I don't want to go through another phase. Oh my god, where's the boss saving that? Wait, does it always spawn one tentacle if you're like in some random corner? actually didn't know that. Hold up. Wait a second. Uh, we could fight the jardian. I think Sepok is probably going to be easier. Okay. The watch. There we go. No coal. Yeah. I mean, would be good to throw in a coal support, I guess. Probably better string XR. Really? Can we beat What's the time to
beat? 5:30. I mean, if XRO takes me like seven minutes, bro, then I don't know what to say. I don't have any good flasks here. Should I switch over to a ruby flask? I would love a ruby flask. Um, am I going to level up? Should I level up? Would be nice. Guess so. It has to be good. True. Stop. The phase is lasting far too long. Should I go for the level up? Yeah, I mean, it's going to take me 5 seconds in this G16 considering I'm level 82. Yeah, sure, why not? Okay, it's a lot more than 5
seconds, but basically I'm scared that I'm going to run out of portals in the boss fight because there's a decent chance that I die to an auto attack and there's also a 100% chance that I die to a ball at some point. So, because I die to a ball, I want to reduce the death that I have to auto attacks. Therefore, if I can increase my HP, not just by leveling up, but also by grabbing a big life node, then I will gladly do that. There we go. [Music] three and we should have that invitation. And I want a ruby flask. And
I want like one charge gain on hits. Can I even roll this low? should be able to deal crits. There we go. And then I want the life plus gain charges. Cool. Crafting time. Yep. Time to craft. Grab life node. It's only a small nude. I forgot. Yep. That's I mean that right there is um actually what I was worried about. Just get [ __ ] smacked and uh Yep. Uh all right. Well, just don't let that happen again and we'll be all right, I guess. Just need this guy to absolutely never touch me
ever. Okay, I live that somehow. I don't know how. I can live this with the suppress ruby flask gone. Cannot live the auto attacks though. Word noted. Cool. Absolute s of bose. Um I don't know where the boss is so I got to run away. Disintegration. Cleansing. I kind of need to lock in for this fight, I think. Ah, yeah, my bad. Five ball phases. I mean, the hardest part is going to be surviving a right click from the boss. Okay, one ball face. I should be careful about blinking. I am not alone.
God, disintegration cleansing. Incineration, disintegration, cleansing. She's in pee. The reason it doesn't have damage numbers man screen. Stupid as hell to have damage numbers on screen in my opinion. I always play the muffin Diablo. I put the muff in WoW. The damage numbers is from uh Q just like our calculator. Anyways, so annihilation Okay, buddy. All right. Yeah, sure. Whatever, man. I can't see [ __ ] with Maven being here. I'm dead. Goodbye. Really? Okay, dude. Yeah, I bet. O. Oh, gee. Oh my god, I [ __ ]
moved. We're good. Disintably pressed my life flash like nine times. I like this. Hey, you didn't do a voice line. If I lose sub 530 cuz I don't have coal. Oh man. If I die here, I'm buying coal for sure. I can't see [ __ ] I can't see anything over Maven's toes. Help. Incineration. Kill the boss. I am I'm I'm a [ __ ] I'm leaving. Can I live this? Can I tank that? We're good. All right, we win. Yippee. Um, yeah. So, I spent a lot of time gearing cuz I got a 100%
suppression. The damage is pretty bad if you haven't noticed. Um, yeah, I'll take it. How many deaths do you guys think? How many deaths? Buff bows. Yeah, I mean the the run is great until you realize that like I have one ace the deaths on any melee build. All right, let's see. I think it's going to be in the 30s. That's my guess. I wasn't even close. I wasn't even right. All right, there it is. Thanks for watching on YouTube. Love you guys. See you guys. Uh, Twitch TV/Killer. Tune in, dude. Log
in. Don't forget to like, comment, subscribe. Bye. Bye.